next senate intelligence committee
chairman arlen specter and vice chairman
bob carey and cia director john deutsch
the senator's brief reporters on their
closed door hearing on damage assessment
in the aldridge ames case mr deutch
remarks on the effects of double agents
on the u.s intelligence community
the intelligence committee has just had
an extensive briefing by
director deutsch and
as is our custom vice chairman and i are
prepared to give you
a comment as to
what we saw what we heard
we have had a further
description by the cia about the
scope of damage in the aldrich ames case
and it is much more extensive
than was previously reported
one of the items of enormous seriousness
is that the cia was passing on
information to customers
knowing that the information came from
individuals who were controlled by the
kgb
to repeat they passed on information
from individuals
whose information was tainted
because they were controlled by a
foreign hostile
intelligence source which undermined the
credibility of that information just
totally
and they did not advise the customers
of that situation
and the customers were making purchases
of military equipment
with vast sums of monies involved
and we're making judgments vital to the
national security
and this information went to the
rank of the president of the united
states and other key members of the
defense establishment
so that it's just uh
mind-boggling the scope of
of what went on here
there's a great deal that could be said
let me just make one other comment uh
director deutsch was asked to reconsider
uh the censure the consequences as at
least to
one individual who was still employed by
the
agency and then uh
senator kerry developed a line of
questioning that i'm sure you'll find
interesting
well uh as the chairman said i mean can
you stand by
i'll stand behind almost anything
well as the chairman said there's a
significant failure on a part of the
the central intelligence agency to
uh provide
uh
accurate uh intelligence to the people
who are making decisions all through the
80s and period of the 90s
and it calls
into question
some of the structural things that we do
some of the
ways that we are currently operating the
central intelligence agencies and most
of those questions i cannot answer today
i just
know that i'm operating in a very
unusual environment where i am saying to
the american people
we need to keep certain things secret
from you and you must trust that those
are in the national interest and you
must trust that i will exercise vigilant
oversight when
things are done in an incorrect fashion
and
i must say once again i find myself uh
concluding that something has gone so
terribly wrong that for a very long
period of time
activities uh that shouldn't have been
going on were and uh no question in my
mind that it affected judgments that
were made by both elected and appointed
representatives of the people
what the chairman is referencing is that
the line of questioning i was developing
earlier
had to do with a published report that
the inspector general had
recommended that
reprimands be
issued to all three former dcis whose
watch it was
that stretched across these events
the recommendation was no reprimand for
the three dcis
and i have a public letter that i will
distribute you can all have a copy and
examine all three
dcis remarkably have written to director
deutsch
and have indicated why they should not
be held responsible
a new standard of accountability in my
judgment uh is being applied we just
didn't know if you don't know it doesn't
it's not
apparently true that you're going to be
held accountable for your actions well
they should have known all three of them
should have known
um i mean they're not not like they were
this is a
an issue involving uh grenada it's an
issue involving the number one threat
the united states of america the 1980s
the soviet union
and to say gee i didn't know that maybe
they were doctoring intel
is to call into question whether or not
you
were informed as to what the job was
going to require of you when you took
the job in the first place and then most
remarkably of all in the
second the last paragraph the three
former dcis
say
maybe the inspector general needs to be
investigated
uh maybe the inspector general needs a
special panel because nobody
is holding him accountable in this whole
situation at all i don't believe that
the morale of the
the men and women at the central
intelligence agency who do in fact risk
their lives they do in fact work very
hard to try to carry out their missions
i don't believe their morale is going to
improve
until unless those of us who are either
elected or are appointed to carry out
the same kinds of jobs are held to the
same standard of accountability and my
judgment these three dcis were not held
to the same standard of accountability
we were told earlier by the chairman of
the house intelligence committee that
while there were
should have been serious suspicions as
to the reliability of these sources
the information passed on
was not focused it was in fact true
information designed to shore up the
credibility of the sources can you sort
that out for us
the
information
was passed on according to one
individual no longer with the cia
who did not inform the customer
about the tainted source
because that cia official did not want
to undercut the reliability
or the customers
acceptance of the reliability of the
information
but from what i saw and heard there's no
assurance
that the information was reliable
so you don't know whether it was
accurate
or disinformation as well
on this date of the record
there
are many many items of information
uh which were given and this is
something we're going to have to track
down
and we're going to have to see
what officials acted on the information
because a lot of judgments were made
including the purchase of a lot of
military equipment
and
whether the customer relied upon this
information
is something that has to be determined
and the accuracy of it has to be
determined
but we got into details as to one person
uh who on 16 occasions
gave information to a customer
from a source which was controlled by a
hostile foreign intelligence agency the
kgb
without telling the customer
that the source was controlled by the
agency
now that does not have any indicia of
reliability that i can see
coincidentally the information or some
of the information might have been
accurate but who knows
when you have a tainted and controlled
source sorry senator that person knew it
at the time
that's right it's it's hard it's hard to
believe
how many off that somebody would
knowingly
pass on information
uh to the highest levels we don't have
at our fingertips what went to the
president but some of this went to the
president
and others went to
uh this is uh during the uh
uh i'm not sure whether it extends into
1993 or not so we don't know for sure
president clinton's been handed any of
this back well um
it's in the late 80s and uh
that's it's less likely to be busy well
yeah
we we have a voluminous report and we
just spent
until 5 20. we started at 2 o'clock
interrupted by a business meeting for a
short time and a vote
uh but we're in mid-stream on really
digesting all of the right ways but we
do know for sure we went into one person
in detail
that on 16 occasions and they counted it
up while we sat there for a few minutes
on 16 occasions one cia official passed
on to the consumer
information from sources which were
controlled
by the kgb
can you give us an example again let me
comment on that again
there are many aspects of this thing
that i haven't fully digested because
i've just been through the report once
and uh we'll have to get further into it
before i can
uh before i can reach
solid conclusions but this much i do
know
uh i mean the the dci
if this is a situation of sexual
harassment the dci says well i didn't
know about it therefore i'm not
accountable fine
but you're you're talking about the dci
having
saying essentially how did i know
that the that the soviet union that
they're the the kgb was going to try to
provide us with bad intel upon which we
would then make policy decisions whether
it was a weapon system or treaty how
would i know that was going on
it goes on that's why we have ci that's
why we have this you know that's why
we're organizing the way that we're
doing so for the for them to deplete
ignorance and then to write this
remarkable letter i mean i i must say
that
the the most important item of business
as far as personnel action and holding
people accountable is making sure that
the word goes out to people that are
hired that are professionals that are
going to stay on after the political
appointees leave the political point
he's going to be held to the same
standard of accountability how many cia
case officers do you think were involved
in uh in this where they passed on
disinformation that they knew was from a
double agent was there more than just
this one that you're mentioning or
whether
we have information as to the three
directors as senator kerry has said
and nine others and we have not sorted
all of it out the three directors
senator
knowingly passing along information no
not not the director senator kerry has
made the comment explicitly that the
directors are asking to be absolved of
responsibility because they did not
actually know and they've sent a public
letter uh detailing why they should it's
a it's a remarkable letter it's a
remarkable letter especially the part
about in investigating the investigator
when the ig
criticizes them that he ought to be
subject to a panel of investigation it's
a remarkable level you'll have time to
read it
but but but the point the point to be
clear about is that
others at least one person repeat for
the third time on 16 occasion knowingly
passed on information to consumers
without telling them of the tainted
source you know give us an example
policy decisions that were made based on
this bad information nothing cannot we
don't we we we have to we have to get
into that that's that's one of that's
one of the items to follow up
uh to see
what what information was passed on by
these individuals from tainted sources
to officials who made decisions
which may still be operative involving
enormous sums of money i think you can
say in general either the information
and intelligence being supplied by the
by the cia
is of no value whatsoever or it
contributed to very bad decisions
did they give you an example what kind
of information bogus information was
passed on i mean
generically or even a specific piece of
information that turned out to be
possible the most specific thing that
we know about i know about at the moment
is that judgments were made on the
purchase of
military equipment involving significant
sums of money i cannot be specific we do
not have that that's what has to be
traced through what was director
deutsche's uh reaction to this letter
and to the argument that his
predecessors used
i'll yield to the interrogator on
uh
that
again all after what what was what was
deutsche's reaction to the letter and to
the argument that his predecessors used
to absolve themselves i would let
director deutch handle that uh well we
thought he was going to come out
yeah
are you talking about a small fraction
of the soviet divisions reporting from
being coming from controlled sources or
are you talking about most of the
information delivered from the soviet
division to policy makers in this period
from the late 80s to the early 90s
coming from controlled sources there's
no way to qualify information to answer
your question
are you
how many controlled sources it is a
fraction it's certainly not 100 it's a
fraction and there's other sources
for policy
how many controlled sources have they or
you identified we
we can only tell you
that in the summary report we have that
there were 12 people identified
and three of them are former directors
and nine are cia
how many how many controlled sources how
many sources
uh were
we do not have that information
available so you don't know how many
different agents were doubled how many
assets
we do not have that information the
bottom line is you don't know whether or
and no one knows at this point whether
the information delivered here is false
bogus or true or partly true or partly
lie it's a muddle
that's we that has to be determined step
by step and piece by piece so you would
call it disinformation that was fed to
them well
was there only one cia officer who knew
who knowingly passed this on or were
were more of these 12 people knowingly
passing on distance more than one passed
on information knowing it to come from a
tainted source controlled
by a hostile foreign
you pass it intelligence that we don't
know
that we don't know
one of them defended on the ground that
he didn't want to tell the customer the
source was tainted
because he thought the information was
reliable
but how he could come to that conclusion
given the tainted source is remarkable
and when you say passing along to the
customer the customers would include the
pentagon the national security council
the white house and members of this
committee perhaps
i don't know about members of this
committee but it goes to it went to the
president and uh that may be as high as
you can go would you say so bob even
with the committee in the line i would
say most of my good information comes
from the public source
about all this year
is the net effect here that because of
information provided by any of us the
soviets were able to present controlled
agents to cia and present a mixture of
truth and falsehoods so that to this day
we don't know what happened we don't
know what the truth is in terms of the
reporting we do not know what the truth
is the one thing we can tell you
categorically we have that information
was passed on by controlled sources
whether the information is true or false
is something we have yet to determine
but you have a fairly strong inference
that the soviet union is passing the
information through controlled sources
it isn't for the benefit of the united
states of america
this is not the only source of
information that policy makers have they
sometimes read the new york times for
example and reach decisions they
sometimes there's all sorts of other
sources that they use to make decisions
and
uh you know it's not as if the the even
the cia
coming out of the soviet union was
supplying uh all bogus information
senator specter should anyone be
prosecuted as a result of this do you
think
are there any criminal violations well
that question was raised during the
course of the hearing as to
whether any criminal statutes were
violated you do have the element of
willfulness and enchant and knowledge
which is the crux of the criminal
prosecution and the question is whether
there are statutes which apply to it and
we're looking at that now do you expect
to make the criminal referral to the
justice department well the matters have
already been referred to the fbi
director deutsch said that himself he's
already thank you very much can you
explain though again how ames fits into
this picture with the disinformation was
he manipulating
all these different
soviet sources or manipulating the
soviet division to accept this
information this disinformation
well
aldrich ames was responsible
for
allowing the sequence to arise
where all of these double agents uh
were passing on the information i can't
really give you a categorical answer to
how ames fit into each one of these
situations
thank you thank you
dr deutch is coming out he is coming
is he coming out now
[Laughter]
i have just finished today testifying to
the house of the senate
and describing the results of the aims
damage assessment carried out over the
past year and a half
by an independent group of experts on
all the amid damage that ames did to
this country it is a devastating record
that will take us years and years to
recover from
uh an important aspect of that report
was new information to the senators
about sensitive intelligence reporting
that the cia knew was tainted and was
passed on to
policy makers of this country on which
they relied to some extent
it is an inexcusable lapse in
elementary intelligence practice
nobody could be more indignant than the
uh than i am as a former consumer of
this high level intelligence when i was
in the department of defense as under
secretary and his deputy secretary
the problem we face now
is to reconstruct and put into place the
changes necessary to make an effective
clandestine service again
high on the list of things that we must
do is to
rebuild confidence in our policy maker
consumers in the integrity of our human
intelligence we have designed a process
for doing so where we will for the first
time in the history of the cia allow
policy making consumer representatives
into our cases to assure that we are
reporting information to high-level
policymakers with integrity about the
sources from which they come i'll take a
couple of questions and then i'm afraid
i have to go if the three
previous directors involved in this are
to be held accountable
what exactly is it there to be held
accountable for for their for their
inaction for their conduct uh
what exactly is it that they're
being accused of
the inspector general noted the three uh
uh past directors of central
intelligence as being accountable
on the charge that i would the criteria
that i would use for uh taking action
against individuals
i would not do so against any of the
three prior uh
directors of central intelligence for
whom i have the highest professional and
personal regard
can you be sure that this information
still isn't being passed passed on to
the cia very good question we are uh
alert to uh all possible cases of
perception management or disinformation
the damage assessment has gone uh done a
very careful assessment of that and let
me just say that i am secure
that our new
post aims efforts at counterintelligence
will protect us against a catastrophe
like this happening again
has anybody been fired as a result of
this
of 12 individuals named as accountable
by the inspector general 11 them 11 of
them are no longer in the employ of the
central intelligence agency therefore it
is hard to fire them uh anyone who is no
longer in the employ uh the 12th
individual has been disciplined in a way
that i found appropriate have the other
11 retired since you took over the
agency that's correct no all 11 were
left before i came to the
you've gotten to the bottom of all the
damage games has done or is there more
to come yes i am very secure that we
have come to the damage we'll see still
see tracings of it in the future but i
am very secure that we have come to the
end of our assessment of the damage that
aims has happened it is not the first
time that the united states national
security apparatus has been penetrated
by foreign agents but i will say this
that we will do the rebuilding necessary
changing the practices the attitudes the
performance of the director of
operations so that we once again have
the most effective clandestine
intelligence surface service in the
world and i am dedicated to making sure
those changes take place what sort of
reprimands or warnings did the four
receive if they left the agency before
you took over sir uh the i action was
taken against uh four individuals where
i informed them of action i would have
taken had they been an employee of the
agency included terminating two of those
four
questions of the soviet union now what
do you think is our biggest threat for
counterintelligence
we face uh threats of
counterintelligence for many quarters
it's been a very long day thank you all
very much thank you thank you thank you
the fbi arrested aldra james in february
nineteen ninety four he is serving a
life sentence in prison for spying
today on washington journal our
newspaper roundtable guest our theater
in washington dc a symposium on the
civil war with a special focus on
slavery
[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
david weiss author and former washington
bureau chief of the new york herald
tribune he joins us to discuss his
recent book cassidy's run the secret spy
war over nerve gas
[Music]
david wise author of cassidy's run the
secret spy war over nerve gas
who was cassidy
joe cassidy was a very ordinary american
from a blue collar background in erie
pennsylvania he dropped out of high
school joined the army and when the fbi
recruited him for this spy operation he
suddenly found himself a secret weapon
in the cold war without any training
and what was that
well
his job
was to
pass what turned out to be 45 000 pages
of secret documents to the russians all
under the control of the fbi joe cassidy
pretended to be a traitor
for 21 years
there he is
and
he pretended to be in aldra james if you
will for 21 years it was a remarkable
bit of acting and the russians believed
it
kind of a guy was he
well
i think he's
a very
down-to-earth plain
simple
but highly intelligent
the one quality he had that made him
perfect for this job was that he's he
was an excellent actor a natural actor
and he has a lot of intellectual
curiosity he was able to play the role
of a traitor so convincingly that the
russians never tumbled to the fact that
he was or the whole operation would have
blown up and his own safety could have
been endangered what years
was he in the army
well
let me
let me try to set the stage a little bit
for you more generally and then answer
that
as you know i've been writing about
espionage for
more than three decades
this was i think without doubt the most
extraordinary case i've ever uncovered
and not a word of it has been made
public until now
it when i say it was extraordinary it
was extraordinary to a great extent
because of joe cassidy who is the hero
of the book and the main character in
the book
but it was extraordinary as well because
it went on for such an astonishing
length of time 23 years that made it the
longest running spy case in the entire
history of the cold war
unusual as well because one of the
things that cassidy gave to the russians
was a
deliberately gave with the approval of
the us government was a formula for
nerve gas which was designed to mislead
the soviets a very deadly uh formula
and in addition to that
the two fbi agents were killed in this
case and the true purpose of their
mission was covered up until now and a
university of minnesota professor turned
out to be a spy in this case
and finally my favorite spy in the whole
business was
the russians sent a man code named xora
to new york city to live a very
anonymous life and his main job in the
event he learned of a nuclear attack
planned by the united states that he
learned that through joe cassidy was to
climb up on a huge rock in central park
at 68th street and fifth avenue and with
a trick radio signal the russians
uh a warning
so
this is a very large canvas of which joe
cassidy was the central figure he joined
the army uh during world war ii he had
been working in a steel mill in erie
pennsylvania so it was about 1943.
so how many total years was in the army
well he stayed in the army till 1973 so
it was a 30-year career he became a the
highest non-commissioned officer that
you can
is he still alive yes he is he's
79 years old he'll be 80 in june on the
25th of june and he's alive and well and
of course so is his wife marie who
helped him in this project just to
divert a moment his wife marie was a nun
for how many years
she was a nun for over 20 years and that
is certainly one of my favorite stories
in the book the fact that she wasn't
none because
there she is in her nun's habit as a
sister in the vincentian order
from pittsburgh and when joe met her in
1968
he had no idea of her background
and on the first date he took her to the
playboy club
which was big mistake
for a former nun but she had not wanted
to tell him that
that she had been in a convent
and joe claims that he was there at the
playboy club not to ogle the waitresses
but simply because at a dollar fifty for
an army sergeant in 1968 this was a
bargain to get dinner at the playboy
club well nor did she know of course
that he was a spy
and
when the fbi
uh
began to try to check her out because
joe cassidy being a double agent as the
term of art is called had to tell the
fbi that he was seriously seeing a young
woman
and they began to try to check her out
they couldn't find a trace of her and
they were alarmed there was a suspicion
perhaps she was a a russian spy sent to
spy on joe cassidy what is known in the
trade as a swallow
and the fbi was quite alarmed until they
finally
learned the fact that she had a
different name and had as a nun of
course sister miriam joseph and had been
living in a convent for 20 years so that
for part of that time so that that
explained why they couldn't find any
trace of her she in turn of course knew
nothing about this man whom she was
about to marry that he was a spy an
american spy
and it was only after their marriage
that the fbi rang the doorbell
and special agent james marcy said
there's something i have to tell you
about your husband
this is what book for you
this is number 12.
when did you write your first one in
1962
and that name was it was called the u2
affair my co-author was tom ross we were
a couple of young reporters here in
washington and
you know i'm an old police reporter and
i looked at the shooting down of francis
gary powers in his u2 on may day 1960
and i said there has to be a coincidence
that this is 10 days before the summit
meeting with eisenhower and khrushchev
and so
on that premise we began to dig into
this flight
and uh
and wrote our first book the first book
i can remember reading was the invisible
government yes also with tom ross that
became with tom ross that became the
number one best seller in the country
thanks very much to the cia which tried
to stop the book
and when they tried to stop the book and
they approached random house my
publisher to try to do that of course
bennett surf who was then the head of
random house and a wonderful funny man
as you may recall
he said to the cia well look
we will sell you the first printing as
they were asking to keep it out of the
bookstores but i have to tell you we're
going to go back to press and we're
going to do another printing and another
printing and another printing what was
it about
the invisible government was the first
look at the intelligence agencies of the
united states up until that time
it's hard to remember but people barely
knew there was a cia and what it did and
what these other agencies like the
national security agency did
of course people knew about the fbi but
not about the dozen or so other agencies
that are involved in intelligence and so
the book was uh
was uh greeted with uh quite a bit of
interest at that time was on the
bestseller list for 22 weeks
how long were you a reporter
well i worked for the new york herald
tribune for 15 years until the paper
departed except in paris where it still
lives on and that was in 1966 i'd
already started writing books before
that time and have you made a living
basically out of these books over the
years
my wife occasionally raises that same
question but yes i have where do you
live in washington dc right in town and
where did you get the first inkling that
you had
a book
called cassidy's run
well i didn't know then it was going to
be called cassidy's run brian for a very
simple reason what which was i didn't
yet know the name of the spy who was at
the center of this whole drama
joe cassidy
i
learned uh nine years ago from a source
in the intelligence business some
fragments of this story some bits and
pieces and the source did not know
the whole story by any means but just
enough that i was totally intrigued to
learn more i had to know more
and that was the challenge because the
files were and are still locked up in
the governments uh inside the government
inside the fbi and inside the pentagon
so it was a great challenge it took me
five years before i even could determine
the name joe cassidy
up until that time no one even my
friends in the intelligence business
wouldn't divulge that name for
understandable reasons he'd been a
double agent he was at some risk of his
life
finally in 1996 i was able to find him
and i went to see him
and he turned out to be
very open uh ready now finally at the
age of uh at that time probably 75 or
six to tell his story was he allowed to
that wasn't a question i raised
all i know is that he's talked to me for
many many days and hours and weeks to
tell his part of the story of course he
didn't know the entire story he was one
piece of it
did he have to get permission to talk
well i don't think he did
i don't think he did
uh there were uh people in involved in
this who
who wouldn't talk to me because they
felt it was all secret but there were
other people
who felt it was time for the story to
come out after all the cold war has been
over for almost a decade
these events are long past
and
there were people especially i think
in the fbi and elsewhere in the
government who felt that
this story while it had some uh some
minuses also had many pluses and that it
was time to get it out
and uh that's i think was the motivation
of people talking to me what's the first
thing they did when they and and who
asked sergeant cassidy to be a spy
well well joe cassidy was
had decided to re-up and stay in the
army after world war ii
and uh in
1959 he was called in with a bunch of
other non-commissioned officers to
a library at fort belvoir i believe
where he was stationed at that time
right here right near washington and
he was there was a lot of buzz in the
room people thought has there been a
security lapse why are all of us being
called in this is some kind of special
meeting
and one by one they went in and they
talked and when his turn came there were
two men in in suits
civilians
sitting in there which was very unusual
in itself and they didn't identify
themselves and they started asking him
some questions
and uh
one of the questions they asked was
do you ever play
volleyball that's a funny way for what
became a lifetime of work for joe
cassidy began he said well yeah sure as
a matter of fact our team you know the
second battalion whatever had uh
was pretty good at it and we used to win
cases of coca-cola and so he said sure
they said well would you be willing to
play volleyball over at the y a block
from the white house in washington every
thursday night
and he said well sure i guess you know
this is the army uncle sam and you do
what you're asked to do so he said he's
willing to do it and they said well you
may be approached by someone with a
foreign accent
so just go and work out and after
your workout
put your uniform back on and sit out on
the steps of the y
well joe cassidy did that and he did it
for six months
and
the reason the fbi had put him there was
that they knew of course that a soviet
intelligence officer a man named boris
polycarp had played at the y played
volleyball and was quite good at in fact
and
he
was known to play there on thursday
nights and after six months one night
in the summer
joe cassidy was sitting out on the steps
when polly karpov
uh
emerged and
of course noticed the uniform and
said
have you had dinner they'd played on the
same team they knew each other now but
didn't really know each other
and
joe said no no i haven't had dinner they
went off and had dinner what became a
series of dinners some seafood dinners
along the potomac on main avenue
and
gradually
the man revealed that he was a russian
not at first
and uh he asked for very innocuous
things at first which is how they're
trained to do to try to cultivate a
source
but he was well aware that being inside
the military joe cassidy who had the
potential of being a mole inside the
united states military for the soviet
union
mr palikarpa of commander polycarp was a
was representing the gru which is not
quite as well known as the kgb but the
gru is the military intelligence and it
operates on a parallel level with the
kgb at that time which was the civilian
spy agency and they're mostly after a
lot of the same things but of course
particularly military information
so this was 1959 that's right and
how and eventually the name mike came
into this
well all of the russians for reason best
known to themselves identified
themselves as mike so there was series
of mics that were in fact nine mikes
over
how many years 21 years nine different
people that's right all they call
themselves mike but the but the one man
who was entitled to call himself mike
was mikhail nanilan
who was a good-looking young man
representing uh the gru and he twice
came to the united states to handle joe
cassidy for the for soviet intelligence
they did send a total of 10 people
in connection with this case
they must have regarded it very
seriously but danilan was the main
handler and of course the fbi was able
to identify all 10 of those people
so when did the real information start
being exchanged
well almost immediately
after a period of several months had
gone by and and cassidy had been they
thought brought in and you see what's
what's very important here if i may
digress just a little bit is that
people walk in all the time to embassies
and say
people walk in russians walk into the
american embassy overseas or vice versa
and they say you know i have information
for sale well very often that's
a volunteer who really isn't a spy and
he's trying to penetrate the other
service
and so there's always a big question for
example when aldrich ames walked into
the soviet embassy in in downtown
washington
and said you know i have information of
value well it turned out he had
information of enormous value
but
the russians would have to ask
themselves well is he real or is he a
dangle
and so volunteers are often looked at
very very carefully as potential plants
but in this case the russians felt they
had found cassidy i mean here was this
soldier was playing volleyball and then
sitting out on the steps and resting
afterward and paying no attention to the
to the russian spy who was on the team
and the russians felt they had found him
that they didn't realize he was a dangle
who had been put in his way very
deliberately by the fbi it was very
clever really and it worked because
with the assurance that they had found
him they never worried very much that he
had been planted on them it never
occurred to them that someone playing
volleyball at the y might be in fact a
double agent were we doing the same
thing in russia at the same time
well that's another book i mean i think
the the double agent game has gone on
that went on all through the cold war
and is probably going on even today
what are micro dots
hollow rocks
rollover cameras
and special pencil led
well the book of course has all the spy
stuff which
uh you know is a lot of people are fat
it's the james bond stuff and people are
fascinated with that
you see if you're a spy and joe cassidy
they thought was a spy for the russians
they couldn't just call them up from
their embassy for example and say uh
you know uh oh mr cassidy today you know
we like you to steal a certain document
leave here you know and we will pick up
or you can come to embassy no the
communication has to be
uh in a way that it can't be detected so
the telephone isn't used at all ever
period
personal meetings do take place but very
carefully choreographed and orchestrated
what the russians
favor
and have favored over the years and
still favor are things called dead drops
which are hiding places that can be
placed like a squirrel might like a
hollow of a tree or a loose brick in a
wall and there's a little space behind
it it's usually outdoors and it can be
anything like that where there's room to
hide something film or microfilm or
documents
and the spy let's say in this case joe
cassidy uh would go to that dead drop
and
they taught him how to make uh fake
rocks
in fact uh like mr cassidy sergeant
cassidy made one for me
uh out of paper mache showed me how it's
done
and it looks absolutely realistic then
he would roll it in the dirt
to look like a rock to pick up some dirt
and it was kind of gray looking to begin
with and the inside would be completely
hollow and in there he would have some
ordinary tin foil
that you would buy at the supermarket
and inside the tin foil
he would wrap
uh the film of the documents he had
secretly photographed on behalf of the
russians all was under the control of
the fbi and the joint chiefs of staff at
the pentagon
the russians would then pick up this
this uh these films
and um
uh
they would develop them and they would
think they had the secret documents they
indeed many of them were marked secret
even top secret but they'd all been
approved by the joint chiefs of staff as
okay to give to the russians for one
reason or another in this game you have
to give away some secrets in order to
establish credibility and to obtain
secrets that's the name of the counter
intelligence you make the point in the
book that if
one of us were to give the same secrets
away to the russians we could be
arrested but under this
format the sergeant giving away real
secrets right of course we had the
approval of the highest level of the of
the pentagon of the joint chiefs of
staff for each of these documents that
he gave away but to answer your question
they gave him they communicated with him
mostly through hollow rocks and they in
turn would leave a hollow rock for him
to pick up and inside that hollow rock
would be micro dots now micro dots are
no bigger than a period in one of the
sentences in my book
and so you're not going to find them if
you open up a rock and find let's say a
matchbook
in
inside the hollow rock
and
in that matchbook cassidy would be told
to look under the letter a for example
and that right under that letter there
would be a micro dot in a little slit in
the matchbook cover and they gave him a
micro dot reader so that he could read
these and magnify the messages which
would tell him
where the dead drops would be for the
next several months when the next uh
personal meeting would take place with
the soviet agent and so on those that
was how he got his instructions on
microdots they also communicated with
him later on through morse code from
radio moscow with six-digit code groups
that he would have to decipher with the
help of a tiny little dictionary so
the pencil led you asked about
that was a chemical he would crush the
lead and try to dissolve it it was
didn't work too well actually but he
would use it for secret writing there
was a lot of secret writing which
kind of like what we did as kids with
lemon juice you know that you would it
would look like a blank sheet of paper
but treated with the white with the
right chemicals the message would uh
appear what about a rollover camera
what's that
yeah the rollover camera was something
the russians had invented so that
joe cassidy
although he sometimes used a
conventional camera could take this
special camera they had rigged up it was
very small no bigger than a pack of
cigarettes as i recall
and he could roll it over a document to
which he would have access
and he would roll it over in three
places so that it would scan and
photograph that document he wouldn't
have to manipulate the camera it was
just automatic and then he would turn
over the whole camera which is very
small inside one of these hollow rocks
and they'd give him a new one the next
time he picked up a hollow rock
how
micro dots hollow rocks roll over camera
special pencil lead jump from 59 to
2000
what do they use today
or do they use these same kind of things
today in
intelligence gathering well as a matter
of fact
a lot of this business hasn't changed i
mean we all enjoyed the james bond movie
and and
the q
the gadget meister who recently died in
the movie at least uh movie version uh
and a lot of exotic weaponry and so on
well there is some of that but for this
kind of operation
where a intelligence service believes
they have an agent working for them a
mole inside the united states government
the communication today my guess is it
goes on exactly the same way
it's not high-tech but it works you have
a story in the book this is out of
context of what we're talking about
where the guys walking down the street
in london
yeah with the umbrella
yes uh
i tell that story to indicate
that uh the kgb did
at least and and soviet intelligence did
at least uh 15 20 years ago
engage in assassination and the umbrella
man
was a man who had been
working for bulgarian intelligence
and he came up behind a man named
georgie markov
and it was either on waterloo bridge or
on the strand nearby and he poked markov
with this umbrella in his thigh and the
umbrella tip
with the help of the kgb who had given
this technique to the bulgarian service
uh contained a capsule of of a highly uh
poisonous uh substance called uh reason
which is uh a a derivative of the castor
bean plant
of any of us who've ever had castor oil
probably knows it's very toxic but this
stuff kills and kills very quickly
um and
that that story took place around 1977.
but you indicated that maybe some of
these secrets were passed on would have
led to the production of this from us to
the russians well as a matter of fact
recent was a secret that was passed on
not as part of this operation but
by the people at edgewood arsenal
near baltimore which is where the nerve
gas that is at the heart of the story
was developed and where joe cassidy of
course was stationed in the 1960s that's
what made him of such uh enormous
interest to the soviet intelligence
where is edgewood
well it's northeast of baltimore it's
part of the aberdeen proving grounds
where they test missiles and ordnance
but it's a huge complex of laboratories
where america's nerve gas was developed
you know that nerve gas was originally
captured some of it the early versions
of it were captured from the nazis at
the end of world war ii
uh a gas called sarin
and to to show you how little things
have changed in the spy business
uh the sarin gas was used in tokyo five
years ago in the terrible attack in the
tokyo subways by the uh by the
japanese cult have you been to edgewood
well i have been to a lot of places in
connection with this book
i have not personally toured the
laboratories
they for one thing they are no longer
producing nerve gas as such in edgewood
they are still doing defensive research
i don't think
an outsider would be a popular figure
inside a secret nerve gas laboratory
who's the fellow named hormats
well saul hormats was some people call
the father of the nerve gas program a
sort of edward teller of nerve gas
and
he
was a
in charge of things at edgewood arsenal
for many many years
and then
after he left the government he became
an opponent of nerve gas and many of his
colleagues turned against him for
breaking ranks
but hormats felt that this material is
so deadly
and so
and can kill civilians
that
it should be it should not be used and
indeed is not effective
militarily who are the good old boys
well the good old boys were a group
dwindling now
of nerve gas scientists they all live up
around bel air which is a suburb of
baltimore near the old laboratories and
the good old boys were nerve gas
scientists who used to gather once a
month and
swap stories about
the nerve gas business just like
you know mr de tocqueville said we're
all great joiners in america and
everyone has to have a club including
the nerve gas scientist did you meet
with them
i have spoken with several of the good
old boys yes how long did
sergeant cassidy live around edgewood
well he was there from 1962
until 1969
and it was during that period at
edgewood where he had
complete access for most of that period
to the chemical weapons laboratory to
the nerve gas formulas and there it is
he
uh he everything crossed his desk
because as a non-commissioned officer he
was in charge of filing and dealing with
all of this material so he was quite
convincing that he had access to the
material and the russians of course
wanted it and it was during this period
that the deception phase of this whole
operation took place that's the most
sensitive and delicate phase
that
even some of my best sources were very
edgy and wary about discussing with me
what's that mean deception
well
you see in every uh double agent case
where the double agent is built built up
by passing real secrets there's a
terrible temptation to
slip deceptive material in bad and with
the good in order to deceive the
opposition intelligence service
to slip a mickey in effect in with these
good documents and the decision was made
and approved again at the highest level
of the government
of of the military the joint chiefs of
staff
to give
the soviets
a
nerve gas formula
called gj
which was part of the g series like
sarin is called gb and so on so minus gd
and this was invented we're going to
call it gj
and it indeed was a very deadly nerve
gas
developed in the labs at edgewood but
american scientists had found it to be
unstable and couldn't be weaponized
could not be stored in a weapon because
it would lose its toxicity it was very
volatile it wouldn't stay useful as a
deadly nerve gas and so the decision was
made you know we're not going to put
this stuff in weapons
but someone thought let's give it to the
russians
the purpose was to try to mislead them
and and as it's been explained to me at
least to try to lead the russians down
the garden path make them spend a lot of
time money and resources trying to
replicate a nerve gas that in the end
wouldn't be useful to them
do we have nerve gas today
well under the chemical weapons
convention which the united states
senate ratified in 1997
we're supposed to be destroying in the
process of destroying our stocks of
nerve gas we're no longer producing
nerve gas as we were very actively
in the 1960s and again in the 1980s have
we ever used it in war
we have not
did the russians have nerve gas
well yes of course
in fact a lot of my book discusses the
russian nerve gas program
there is a scientist whom i interviewed
uh both in moscow and here because he is
now here
who was arrested by the kgb his name is
villa mirzayanov
and he revealed that the russians had
developed a very deadly nerve gas ten
times more powerful than anything in the
united states arsenal called novac
now
novichok has never been acknowledged by
the soviets
as
and there's veal merzianov
uh he was arrested by the kgb for
talking about novichok which has never
been acknowledged by the soviets to be
in their arsenal of nerve gas
and they've never listed it under the
chemical weapons treaty which of course
they have also signed where do they make
it
well the soviet uh nerve gas
establishment was
in two places as i discussed in the book
the central laboratory where where mr
mirzianov worked was
in
moscow itself
and
the plants for
large scale production because
laboratories just produce
pilot amounts small amounts of nerve gas
and then it goes to the big industrial
plants which are all along the volga in
three separate locations and there are
also some testing facilities there as
well
the palmettos yes who are they who were
they
well i mentioned the university of
minnesota professor
and uh
that's
who one of the palmettos eventually
became
um the best way i can explain the
palmettos is to tell you
that in 1971
after joe cassidy had been transferred
from uh
edgewood arsenal where the nerve gas
center to mcdill air force base
in tampa
a transfer that
created a whole new phase of this case
the palmetto phase
because the russians
were restricted to 25 mile radius
traveling outside of their embassy in
washington
the russians could not
follow joe cassidy to florida and the
fbi believed correctly as it turned out
that the russians would have to surface
and illegal now an illegal agent is
someone who doesn't operate under
embassy cover he's not you know boris
ivanov who's the first secretary of the
embassy posing you know posing as a
diplomat who's really a kgb or gru agent
no the illegals could be anyone
they are people without benefit of
embassy cover they could be your next
door neighbor i'm not really suggesting
that but it could be anyone in fact the
russians have very successfully planted
people in our society some of whom have
taken the names of real americans so
there could be a brian lamb walking
around somewhere you know using your
name and identity is actually a soviet
illegal or today a russian illegal and
this is still going on
in 1971 in march
joe cassidy put down a hollow rock at
the base of a little palm tree
and there it is
uh
and uh or at least there he is putting
down it said this is a 72. this is a
similar kind of thing a similar thing a
year later
and he put this rock down at the base of
a palm tree
and
the fbi was waiting in a condominium
apartment overlooking the scene with
their cameras going
they didn't know who was going to show
up or whether anyone would show up
but someone was supposed to under the
plan
and they knew it wouldn't be a soviet
diplomat their hope was was that it
would be an illegal
well one of the fbi agents had a knight
scope
and he was looking through the knight
scope and he said to jack o'flaherty the
agent in charge down there of this
operation he said
i see a hand
that was the first appearance of the man
who became known as palmetto
and that hand was groping through the
bushes trying to reach the rock without
showing his face and his body
but he couldn't reach the rock it was
just out of reach so he had to come
around to the great relief of the fbi
had to come around the bushes of the
palm tree and show himself and they got
a good look at him and they got pictures
of him but they didn't know who he was
and they didn't know
how they were going to find out who he
was because they were very reluctant to
put any agents on the street to tail
whoever showed up they didn't want to
blow the whole operation out of the
water
by making the russian spy aware that the
fbi knew about them
so they were cursing their luck when the
man with the rock started walking off
out of camera view
and then they got a terrific break
because a few minutes later a volkswagen
drew up to the palm tree to the street
in front of the palm tree and the man
who was dressed in white slacks hopped
out he's very visible in the night
he hopped out and laid down a
supermarket shopping bag or ordinary
brown paper bag at the base of the palm
tree
he had forgotten to put his signal down
which would indicate he had cleared the
drop
very very poor tradecraft
well now the fbi had a license plate
and the license plate was traced to a
rental agency during the night
in miami
where
the fbi got a second incredible break
gilberto lopez
code name now palmetto which is this fbi
code name gilberto lopez rivas who was
celebrating his 28th birthday had rented
the car under his true name
the fbi was able to pick up his trail
again they didn't want to be in too
close to him but they found out that he
had taken a trailways bus and they
traced him to houston and they
determined he'd gotten on a plane to
mexico city
gilberto lopez was and is a mexican
national who was at that time studying
as a student in salt lake the russians
had brought them in
infiltrated them into this country as a
student
and he showed up six more times in st
petersburg florida at these drop sites
different drop sites to pick up
documents uh for secret documents uh
some of them top secret from joe cassidy
and often he appeared on four of those
occasions he appeared with his uh with
his wife and i think on three of those
occasions he appeared
and there there they are with his wife
and his two-year-old son
who was uh emilio flores
well
the fbi was anxious to learn more about
gilberto lopez
who incidentally now i can tell you is a
member of congress in mexico a member of
the chamber of deputies
which
as we speak
has not yet been noticed by anyone but
that may change shortly
mr uh mr lopez was living in salt lake
with his wife
as a
young student getting his phd
and
at the
university of utah
and the fbi was anxious to learn more
about them well how are they going to do
that
they decided the best way to do that was
to get someone who was fluent in spanish
who worked for the fbi
and infiltrate them try to penetrate
mr lopez's immediate circle
and get to know him
and so they found an agent in miami
named aurelio flores
who was a young agent about the same age
as gilberto lopez who had
a young child
like lopez
and they said we're transferring you to
salt lake city if you're willing to do
this undercover work
and you will enroll as a fellow student
at the university of utah and he did but
the way he was able to uh to
get to know lopez
was
dropping off
he made certain that he dropped off his
child at the same day care center
and one day he uh blocked lopez's car
with his own car
and so that lopez uh would have to wait
a moment for him to for aurelia flores
the fbi man to come and move his car so
that he could get out
and flourish came along and he said oh
dispensa may excuse me you know i didn't
mean to to lock you in this way and he
moved his car and they became buddies
very close friends to the point where
the fbi man was babysitting lopez's
child and lopez at one point got to know
el reggio flores so well
that he actually tried to recruit him as
a soviet spy
the fbi put
little tiny cameras
in the apartment how did they do that
and how small were the cameras
well
after uh
after uh they didn't do that in salt
lake although they they wiretapped his
telephone
but after lopez decided to transfer
he had a ford foundation grant this
russian spy and decided to
continue his studies in at the
university of texas so he moved to
austin
and uh well let me just stop yeah i mean
the ford foundation
was funding
a russian spy from mexico in this
country they didn't know it of course as
far as they knew he was a promising
young student
and
he was at the university of texas now
and aurelia flores his great friend and
babysitter from salt lake had said you
know i'm not too happy here in salt lake
i think i'll transfer over to university
of texas too and i think
lopez encouraged him to do that so there
was no suspicion
and
flores
then therefore is on the scene again
in austin and it was in austin that the
fbi
found a crawl space over
lopez's apartment and they were able to
gain access to that crawl state crawl
space
and they used a camera they made they
drilled a little pinhole in the ceiling
and they used a camera of the crawl
space
a camera that they'd gotten from nasa i
believe the technology was such that
it was a very small camera very
concealable and
could operate through a very small
opening in the ceiling
and so they had the house uh bugged
wiretapped and video taped they could
actually see lopez taking uh getting
more code instructions i think from
havana maybe directly from moscow in
some cases
getting his own instructions by morse
code and with his uh
uh
earphones on
eventually and you mentioned this in
your early remarks there were two fbi
men that were killed yes in relationship
to this man flores how did that happen
well in 1976
mr lopez became professor lopez and he
and his wife moved to minnesota where he
got a teaching position
at the university of
minnesota
as a
an assistant professor in the chicano
studies
department
and
there at the
university uh the fbi of course resumed
its uh surveillance of him trying to see
whether he would again engage in the
kind of activities that he engaged in in
tampa and they were hopeful that perhaps
of course joe cassidy by now was out of
the picture he was not in minnesota they
were hoping perhaps he would be picking
up materials from some other source so
that was the purpose of the surveillance
at that time
but
how were mike kirkland
and
agent basford killed
well
uh i had us at the stage here in
minnesota because there was a young
agent
named uh mark kirkland
who was assigned to this case and there
he is with his
fiancee at that time julie
and
mark kirkland uh whom he then married
and they were raising a family they had
two small children and this became his
case
he was uh
young and enthusiastic
and uh very anxious to
try to catch
lopez
and his wife in some espionage activity
they knew that he was a russian spy
and so kirkland grew a beard and began
to mingle pretend to be a student
one of the photographs in there actually
shows him with the beard posing as a
student at the university of minnesota
so that he could get closer
to
to professor lopez and the fbi also
succeeded in
placing an undercover agent a woman
and
you won't find that in a picture of her
because she has to remain in that
unknown capacity but she was actually in
in the class
uh with uh one of the students of lopez
but she was working for the fbi and
one of the ways that
that the fbi tracks people
in cases of this sort and in criminal
cases as well is aerial surveillance
in august of 1977 late august
lopez and his wife
and uh their children
headed north toward the canadian border
for what was ostensibly a camping trip
the fbi suspected he was on his way over
the border
perhaps to do something in canada where
he had lived previously before coming to
the united states
there's a great temptation on the part
of the soviets to send spies in over the
canadian border which they've often done
because it's such a porous borah border
and
and relatively easy for people to go
back and forth
so
the mark kirkland went up in an fbi
surveillance plane which was piloted by
special agent trenwith basford who was
getting ready to retire but was a very
experienced pilot
and also
not just a pilot but a special agent in
the fbi
and they
tracked
the uh
they tracked the uh lopez family as it
was driving north and when the lopez
stopped for the night the plane would
land and then it would take off the next
morning well on august 25th 1977
up near chisholm
the
northern minnesota and the lake country
they ran into their little cessna ran
into a terrible rainstorm
and
they tried the pilot tried to land
on
dewey lake which was one of the smaller
lakes in the lake country of northern
minnesota and he crashed
and that cost the life of both of the
agents
they both
had children in the case of mark
kirkland very young children and
so
there is
julie kirkland with
kenneth and christopher two very young
children how long ago was this picture
taken well that was taken around 1977
early 78. so they're all grown now yes
they are
uh but one of the reasons that i
have that picture in the book and and
talk so much about mark kirkland is that
i wanted people to know that the cold
war was not just a video game and we're
not talking here about nintendo this is
this is this cost lives and in this case
and this operation cost the lives of two
fbi agents now the the real purpose of
their mission was never admitted and
revealed for the first time in in the
book because
even their wives were not told for many
many years that they were on an
important national security case that
they were trailing a spy when their
plane went down
and what the public and press were told
it was something quite different at that
time
who
who likes what you're doing here and who
doesn't
other than people who read your books
well um
i don't think the
that the uh
that the gru is going to like it because
it makes clear that for 23 years they
thought they had a mole inside the
united states government who was in fact
working for the fbi at all times
so they can't be happy with that did
they know it at the time
no
they i mean is this the book the first
time that the gru will find out that
this
sergeant cassidy was a mole well
i would like to think so but that's not
the case because
they they already had a strong suspicion
because
in
1978
phil parker the fb
fbi man in charge
of this case at headquarters
flew out and there's phil parker
with a very un unregulated handlebar
mustache which he insisted on using in
the fbi despite regulations
uh phil parker flew out and confronted
lopez and his wife the palmettos
and indeed got them to got the husband
to confess
that he had been working for the soviet
union
so
the
hope was
on the part of parker and the fbi
that
the two mexicans
the illegals husband and wife could be
arrested they weren't
the justice department refused to allow
the arrest of the two spies
therefore there are people formally in
the justice department and maybe some
still there who will not be very happy
with this story
although they had
some arguments on their side
that
very complicated but legal situation
that
led them to come down on the decision
not to arrest
you say you did 450 interviews with 200
people yes how many different places in
the world did you have to go to to do
that
well
i went to uh
to moscow of course uh in 1993
and i traveled uh fairly extensively
around this country
um
spent a lot of time down in the saint
petersburg tampa area of course where a
lot of this action took place
and in new york and
around washington but
the moscow trip
was
the purpose there was i was being
stonewalled by the pentagon
i applied under the freedom information
act now we hear wonderful things about
the freedom of information act foia as
it's called
i've never found it all that useful
because as a writer of books
you put a request in as i did in this
case
and by the time you get any information
it's five or six years later because
there's so many requests and the book by
that time has been published and i'm
talking here to brian lamb and and the
information when it comes in is of some
interest but no not applicable to the
book in this case i never even got to
that stage of getting documents you know
five or six years later i may yet get
some
but the army
i submitted the request to army
intelligence and the fbi and the army
wrote back and said
this thing was called operation shocker
by the joint chiefs
that was what they called it
had a bunch of different code names
because code names changed to try to
protect the operation
the army wrote back and said we have no
record
of this case
so i wrote back and said well now come
on fellas you've got to have a record
this went on for 23 years it was the
most
important counterintelligence case in
the history of the united states
government the longest running certainly
and there's no way that you don't have a
record of it
so
they said they had no record of it
the
i then started dealing directly with
some officials at the pentagon
and i talked to a colonel
and i said i'm not getting anywhere with
the freedom information act
and i said i talked to a colonel and i
would like to bring this up to the level
of the secretary of the army to see
whether
the files can be found and whether i
could have access to the files of the
case
the colonel said to me
on the phone after we got to know each
other a little bit
one day he said to me on the phone you
know after you first
called me and made this request to try
to move up the line to get these
documents he said
the colonel came down from fort meade
which is where army intelligence command
is located
and he said
don't talk to david wise about this case
so i said wait a minute
am i missing something here
you're telling me that the army
sent a colonel down to tell you not to
talk to me about the case that they say
doesn't exist
and he said you've got it you've got it
right
well ultimately
uh through the good offices of ken bacon
the pentagon spokesman secretary cohen
spokesman togo west who was then the
secretary of the army agreed to review
the files to see what if anything could
be released to me
months went by
and then i got word back that yes i was
right there was such a file they'd found
it and no i couldn't have it it was
classified it was secret
one little item about your moscow trip
that popped out there are no telephone
books in moscow
oh yeah well that was the problem you
see
i was looking for mikhail danilan
as i mentioned the one mike who who had
the right to call himself mike because
his name was michael in russian mikhail
like gorbachev
and mikhail danilan
uh
was presumably i hoped still alive and
and well and maybe living in moscow
because
like a lot of our spooks when they
retire they you know continue to live in
northern virginia
or around washington because that's
where they've lived all their lives and
i was hoping that it would same would be
true and i might be able to find mike
denilan
in moscow or in that area
but there are no phone books so you
can't just look them up there's a number
you can call so like an information
operator
uh and i asked for mikhail denuan and
there's about a hundred of them in
moscow and of course none of them were
the right one anyone i started calling
them and
none of them were gonna be russian i
speak a little but i had someone to help
me do that do the phone calls
uh a translator
and um
finally
i was able to find someone
who uh actually had known to neil and
when he was stationed in the embassy in
washington
and
that person
uh
was able to uh was willing to contact
neelan on my behalf
now my intermediary didn't know his
phone number but he knew people who knew
them and that's kind of the way the
phone numbers are exchanged in moscow
you have to you know call boris who
might know michael who might know sergey
and
and you know this sort of phone chain
and finally he was able to locate daniel
and whom he knew
and said you know david wise is here in
washington he is trying to research an
old case
and uh would you speak with him
and denylin said that he was still
working for the gru and therefore he
could not possibly speak with me he did
say that
and then he also said being a
professional spy he said of course it
wasn't my case of course i knew better i
knew that he was the chief handler of
joe cassidy it was very much his case
but that was the position he took so i
left moscow quite disappointed i never
actually sat down with danilan
where are you from originally
i grew up in new york and
went to
columbia college and
became a
newspaper man a reporter on the late
great new york herald tribune and then
came to washington after uh
eight years of doing that and do you
have a family here
yes i do uh all my family is here my
wife and two sons you've thanked your
brother
yes he's up in new york he stayed in new
york what'd he do for you in this
story and i should say i have one son
who's now living in arizona but he had
been here until quite recently but your
brother what did he do for your book
well one of the things he did was that
the wonderful spy in new york the
sleeper agent is named exora code named
exora by the fbi this is the man whose
job was to climb up on the rock in
central park
if joe cassidy telephoned a planned
nuclear attack a warning of nuclear
attack to him and radio the russians
from this high it's really not a rock
it's like a small mountain you can walk
by 68th street and fifth avenue and see
it right there here he is the picture of
mr freundlich edmund freindlich aka
exora
and um
what my brother did was that when zoro
was infiltrated penetrated this country
as a refugee from austria
ostensibly but actually working for the
soviet intelligence
he got a job and the job he got was
working for robert maxwell the famous uh
publisher late publisher who
died mysteriously off his yacht
a few years ago
and he worked for robert maxwell
for a publishing company that maxwell
had in terrytown new york called
pergamon press
so um i
can't do everything although i try and i
asked my brother if you'd be kind enough
to try to locate for me some of the
former officials of burgham and press
officials and directors to see whether
they remembered the sleeper agent xora
although whom they knew was edmund
freundlich
and sure enough he did find me
two former directors officials of
pergamum press which is now defunct as
far as i know i hope
i'm saying that correctly and if not
we'll hear from them but
they did remember edmund freund lincoln
told me quite a bit about him he lived
an incredibly anonymous life a gray man
keeping as low a profile as possible so
that nobody would take notice of him
people are going to have to read the
book to find out more about exora here
is the cover of the book
the secret spy war over nerve gas
cassidy's run our guest david wise we
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
ah
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777
or call us at area code 765-464-3080
the informant a true story by kurt
eichenwald details the fbi investigation
of commodities company archer daniels
midland and focuses on top executive
mark whitaker who was also working for
the fbi mr eichenwald covered the
six-year investigation for the new york
times
well anyone who comes in now is late
um
hi i'm kurt eichenwald and i am the
author of a book called the informant
which is about events that took place
here uh
this is uh the story of the
investigations
of the conspiracies at the archer
daniels midland company
and the ultimate uh
bizarre tale that spun out from that
now it's i'm really glad to see so many
of you here because basically for the
last five years
i've been your neighbor
i've been
sitting next to you
you know
at lunch
i've been down at hux buying a buy
myself a diet coke i've
been driving all over town i've been
taking a trip between
between decatur and springfield and back
again and then down to champaign and
back over
so
as a result i kind of feel like i've
been living here myself
what i'm going to do today is i'm going
to talk to you about
what i was trying to do with this book
um
what it tells us and
read you a few things that i think
underscore that
now to do that let me tell you a little
bit about myself um i am an
investigative reporter at the new york
times which is
a big 50 word that basically means you
know i look at things
real hard for a long time
um
and in that job i've got i've had the
opportunity
to
see some of the more interesting
um corporate cases that have come up
over the years
and i kept noticing a trend
like i would write about a corrupt law
firm
a year or so later john grisham would
publish the firm
and i would write about a corrupt
insurance company
and year or so later john grisham would
publish
rainmaker
now i didn't write about the tobacco
companies but colleague of mine did and
a year or so later john grisham wrote
runaway jury
and and i read a news article where john
grisham said i get all my ideas from the
newspaper
and i thought
why is john grisham getting to have all
the fun
and when you think about it john grisham
brilliant he is writing
business stories he is writing thrillers
based in the business world
and
i stopped and scratched my head and
thought you know he's very right these
stories are thrilling these stories are
exciting
and maybe i should try to write one but
instead of making it up
i'll tell a true story
i'll just write it the way a novelist
would write it i will write a thriller
in novel form
that happens to be true
well almost at the very moment i had
that thought
a fellow named mark whitaker
burst onto the national stage now
everybody here
who doesn't know who mark whitaker is
yeah i thought so uh
since we're speaking in near mark
whitaker's hometown in the in the store
where he bought his books everybody here
knows but we do have a camera here for
people outside of the decatur and
forsyth area
so mark whitaker was a senior executive
at a company everybody here knows the
archer daniels midland company
which is
a company that makes the grains and
fibers and oils and additives that we
find
in virtually every food we eat i mean
it's in everything from popsicles to
pepperoni from
gerber baby food to kellogg's corn
flakes
they're everywhere i mean you have a
coke a pepsi or a 7-up you're getting
some ingredients
from adm
and whitaker was their golden boy
whitaker was a fellow who was a rising
star a man who had great promise there
very young man
but he also had a number of other lives
the one that was known about first was
whitaker was the highest ranking
informant ever to work
for the federal bureau of investigation
to work with the federal bureau of
investigation for the whole time that he
was or many for many of the years for
two and a half years during the time
that he was working for adm
he was simultaneously walking around
inside the company
wearing tape recorders inside his pocket
strapped to his back
and hidden inside his briefcase
video cameras hidden inside of lamps
and recording everything that was going
on inside because whitaker
had a number of secrets
but the one that
was the biggest at that point
was that adm was engaged in a series of
international conspiracies
to rig the prices
with competitors
of some of
those ingredients we find in we
ultimately find in our food products
that alone sounds like a great
possibility for a grisham story that
alone or in fact it sounds very similar
to something that scott tarrow just
wrote and personal injuries
but there was one more element
that made this story
more bizarre than anything i could ever
imagine
more bizarre than anybody could imagine
was that the entire time whitaker was
working for the fbi
he was also gradually losing his mind
he was a man that no one knew
was becoming very psychologically
disturbed
and was having a great deal of trouble
telling the difference
between what was real
and what was not
as a result
a lot of people the fbi the justice
department the american media
started following down trails
some of which were real
some of which were not
now when i first heard about this story
and over the
months and years that i continued
working on it for the new york times
eventually i realized this was the
perfect story this was the perfect
non-fiction novel
because you had in this story in one
place
the cia the fbi
international conspiracies money
laundering swiss bank accounts suicide
attempts
corporate espionage through the use of
prostitutes campaign finance violations
political power
gone and on and on and on and on
reaching all the way up to the offices
of janet reno and louis free at the
justice department in the fbi
i couldn't possibly think of a better
story
and so
i set about attempting
to
capture that
now
if you're trying to write this story as
a novel
that's true
uh the biggest problem would be how do
you write it well fortunately i'm the
one thing i like about this i gotta
throw this out uh liz smith the gossip
columnist took a look at the book and
she described it yesterday so i think i
succeeded she described it yesterday as
john grisham on acid
and uh
i i don't get any of the credit for that
i i get the credit for being able to put
it all on paper but honestly it's all
true but it is john grisham on acid
um
to put the structure together the first
thing i had to do was go back and look
at the novels i liked go back and look
at the non-fiction books i like the
narrative non-fiction books i liked and
i read book after book after book
underlining little devices they use how
did they get the pacing right how did
they
how did they keep my interest how is it
that i i was able to read this book and
not put it down all night long
then i went back
and read
a lot of books
that i didn't like
um
figuring what was it that they did wrong
what was it that didn't work
and
ultimately
had an idea had an idea of how to
structure it
the single most important thing i
realized in almost every book that
worked
was detail pacing was important pacing
was good but the tail was the most
important element you were able to see
everything that was happening there were
no walls if somebody went into a room
and closed the door you kept going with
them and you knew what kind of door it
was what kind of rug it was and what
kind of desk it was
and so detail
was
the secret of this story
to get that level of detail
meant that i had to engage in some of
the strangest interviews i have ever
participated in
there have been times i have sat with
people and they have told me the story
of the most difficult day in their
professional career how they sat down
with a colleague and realized that they
were concerned that the institution they
worked for was not was not doing things
the right way and as they sat there over
lunch
anguished over whether they could
continue
working in their job and i followed up
with the question
and what were you eating for lunch
sometimes people got very frustrated
with me but ultimately i ended up with
the detail i needed to tell the story
now there was a second problem
that being
this was a story where many many people
lied
this was a story where many of those
lies
found their way into records into
documents into print there were
allegations completely false allegations
that were made against honorable people
there that were printed up
there were
stories that left everyone confused
how do you figure out what's real
in a world where everybody is telling a
lie or almost everybody
for that i knew i needed to not just be
a novelist but also be an investigative
reporter i needed to obtain the records
i needed to obtain the transcripts
of the tapes that whitaker had recorded
i needed to obtain
other records from within the government
that would allow me to describe what
happened there i needed to call every
single person i could find
who played a significant role in this
case
and pushed them to talk to me
i needed to
sit down with those people and run
through it and compare what they said to
the documents that i could find and
eventually blend that all together
into one
long
narrative
but then the next level telling this
story is so
that's so confusing in a way that will
allow people to understand it
so i had to take a step back i had to
think about this how do you tell the
story the right way
and this was the most important decision
i made
in this case
it was easy to think who's the hero
maybe it's the man who wore the recorder
a lot of people thought that at one
point a lot of people at one point
thought mark whitaker was a hero
maybe it's the prosecutors maybe not
i decided in the end there were really
only one group of heroes here people who
dedicated their lives
to this effort people who regardless of
how tough
it became
in pursuing this case to justice
never let up
and that was the agents the field agents
of the fbi
these are people who work long hours
for not a lot of money
and did so solely for one reason they
were interested in pursuing justice
the answer became obvious how do i tell
this story i tell this largely from the
perspective of the fbi i tell this from
the perspective of
you find out what's going on about the
same time they find out what's going on
now i'm not going to leave you
completely surprised i'm not going to
raise something that i gave no
indication of you'll get hints along the
way but for the most part you're going
to find out things as the fbi finds them
out
what that means as a result
is the book becomes something of a
chinese puzzle
you open a door
you find another door
i'm never telling you where truth is and
where it isn't until the book finally
reaches its end
at that point
people in this community in particular
are going to find out everything you
wanted to know about what really
happened in this case
all of the confusion is stripped away
all of the false stories are stripped
away
and you end up with
a reality
a version of reality that
is backed up by about as much reporting
as i could humanly do
and
hopefully
that falls into the realm of what i was
trying to accomplish so
the story we have the story we tell
is um
the story of mark whitaker mark whitaker
working with the fbi mar the fbi
pursuing this case the fbi trying to
find out
how
adm was working with its competitors to
rig prices in this case in a in a
a product called lysine it's an amino
acid that's used to fatten up pigs and
chickens
probably everybody here knows that right
so you have the first day i'm going to
read a few scenes from the book has
everybody here read the book or i'm just
going to bore them no well now some
head's not not a lot nod so that's okay
i'm gonna read you a few scenes from the
book
the um
and i should tell you i'm a little bit
anxious here because i'm as i'm looking
around the room i've seen a few people
who are in the book
nobody jump up and say that's not what
happened
mark whitaker
began this event
by telling a story
he came to adm one day and said i
received a telephone call i received a
telephone call from an engineer at a
japanese corporation one of our
competitors and that engineer told me
that we have a saboteur in our plant
and that saboteur is contaminating the
plant and making it so it can't work
he told this to mick andreas the vice
chairman of adm
and in no time adm alerted the central
intelligence agency
said we've got a problem out here
the saboteurs out here this hap and this
this man who called us this engineer
he's demanding 10 million dollars to
identify the saboteur and to give us
the ability to fight off these viruses
they're using to contaminate our plant
well the cia doesn't have authority to
deal with that kind of situation so the
cia called the fbi eventually it arrives
at the fbi in chicago which called the
fbi in springfield which called the fbi
agent in
decatur illinois brian shepard
and
brian shepard came out interviewed mark
whitaker interviewed uh
mick andreas found out more about this
engineer found out more about this
contamination of the plant
and whitaker was saying he was getting
phone calls at his house
phone calls from the japanese engineer
who was demanding the 10 million dollars
so brian shepard
made an appointment to come out to mark
whitaker's house to put a tape recorder
on that phone
to catch this japanese engineer
and
get the proof that this extortion
attempt which is really what it was was
going on
earlier that night mark and ginger
whitaker went out to dinner
and that's this scene
ginger whitaker stepped into the crowded
formal dining room at the country club
of decatur and looked for her husband
it was just after 6 p.m that same day
most of the tables were filled but
ginger found mark and his guests quickly
he saw her clad in one of her nicest
dresses and stood to greet her
the dinner had been planned for some
time an adm vendor was visiting decatur
with his wife
whitaker had a close relationship with
the man
after hearing the family enjoyed horses
the vendor had presented the whittakers
with an expensive riding saddle
dinner was relaxed and elegant with wine
and laughter throwing flowing freely
late in the meal ginger excused herself
to make a trip to the ladies room
as she stood placing her napkin on the
table mark reached out with a business
card in his hand
here's that phone number you wanted he
said
ginger smiled as she took the card
uncertain what her husband was talking
about
she headed past the dining room dining
room's entryway and looked in her palm
she was holding one of mark's business
cards for adm
she flipped the card over and felt her
heart drop as she read words written in
mark's familiar scroll
the fbi is coming by the house tonight
at 10 o'clock
our house
ginger felt a chill
over the past two days mark had given
her some hints about what was bothering
him nothing in much detail but enough to
worry her
she'd hoped that the previous day's
interview was going to be the end of it
now some agent would be coming out to
their home standing with them probably
asking them questions
ginger could not think of the last time
she was so frightened
they leave dinner they go out to their
cars they drive home in separate cars
because whitaker has to take home
the vendor
as she's driving along suddenly
the phone rings in ginger whitaker's car
she knew it was mark calling from his
car
he had just dropped off their guest and
finally had a chance to talk
this is really going to be something
mark said over the car speaker sounding
terribly nervous again i don't know what
to do
i know what you're going to do you're
going to tell the truth
you don't understand
these guys are more powerful than the
government i'm more scared of adm than i
am of the fbi
if i were you i'd be more fearful of the
fbi ginger replied you don't mess with
the fbi adm's nothing compared with the
fbi
but as far as ginger was concerned adm
was just another company
mark said she didn't understand how
powerful adm was and what it could do
i could tell brian shepard everything i
know and tomorrow morning i'll probably
be fired from adm and they're a lot more
powerful than the government
gingerside
mark you only have one choice don't
worry about adm
you have to tell everything
ginger paused as she pulled onto main
street in mowiqua her husband's
nervousness had made her more wary
mark she said gently trying to mask her
concern have you broken the law
whitaker was quick to answer
no he said i haven't broken the law at
all
well
that's the moment of tension as they're
building up to it
brian shepard doesn't know this is going
on as far as he's concerned he's just
going to go drop off set up that
recorder and leave
about 10 p.m
shepherd approached the blinking red
light in the center of mohiqua he turned
right passing a series of modest homes
as he headed west large maple trees and
bushes obscured whitaker's house
the two-story home with multiple white
awnings pillars and decks was visible
only in spots where dense foliage and
their foliage had never grown
finally the bright interior lights of
the house cut through the darkness
shepard pulled on turned onto the
driveway passing a black gate supported
by brick pillars
inside mark and ginger were upstairs in
the master bedroom where they had
continued discussing the impending fbi
visit for another half an hour
market opened up a bit telling her
details of what he knew
ginger was more convinced that she he
should talk
just tell them everything she said well
just leave i don't like what this
company is doing to you this is a chance
to go somewhere else
mark sitting on the bed looked up at her
i may tell them at some point but not
right now right now i'm going to follow
the company line
ginger's face was a mask of
determination
mark if you don't tell them i will
the room fell silent
mark stared at her
he wasn't ready he needed more time
i can't he said softly
not now
brian shepard pulls up to the house he
comes in he introduces himself
goes upstairs hooks up that recorder
is getting ready to leave ginger's been
listening in
and realizes that mark never said a
thing
shepard had returned to the front door
thanking the whitakers for their time
mark opened the door and shepard walked
out crossing the porch toward his car
inside the doorway ginger looked at her
husband
are you going to say something she asked
softly or am i
mark didn't respond and started closing
the door
shepard had almost reached his car
ginger turned away from her husband she
shoved past him pushing open the door
and heading outside
brian
shepard turned when mark called his name
yes
mark took a few steps outside
do you have a minute
and that was it that was the moment the
beginning
in the five hours that followed mark
whitaker sat in brian shepard's car
telling a story almost beyond belief
that the company he was working for was
engaging in this international
conspiracy to rig prices basically to
rip us off
to cause the price of products
that food companies buy to be higher
than they otherwise would
if there was real competition
it was a massive allegation of a massive
fraud a fraud that was drive that
if successful would drive people in
this area this community out of business
people running small feed stores
wouldn't be able to afford the
ingredients they needed to run their
business
if true
this was one of the biggest
such conspiracies ever found by the fbi
over time it became evident that it was
true
for that i'm gonna go to one of my
favorite scenes here
one that takes place at a place you guys
might know it's called the hickory point
mall
that's where we are right now
uh or it's if you know there's a whole
slew of hotels down there and it took
that place just down the road
so if anybody sounds here's anything
familiar you know
that's why
north of decatur at the intersection of
interstate 72 and route 51 lies the
village of forsyth founded in 1854 as
the spikes were being driven for the
illinois central railroad forsyth had
long been little more than an appendage
to decatur but beginning in the 1970s a
boom in economy hotels there followed
the construction of the hickory point
mall
forsyth tsunamers is a frequent stop for
budget-minded travelers by the summer of
1993 the forsyth hotels had also become
popular spots for the fbi's meetings
with mark whitaker
storm clouds were gathering on the
evening of july 13th as bob herndon
another agent on the case drove his
bureau car to forsyth
after more than a month on the case
tonight he would meet whitaker for the
first time
herndon put on his blinker when he saw
the brown and white sign for the mall he
drove into the entrance and made a quick
light right ahead was the hampton inn
his destination after parking herndon
threw a floor mat over his red bubble
light and stuff his radio microphone
under the seat he didn't want passersby
to wonder why law enforcement was up at
the hotel
upstairs his partners were waiting the
three agents spent a few minutes testing
the telephone recording equipment they
wanted to use that night
shepard and herndon took off their guns
putting them in their briefcases
there was no reason to make whitaker
uncomfortable
their witness arrived about 45 minutes
later by then a torrential downpour had
begun
hey how you doing whitaker said as he
walked inside the room
a lot more chipper now than he was
before shaking off the rain
he glanced around whether all the other
agent on the case was sitting on a bed
i'm sorry was sitting on a couch on the
bed whitaker saw a young athletic
looking man he did not know
mark this is special agent bob herndon
shepard said like i told you he's
transferred from another office and been
assigned to the case
whitaker broke into a smile hey it's
nice to meet you great to have you here
there's some chit chatting as everyone's
having a good time meeting each other
whitaker turns over his tapes and
finally they say
there's a call they want him to make
they want him to call a fellow
in japan
the fbi wants to tape videotape the
japanese the koreans and the americans
as they engage in this conspiracy
their hope is
they'll have the lock solid evidence the
rock solid evidence to prove the
conspiracy
as long as the meetings are in
are in paris or in vancouver or in
mexico city
the fbi doesn't have the authority to
videotape
but they've got to lure
the japanese and the koreans
to america
and they've been wrestling with how to
do it they finally came up with an idea
golf
they would use the exciting world of
golf
in hawaii
to bring
these conspirators
into the united states
now these are what you're about to hear
the actual words that were said during
this telephone call this is from the
government transcript of this recording
so
listen to it carefully
because you're going to hear what an
astonishingly
skilled
informant cooperating witness that
whitaker was
listen as he starts drawing out the
other guy
and keeps trying to get him to come to
the united states
put it on my calling card whitaker asked
as he picked up the telephone
yeah shepard said
it was 20 minutes later sitting on the
bed whitaker dialed the number for kanji
momoto at ajinomoto the adm's idm's
japanese competitor
he had rehearsed their conversation
several times and was ready to suggest
the hawaii proposal
the recording device was hooked up to
the phone
it's ringing whitaker told the agents
a woman answered
yes may i speak to mr momoto please
i'm sorry he's in a meeting now but
he'll be free at noon
he told me if he's in a meeting to call
him out of the meeting that it's very
important
the woman asked for his name
whitaker waited on hold until the phone
clicked
hello
is this mr tani in new york or mr momoto
whitaker was still using momoto's code
name for the conspiracy
momoto chuckled
mr tani speaking yes
well how are you whitaker asked is it
mark speaking
this is mark tawny speaking whitaker
replied yamamoto laughed mark tawny
they're having a good old time
the two men discussed the possible
effects of a planned price increase adm
whitaker said was concerned about drying
up demand
remember in vancouver whitaker continued
terry wilson made this very clear that
he'd wanna that we'll want to try to
keep the level of license usage as high
as we can
yeah that's right
not to get the prices too high where we
shrink the market whitaker said yeah
mamoto replied if we shrink the market
of course we have to avoid such a price
increase
whitaker glanced over at the agents the
time had come to lay the trap
since you guys hosted the vancouver
meeting i think adm should host the next
meeting don't you
yeah mimoto said that's fine
and maybe we host it in uh maui
maui
you know have the group meeting like we
had last time in vancouver have it in
maui hawaii
maui hawaii is uh still in the united
states mimoto said warily
whitaker had been told to push moto if
he objected to force him to explain why
he didn't want to meet on american
territory
he glanced at shepard
yeah but what's that mean still in the
united states he said
well momoto said still in the united
states means uh united states is uh very
severe for the control of antitrust
activity no
whitaker's eyes lit up
that statement was going to be almost
impossible to explain away
he brushed aside momoto's concerns
hawaii next to an 18-hole golf course he
said
mimoto laughed if your company judges no
problem
maybe i will consult with our legal
department
whitaker reminded him that the previous
year when the price fixing scheme was in
its nascent stages there had been a
meeting in maui
well momoto said maybe the meeting could
be held in hawaii to establish the
lysene association the one that the
conspirators were using for cover
yeah that's right whitaker said picking
up the theme would be a formal
association meeting
hmm
and also would be a good distance for
you and us both together
yeah yeah that's right mamoto said and
we get to be on the golf course
yeah
whitaker replied
no big problem momoto said
that was it
mimoto had taken the bait
now that proved to be a little over
over uh uh
too quickly decided uh the japanese
backed out
hawaii and golf kept being dangled in
front of them until finally they
accepted it finally they came
that well was not for almost another
year later
now as whitaker was continuing to work
with the fbi and continuing to work with
adm
he was getting more and more reckless he
was beginning to
um take chances
that otherwise
rational people
wouldn't take
there came a time when he was sitting
in a hotel room a marriott hotel room in
irvine california
meeting with two executives from
ajinomoto and accompanied by none other
than mick andreas the vice chairman of
adm the man who was there to help
establish the final rules
needed for the price fixing to take
effect
and then whitaker
what no one knew i should explain what
no one knew was that the entire meeting
was being videotaped brian shepard
was not far away looking at a monitor
as a video camera hidden inside a lamp
was capturing everything that was going
on
whitaker also had a briefcase with him
among other recording devices a
briefcase that had hidden behind a
secret panel
a recording device
but then something happened
now this book is written sometimes in a
quick cutting way where you're jumping
from scene to scene you have three
groups of people happening here
mark whitaker
brian shepard
and mick andreas i will change my
position depending on whose perspective
we're in
whitaker walked away from the easel they
were using to describe all their numbers
and sat down
his briefcase was in front of him on the
table
wait a minute what was that
a click
whitaker had definitely heard a click in
his briefcase
andreas turned his back to whitaker
looking at the easel
there it is again
the briefcase was making a noise
what if the others heard something
whitaker reached down and turned the
case slightly away from the other three
executives
he popped open the latches
shepard watched the monitor intently
andreas was speaking
i would suggest we do the following
andrea said
andreas was on the verge of making his
proposal in his excitement shepard was
paying no attention to whitaker the
agent didn't notice that his witness had
become fiddling with the hidden panel in
his briefcase
whitaker tugged on the panel a small
amount of velcro pulled apart but the
panel stayed in place
slightly farther from the recorder
maybe that would stop the noise
he'd shut the briefcase he shut the
briefcase
i'd suggest you tell the people that
whatever they have in ninety three they
can each have two thousand more in
ninety four andrea said and we get the
rest between you and us
ikeda from ajinemoto still holding the
pen
looked confused
we have to give
some specific number he said
whatever their number is in 93 andrea
said then we can agree to split the
rest there it was
shepard had heard it andreas had just
proclaimed that he was setting volumes
for every lysine competitor dictating
sales for companies that weren't even in
the room
this was dynamite evidence
click
there it was again
whitaker looked up and saw everyone was
at the easel he opened his briefcase and
gave the panel another tug more velcro
tour whittaker shut the case and looked
up andreas was just a few feet away
walking straight toward him
shepard had noticed nothing about
whitaker his witness sounded calm in
control he'd really come through this
time
the group was on the verge of a deal
shepard watches andreas stepped out
toward the bathroom the two ajimoto
executives stayed in front of the easel
speaking in japanese about andreas
proposal
click whitaker decided he had to do
something drastic somebody would
definitely hear this how in the world
would he explain noises coming out of
his briefcase
whitaker scanned the room andreas was
still in the bathroom ikeda and yamada
were talking to each other
no one was paying any attention to him
he opened the briefcase again and pulled
hard on the panel the velcro tore
whitaker lifted it up and looked at the
recording device inside if anyone came
up behind whitaker at that moment
they would see it
i'll stop there
now as everyone here knows
whitaker was not
or i believe everyone here knows
whitaker was not simply
getting risky
whitaker was cracking under the pressure
whitaker was a man with a psychiatric
condition no one knew about
which was gradually getting worse and
worse as the days moved on
the only person who was seeing all of
the evidence of it
was his wife ginger
ginger whitaker almost didn't recognize
her husband anymore throughout their
marriage he had made this family a
priority he always had made time to
raise rabbits with their youngest son
for 4-h club and attended all the
children's school shows but now between
adm and the fbi
the family seemed last on the list one
night she argued with him about his
absences she needed him home more she
told him his children needed him she
needed him
i'm doing all this for you and the
children he protested i want to give you
guys everything that's why i'm working
so much it's for the family
ginger took a breath
mark's tone was snippy he'd always been
so bubbly and happy
these days was often just unpleasant and
tired
mark this isn't for the family she said
we don't need all these things
what you want to be like what are you
glad excuse me what you want to be
somebody living in some small house he
snapped you want to be like those people
who can't afford cars for their kids
ginger felt taken aback it sounded as
though he thought that money made him
superior to people with smaller incomes
something inside him had changed
you're not better than somebody else
because you have more cars or a bigger
salary she said it had nothing to do
with what kind of person you are
she paused you used to know that she
said softly
you used to know what mattered you need
to find that out again you need to turn
back to god
mark glared at her
i don't need god he said
i've got more power than god
this is a man who's changing who's
dramatically changing
but he's continuing
to work for the fbi
in the years that followed
whitaker and the fbi brian shepard bob
herndon
and their supervisors
put together a great case
they captured
these conspirators on tape doing
virtually everything there's a wonderful
scene which unfortunately is too long so
i'm not going to read it i'll just
summarize it
where
everyone's joking about who might be
attending the next price fixing meeting
and they say well maybe maybe some of
our customers will be coming
you know price fixing humor um
and then we'll have one from conagra and
one from another from another customer
and one of the conspirators looks up it
looks straight at mark whitaker and says
and we'll have one from the fbi
little do they realize the fbi is
watching this scene unfold because it's
taking place in atlanta
um
but before the meeting began there had
been a problem with whitaker's briefcase
the fbi was desperately working to fix
it
they had just finished fixing it
and decided to bring it over to whitaker
so as they're joking about the fbi and
the federal trade commission coming to
the to the room there's a knock on the
door and one of the executives says yes
ftc
federal trade commission but it wasn't
the ftc
it was the fbi
and special agent herndon
posing as a hotel employee passes
whitaker's briefcase saying i believe
you left this in the lobby and in comes
this recording device in front of
everybody as they all sit there and
laugh and joke about how funny it is
that this that this briefcase he left
downstairs hadn't been stolen yet
the evidence was fabulous the evidence
was fabulous it's unlike anything i've
ever witnessed
but there was a problem the whole time
mark whitaker was helping to gather this
fabulous evidence he had a number of
other secrets of his own the biggest not
the biggest one of the first that came
out was that
he had been telling people
he had been going around inside adm and
saying
don't tell anyone
but there's a criminal investigation of
price fixing
and i'm the cooperating witness
i i've lost count of how many people
were told it was something like eight or
nine
it is amazing this case was never
disclosed there were people on the night
of the raids when the fbi
was going out to put out their search
warrants and to do the confrontational
interviews who were at home eating
dinner waiting checking their watch
they're supposed to be here any minute
whitaker told me they're coming at six
oh there they are
and as they're being interviewed a few
of them say ah yeah i knew all about
this mark told me
this is a problem this is a big problem
for the fbi
over the next few weeks problem after
problem after problem emerges until
finally the biggest problem of them all
comes out
adm's attorneys who by that time have
figured out that mark whitaker was the
informant in this case
arrive in washington to the senior
levels of the justice department with a
big black notebook and then that
notebook
are checks and wire transfers and all
sorts of other material and they say
guess what guys
while your cooperating witness was
working for you
he was also embezzling two and a half
million dollars from adm
the target of your investigation has
been ripped off
by
your informant
that's a problem
that's a big problem
and then came some of the worst
decisions by the government the
government breaks the case in half they
decide because adm's lawyers make some
ridiculous allegations against the
agents in the case that brian shepard
and bob herndon can no longer be
involved
they bring in a whole new crew
people who don't know who whitaker is
people who are simply looking at
whitaker as a target information is not
shared between the two investigations
leads are lost problems develop shepherd
is in the position of watching his wit
not even being able to talk to his
witness anymore the case the any trust
case is having problems the fraud case
is having problems and whitaker now
the subject of massive media attention
the target of a criminal investigation
watching his case fall away
completely
cracks up these will be the last two
scenes i read
and begins lying to everyone
this is a scene where he's meeting with
his lawyer a fellow by the name of jim
epstein they're about to go meet with
the justice department and explain all
this money that ended up with with uh
with the
in mark whitaker's swiss and cayman
islands and hong kong bank accounts
i want to know everything you did
epstein said looking at whitaker sternly
i want to know who you did it with when
you did it and what evidence you have of
it
whitaker nodded
epstein had told had been told that
prosecutors from the fraud section which
was prosecuting the whitaker case wanted
to meet him on monday august 7th the
idea made epstein horribly uncomfortable
but whitaker was determined to intend to
attend and explain everything he felt
sure the government would understand
now mark if you're not prepared to tell
the truth and tell everything then we're
better off not going epstein said it
would be better not to go than to leave
out one detail or god forbid say
something you know is wrong it'll just
get you in deeper and deeper
i understand whitaker said i'm going to
tell the truth
for hours epstein and his partner
debriefed whitaker he provided numerous
details of his financial activities one
scheme involving a 2.5 million dollar
check made out to a company called abp
had been hatched with another executive
he said
i didn't get all of that money whitaker
said one million dollars of it went to
leonard thorstensen the president of abb
why did he get the money mark epstein
said
he was the guy behind it a million
dollars of it was for him
as they finished the briefing epstein
was less comfortable than when they had
begun the story had a lot of holes
mark this just isn't convincing me
epstein said i don't believe it i swear
i swear i'm telling you the truth
they're going to tear you apart on this
i don't think you should go in because i
don't believe it i want to go i got to
tell them
finally epstein relented as a lawyer his
job was to give advice
he couldn't stop a client who insisted
on destroying himself
they go and they meet with the fbi as
they're walking in the door mark
whitaker turns to his lawyer jim epstein
and says
i haven't been telling you the truth
i'll straighten it out in there
epstein grabs whitaker tries to turn him
around and push him out the door but
whitaker goes no i'm going to tell the
story and sits down epstein sits down in
a position which he has never been in
about to listen to his client
tell the people trying to put him in
jail
what happened and he doesn't know what
the truth is yet
he tells a completely different story
and they leave the room
there's a break
whitaker headed with his lawyers to
another room epstein closed the door and
turned toward his client the lawyer's
cool facade collapsed replaced by open
dismay
mark what is this he asked sharply what
about leonard thorstensen from abp
whitaker shrugged
he had nothing to do with this he said
evenly
nothing to do with this epstein repeated
throwing up his hands you were saying
before this guy stole a million dollars
now he had nothing to do with it
for a second whitaker seemed to consider
epstein's words
i didn't like lennart very much he said
softly
epstein sank into a chair
well mark he said
if thorns if thorstensen knew you you
almost implicated him in a million
dollar theft he had nothing to do with
i'm sure he wouldn't like you very much
either
the lies from mark whitaker continue on
and on and on into this case
i'm not going to tell you what they are
because the more i tell you
unfortunately
the fewer doors you run into you're
going to start to know things that
you're not supposed to know this is in a
way a mystery a game i'm playing with
you i am putting you in the position of
the fbi i am putting you in the position
where you don't know what's real and you
don't know what's fake ultimately i
promise
you will you'll know what really
happened
but
you know it's horrible to say the butler
did it come read the book
so
trust me you'll enjoy it a lot of people
have told me
to say don't start reading the book
after eight o'clock at night
unless you have the day off the next day
because you'll want to sleep in
and
that is that is the story of this book
why i did it how i did it
i hope you enjoy it does anybody have
any questions
yeah
have you visited with mark whitaker
recently in prison
the last time i met with mark whitaker
in prison
well
last time i met alone with mark whitaker
in prison was in april
um
march he was subsequently interviewed by
dateline nbc which was doing a one-hour
segment based on on the informant
and whitaker by that point had developed
a great deal of trust in me he had he
had confessed a number of his lies to me
and he told
me and told dateline that he would only
do the interview if i agreed to be there
and i was there it was it was a very
interesting experience i wasn't doing
the interview but um there was
it was either one or two times i don't
remember which
that i had to go over to him and say
look you have already confessed the
truth to me
are you sure
you know you're he was he was
there's no other word for it weaseling
around a little bit you know he was
having trouble just finally saying the
words yes i lied about this i said
do you want to be doing it this way or
do you want to just come out and say the
whole story
and after that he just
he hit the table he said this is the
whole truth i will tell you the whole
truth and he told the whole truth this
is a marvelous book say that to the
camera
it is a marvelous book
i'm sorry i'm such a huckster
yes
um i have gotten feedback from uh
characters in the story
many of them have called me
surprised at how accurate the book is
i did hear from brian shepard because he
says there is one word i attributed to
him
uh which was not accurate a uh a swear
word
uh and so
i take him at his word it's coming out
of the next edition
um
the
other than that everybody has been
awed i think is the only word that it's
just how accurate it is actually the
funny part was i got a call from the
chicago u.s attorney scott lazar
and he said yeah i got a
book really accurate really like it but
i've got a question for you so what's
that he goes
you've got a lot of things you're not
supposed to have where did you get them
i was like i'm not going to tell you
yeah how long did you gather information
before
well i was gathering information all the
way through the end i mean um i
i
started five years ago and when i was
just doing it for the new york times but
i sort of a pack rat put boxes and boxes
and boxes of material
and that reporting continued
about three years ago i started on the
book
and starting
last july i'm sorry a year ago july i
started writing it
and in the course of writing it i would
find
gee i don't know what hotel they're in
god i don't know what sandwich that was
i don't know who
you know who did this where they were
standing and so i would call people back
people were amazingly patient there was
also a day i mean i
i always said no one would know this so
i'm now going to say it
there was a day where i was writing
about a meeting that had taken place and
the records didn't say where it was said
a forsythe hotel is it was either the
hampton inn or the the what's the one
next door to it
fairfield in
and
i s and i had been told in the
interviews it was the fairfield then and
i thought i think i have a record on
this and i dug and dug and dug and dug
and dug and after an hour i found this
record and no it was the hampton inn and
i went and i changed one word of the
manuscript and thought
who's ever gonna know
[Laughter]
but now everyone does
anything else
yeah
excuse me what's your next project
what's oh the question i should be
repeating the questions that's real i'm
the only one who's miked the question is
what's my next project
trying to get people to read this book
that's that's going to be my job for a
while yeah
and did you see all these changes in his
personality
i i first spoke with mark whitaker in
the fall of 1995. um
i left
that meeting convinced that i was
speaking to somebody who had a
psychiatric disorder
there was
something that that he did he would
repeat
statements again and again and again and
again just like i just did
but he would say you know you know i i
went to the fbi and i told him this i
told them this and when i went to the
fbi and so so later when i was going out
you know before i i'd gone to the fbi
already and i told them this and i was
listening to this point this isn't
normal
this is there's something wrong here
and i called um as a reporter i have
this huge list of experts and i called
some people and i started describing
what i knew what i what i was seeing
and was told
he's bipolar
and it was not long after that in the
conversation i said have you ever been
diagnosed as having a bipolar condition
and he
he had just been diagnosed in august
and so um
you know whitaker i mean whitaker is a
very
people people have always tried to make
whitaker into a hero or a villain
and he's neither
he's both
he's everything i mean whitaker i kind
of view is a tragic figure you know he's
a fellow
who
who brought down
an incredibly important criminal
conspiracy one that set dominoes falling
again and again and they got lysine then
it went to citric acid then it went to
human vitamins and they've collected two
billion dollars in fines it's a lot of
money and all of these frauds are being
broken up because of this one
disturbed man
a man who was so disturbed that he could
never act in his own best interest
and because of what i believe is the
government's
ultimate mishandling by that i don't
mean the fbi i mean breaking the case in
two and the justice department fraud
section handling one party any trust
division handling another part
no one ever looked at mark whitaker as a
whole human being
and so
they sentenced the criminal
without giving him any consideration to
the fact that he had also
brought down
these
huge conspiracies so the result of that
is you have a man who worked two and a
half years admittedly for very twisted
reasons for very
ins on some levels for very corrupt
reasons but worked for two and a half
years
in exposing a crime
who got no credit
for exposing that crime
and if we start demanding that
cooperating witnesses and informants
must be completely clean you know have
to come out of the convent before we
agree to use them
goodbye law enforcement you know
cooperating witnesses need to get credit
of course mark whitaker needed to go to
jail he committed a lot of crimes
but the the fact that simply because he
is too disturbed or was during these
events
to make a decision in his own best
interest
uh hardly seems to merit him getting the
kind of sentence that he received with
no consideration for his cooperation
oh i'm sorry that was your question
wasn't it did i see him deteriorate yes
i could pretty much predict what mark
whitaker's lithium level was based on
how he was behaving the fall of 1996
he was at his worst stage i've ever seen
him
he was completely cracking up
that was the time when a lot of material
started coming out that were forgeries
he was creating bogus tapes he was
making accusations of criminal activity
in the in the fbi he was accusing the
government of becoming communist i mean
he was spinning so far out of control
and at that moment he fired the only
person who was actually acting in his
interest he fired jim epstein
and so his one sliver he had left toward
getting an outcome that was
going to be good
um disappeared
so yeah
i thought it was very interesting on the
dateline that
special agent bob herndon
uh made the comment that he actually
felt sorry for baker
because if it wasn't for him
the fbi would have never the case would
have never been brought just exactly
right i mean what she was saying is that
on on the dateline program about about
the about the book
um
special agent herndon who was one of the
case agents said he felt sorry for uh
for i'm repeating this because i'm
assuming nobody can hear it on tv uh but
he felt sorry for for whitaker because
whitaker
um received no credit for the the works
he did and
it's it's kind of hard to look at these
events objectively and say well mark
whitaker should get absolutely no credit
for what happened
anything else yeah
um
is
the question is what is what i'm saying
that without mark as the informant they
never would have brought these people
down without mark whitaker's cooperation
we would not even know that a crime was
being committed
this so it's beyond bringing these
people down we would be walking into our
grocery stores today buying food that is
being rigged paying more money paying
tens of hundreds hundreds of millions
billions of dollars
out of our pockets to enrich these guys
who want to argue about free markets are
great competition is great now we're
going to close the door we're all going
to rig everything
so yeah we would not know this without
mark
what was in it for mark was
remember it was the fbi came to talk to
him
this is where you have to start i have
to start giving away the stories the fbi
came to talk to him and i'll put it this
way he had told a number of lies
he had told lies to the fbi his wife was
pushing him to tell about the price
fixing she didn't know about the lies if
he didn't say it his wife was going to
if he got caught in his lie there were a
series of other lies behind those that
might get uncovered mark whitaker was at
risk of going to jail
he knew about his embezzlements at that
point
he was a man talking to the fbi who had
a million two million dollars sitting in
a bank account in swiss in switzerland
that he had stolen from his company he
had to distract
reward them he thought that was his
reward on some level he did
on some level he did but on some level
he also thought of it as his his share
of the proceeds you know
there was no way for him to trade that
off
if if you read the book well to trade
that off you mean say i'll admit to this
this is a man you gotta understand this
is a man
who
pled guilty
went to prison
served almost three years until he
finally
confessed to what the truth was
he was incapable of acknowledging what
he had done
and it was only when
i'm not a threatening guy
it was only i couldn't put him in jail
he wasn't jail i couldn't do anything to
him and i just finally say you have to
embrace the truth your lies have not
helped you
and finally he confesses to the truth
but i'm not going to tell you what it is
because it gives away that's the butler
did it
he's no relation to what
i i think that that was pretty horrible
um
what the the question was uh uh that he
thought it was amazing that when the
case finally went to trial
that the original fbi agent brian
shepard wasn't allowed to sit in
the judge's ruling on that i think was
was wrong
i'm not a lawyer
i do think it was a disservice to the
government and it was a disservice to
shepherd i understand why
when faced with the choice
they had to pick one
they they didn't choose shepherd i mean
it's not it doesn't mean anything bad
about brian shepard what it means is
well
herndon is the one who has the better
familiarity with the tapes we're going
to need the tape recall
shepherd is you know is the one who
knows the witness and there was
something going on with the witness at
that point which i don't want to give
away
that made that much less significant
it was just a strategic decision the
decision should not have had to be made
uh it was certainly not meant as an
affront to brian shepard
but it's very hard given the amount that
brian shepard went through i mean you
know probably a lot of you know him
brian shepard is a person who came into
this case
unwillingly he wasn't pleased about
doing it but once it became his
assignment
he pursued justice till the end he
fought against some very very high
hurdles he had to clear a lot of high
hurdles he had people in washington who
were not working in the interest of this
case
and
shepard
shepard is a credit to this community
shepard is a credit to the fbi because
this individual through his perseverance
and through his commitment to the law
was able to ultimately
knock down the first domino and put all
of the bad guys in jail
and there were a lot of defendants who
criticized uh brian shepard for not
realizing about what there was to know
about mark whitaker but let me point
something out adm didn't recognize what
there was to know about mark whitaker
the justice department didn't recognize
what there was to know about mark
whitaker the american press when we
already knew he had embezzled money
didn't recognize what there was to know
about mark whitaker brian shepherd did a
great job
and that is why he's one of the heroes
of the book so he's a man who did not
get enough credit for what he did for
what he accomplished
yeah what happened to the japanese
yeah
the question was
were they punished the question was what
happened to the japanese that were the
japanese executives that were part of
this were they punished
well you had a problem
the embezzlements made whitaker into an
impossible witness
um they needed to introduce the tapes
but you need somebody to sit up on the
stand and say
yes
that's us i'm in that meeting that's me
that's so and so i can authenticate this
tape
the only other people in the room were
the japanese and the japanese adm if adm
had walked in in the fall of 96 and say
hey you're k or i'm sorry in the fall of
95 and said your case is a disaster
will be the witnesses against the
japanese it would have been hard to turn
it down if they'd offered a real
settlement they thought they could fight
it to the end as their fighting fighting
fighting the japanese came in and said
we'll cut a deal we'll be your witnesses
just don't put us in jail
we'll we'll pay big fines
just don't put us in jail
very hard offer to walk away from
because they needed to salvage the case
salvaging the case meant again
tipping the first domino being able to
get the evidence of all the other
conspiracies that the fbi had evidence
was occurring
anything else
you know i'm sorry i keep ignoring the
people back here
the question is do i think justice was
served as far as the industrial
conspirators
i think the law was followed there's a
weasley answer isn't it
no i don't
no i don't if if i go out tonight and i
rip off a supermarket i walk in there
and i
stick my hand in the cash register and
steal a bunch of money
i'll probably get six years or something
like that
these guys sat down in suits
and
with pens and paper they ripped off
every grocery store in america
and they got a statutory maximum of
three years
these are cases that are very hard to
prove that's one thing you will get out
of this out of the story they are very
hard to prove
and so
when you require
an evidentiary level that's like this
and the fbi and the justice department
actually manages to clear it to then say
okay
three years each
is ridiculous
i'm biased
i would think that
nine years would have been appropriate
it's a serious crime
you know anybody who reads the story in
there
of j.r hubble's rudd
the feed the farmer who was trying to
open his own feed business a man whose
feed business was collapsing because the
people at adm wanted a little bit more
money anybody who reads that and thinks
that this is a victimless crime who
thinks that this is a crime that really
isn't very important and shouldn't be
punished hasn't read it right
so
anything else
oh i've got one more over here and i
keep ignoring them yeah
seriously in danger
oh the question was how many lives were
seriously in danger
i mean there is there is really no you
know one of the things
people ask me all the time because i
write about white collar crime they go
oh aren't you ever scared
and my response is always the same
white-collar criminals are wimps
i these guys don't have guns
they
aren't
you know they could make a lot more
money if they went off and murdered
somebody probably if they could figure
out the right way to do it
but
they just
they really don't engage in these things
i mean and i have never actually i've
had people call me up and tell me you
know when i was writing about prudential
oh you better pay up your prudential
life insurance click
it's like what a bunch of jerks um so i
don't think anybody
the fact that you get a threatening call
to me is usually a sign of
nothing
racketeering really doesn't mean
anything other than you've committed
a crime
three times over a period of of of of
over a period of time
through an entity that can be identified
as a racketeering enterprise it's a very
technical definition but racketeering
doesn't mean you know necessarily
they're walking around with machine guns
and blowing people away
it just it just you know there there's a
there was a securities firm up in new
york where they traded a lot of times
really badly and there was they were
breaking the law on trades and they were
indicted as racketeers you know there
were no guns
so racketeering
is just sort of a fancy phrase that says
we get to take everything you own
so
yeah
have i talked to mick or terry in prison
um the only thing i'm not going to
answer is who i've talked to unless it's
actually in the book
my conversations with whitaker are in
the book some of them so
i could talk about that but
i don't want to start going down the
path of saying i talked to this guy i
didn't talk to that guy okay
yeah
yes
the last surprise
lying about everything how do you know
that sometimes
this really happened
the question is basically how can i
believe mark whitaker's confessions now
what i established in this book you know
when you have america whitaker wasn't
the only guy who was lying there were a
lot of people lying what i established
in this in this book was what i called
the pyramid of credibility
in other words nobody gets a free ride
nobody gets to say
i killed john kennedy and i print it you
know i have to be able to
find records documents other material
that backs up what's going on i will
give an example okay
sometimes you have to look at the
minutia of a story whitaker told a story
that everyone in town probably heard
about being abducted i'm going to give
this one away it's a freebie
about being abducted that he was at the
office and he was thrown into a car and
driven away and he gave some very very
specific details he said i was thrown
into a dodge dynasty and the door locks
were sawed off and these guys were rough
and tough and blah blah blah
well i talked to him about that and i
said door locks what kind of door locks
are you talking about you like those
those push down metal kind with the hole
he says yeah yeah exactly there was
sawed-off
well there was one thing that made me
very suspicious about this whole story
one was
brian shepard drove a dodge dynasty
and it was an odd car i was just like
what an odd coincidence
so i checked
the dodge dynasty never was manufactured
with little metal locks that go down
into the hole
what they had were those
you know those little gripper locks
that you pull up and even if you sawed
that piece off you could still pull it
up
so the car he was describing did not
exist
on top of that there is all the evidence
described in the book that made it very
clear you know he wouldn't tell the fbi
he wouldn't repeat it
and so
when i'm talking to him in prison i say
let's talk about the abductions okay
he goes
i said did it really happen
no
you know that one was easy and and it
was it proved it was provable that it
didn't happen that was a little proof
some of the other ones
the final
confession
which i'm obviously not telling but the
final confession
the book was was written
the final confession was an extra i
wanted him to confess
i have already had already concluded
based on the bank records the wires
where
uh
money went how it went to who what it
went from from there
you know
interviews and the rest the interviews
with the fbi things people were saying
things people were swearing to and the
original documentation that whitaker's
entire story had to be bogus it made no
sense it was completely contrary to
every record that existed
and so when i sat down to talk to him i
just laid all that out
and as he raised each
new story i said i considered that
here's what i found he would say such
things as well this individual called me
the night before and said this was
happening how could i possibly know is i
considered that when that individual
testified before the grand jury he said
this and he's a friend of yours
he contradicted you he backed you up on
everything but that
um it was that kind of conversation he
didn't have any reeds left he had no
support left by the time we were done
and also got to bear in mind
this is what he told his own wife
you know after he was in prison
he finally said it's not true he didn't
tell any of us he told her he told me
second
so i kind of think at that point if i'm
hearing what his wife is hearing during
their private visits in prison
and all of the evidence backs it up
i believe it if he comes back later and
says i was lying
i know when he's lying it's that time
you know because there's no way his
story is correct based you just
you can l you can lie as the end of the
book telephone records will document a
call but the meaning of the call can be
twisted into anything
bank records
are solid they say where the money went
you know
so
anything else
yeah well oh well is there somebody hold
on one sec let me get somebody has an
asking question
and
many times
his car repairs and he'd
this is a person saying this is somebody
who had dealings with mark whitaker who
who who uh said mark whitaker would call
to have his car when he was asking
questions about his car
and saying he was over the ocean and
flying somewhere and then later he would
tell the same story and it would be
something different you know what i've
really gone over time haven't i you know
i'm gonna take i'm gonna take three more
questions and then i'm gonna sign your
books
the question is what is he doing in
prison he is working on a tractor
he is uh he is doing work for the at the
prison and
[Music]
you know that's his job is driving the
tractor okay two left
oh maybe we're done
oh i'm sorry were there any signs of his
uh personality problems uh prior to
coming to decatur
subtle were there any signs of
whitaker's problems prior to coming to
decatur uh subtle signs very subtle
signs the kind that you just look at and
say well this is a quirky guy
um
not signs you would look at and say well
you know that he's everything that he
has now been shown to be
and so
um
you would just think that he was
eccentric nothing else
last question
do you want a second one i changed my
mind okay oh i'm sorry is that no
i guess that's it folks i want to thank
you all very much you've been a great
crowd i also want to thank the people at
walden books
in forsyth illinois who set this up who
allowed us to sit down and talk about
this case they did a wonderful job and i
can't thank them enough
and now anyone who would like a book
i will sign now remember they get they
get first dibs
because i had my back to them almost the
whole time
you know this is how about the front of
the line here kurt eichenwald has
written about business and white-collar
crime for the new york times for more
than a decade he has won the george polk
award twice for excellence in journalism
and as a finalist for the 2000 pulitzer
prize his book the informant a true
story as published by random house
or go online to cspan.org
shop and click on book tv
next from the cold war museum in
washington dc author adrian havill talks
about his book the spy who stayed out in
the cold
it chronicles former fbi agent robert
hanson's career as an fbi counter
intelligence expert
and the case that led to his conviction
on 15 counts of espionage attempted
espionage and conspiracy
it's just over 45 minutes
i'd like to take this opportunity to
introduce adrian heville he is a local
washingtonian author uh several books to
his credit which he will i'm sure go
over when he does his introduction i'd
like to call adrian up to the floor to
begin the presentation
and after the presentation is over we
will have books for sale to our left
he'll be here to autograph them
we will also have an added bonus a book
on the u2 incident and my father francis
gary powers written by chris pocock
these just came in today didn't know i'd
have them so i brought them in case
anybody was interested
we also would like to take this
opportunity to show
our gift store collection with our
patches
our lapel pins
and our t-shirts with the culver museum
logo on the front
and the u2 spy plane
skunk works emblem on the back these
make great christmas presents
uh without any further ado i'd like to
introduce adrian habil adrian
thank you
thank you
it's most appropriate that i have a
my book is titled the spy who stayed out
in the cold and i'm at the cold war
museum
of course it's named that because as
most of you know robert hansen began
spying
for the soviet union
full-time in 1985.
and when the cold war ended in 1991
december 26 if you want to
pin a date on it
that's when he more or less stop spying
but he stayed out because he began
spying again
i'm going to start by reading the first
two paragraphs of my book
and then i'll go into to some of the
things i learned in my research about mr
hansen that hasn't been in the
newspapers and hasn't been on television
spying has been called the world's
second oldest profession
prostitution of course is the first
and if you think about it the two
occupations
are not that dissimilar
a member of a brothel
applies her trade
first for the money
and then for the interesting type
of labor that is required and the
thrills it sometimes offers
in the 21st century
the thrill often comes first for someone
who chooses to spy
either for or against his country
compensation can be secondary
a way of measuring one's skills and
worth to an employer
ideology
the decision to risks one's life for a
political belief
is now a distant third
the two careers can be illegal or legal
prostitution's legality is determined by
the jurisdiction
in which the prostitute works
in the world of espionage
legality depends upon one's employers
spy for your country
and you are a quiet unsung hero
spy for another nation and you are a
traitor
a monster
getting caught while working for the
wrong side can mean
death
how can one explain robert hansen
a man who had everything a lovely wife
six wonderful children
son of a cop a 30-year veteran of the
chicago police
department
and a cop himself five years
how do you explain a guy like that
well
let me try and that's what i try to do
in my book
robert hansen was born
on
april 18 1944
in chicago inside the city limits
his father was a chicago cop who had
gone off to war in the navy so he was
away when he was
born he came back shortly
after the war ended and resumed his
career as a cop
both of robert hansen's
parents were in their 30s when he was
born
he lived and you can see the picture in
the book in a little two-bedroom
bungalow very small
and after he was born his grandmother on
his uh father's side came to live with
the family they fixed up a little place
in the attic for her
so there was robert hansen an only child
growing up in these cold chicago winters
and only child living with three
middle-aged adults
when you live like that
and you're alone
and your dad's away in the police force
at all hours of day a day and night
you
learn to develop and read one of robert
hansen's
first subscriptions when he was very
young was to mad magazine
his favorite feature in mad magazine
was if you've ever read magma mad
magazine
um spy versus spy you remember remember
that was always in the back cover
the difference about mr hansen was
he continued
to most people give up mad magazine i
remember i did when you're about 16
years old about your
towards the end of high school
he continued to subscribe to it in
college and beyond college
uh
he had that sort of fantasy life in high
school he was known as what they say
today a geek the prophet protector guy
had few friends
no dates
what wasn't uh you know didn't have a an
active social life
and after he graduated from high school
he went 200 miles away to a college in
galesburg illinois called knox college
he was a chemistry major
when you're a chemistry major
at knox college you have to take a
language he had the choice of three
languages
uh german spanish or russian
you're right he chose russia
he took two years of russian brutal grew
to like the russian
um uh literature and music which was
part of the course
and um
the really unusual part of that
is
he never told his mother or father that
he was studying russian
when he got out of knox college he
applied for a job with the national
security agency nsa up here in fort
meade maryland
he didn't get the job i'm sure they're
very happy when they learned that too
so he didn't want to go to vietnam it
was it was 66
and instead he applied to the dental
school of northwestern university
there was 3 000 applicants that year and
there were 64
people accepted he was one of those
accepted
robert hansen is
whatever you say a very brilliant man
able to grasp a lot which is why he
stayed undetected by the fbi for
decades
he knew how to cover his tracks
so he went to dental school and one of
the people i interviewed i interviewed
about a dozen people who were in the
dorm hall he was in abbott hall at
northwestern
they saw him as much as the people in
the fbi saw him a bit of a strange duck
a bit of a strange person his roommate
whose name is jerry takasano
told me
that in dental school you have to do
cadavers just like you do in medical
school
and bob hansen although everybody else
would go to college dress much the way
you are casually no tie and so forth bob
hansel would wear the black suit the
white shirt and the tie
to school every day he stood out because
he was the only one wearing a suit to
to school
and when he did those cadavers he kept
his jacket on the black jacket
and
dissected him they did it for two days
but
when he came back to the room that he
shared with his roommate he hung up his
jacket and pants and let it sit there
and his roommate told me that the
formaldehyde was you know smell was
permeating the room and it was bob
hansel was oblivious to all this he just
didn't do anything about it so
finally he had to beg him to take the
dry cleaning to uh
take the suit out for dry cleaning
because
he said he couldn't take it anymore but
bob hansen had this
life in college where he wouldn't say
anything but he would come up to a
person much as i'm told he did at the
fbi where he would just literally not
say anything and just look at them
and and look superior bob hansen six
foot three so it was easy for him to to
look down on people
um
he was very repressed then i'm sure most
of you have heard of the incident with
the uh
the stripper on m street where he
became her close friend and tried to
save her
and convert her to the ways of his
church for over two years
but there was never any sexual contact
although she certainly tried she
certainly did her part
and spent eighty thousand dollars on her
over two years
when he was in college
one of
his dorm and the dental students all
like to go to this greek restaurant
after exams
and
have a sort of a celebratory dinner of
um couscous and baklava and that sort of
thing
and
but the main reason they really like
going to this greek restaurant is it had
a belly dancer
but because it has had a belly dancer
bob hansel was so depressed he wouldn't
he was so repressed he wouldn't go with
him he wouldn't go with to the to this
and they always thought that was sort of
strange
he met his wife bonnie
in 1967 in chicago she had graduated
from loyola university and she was
working in the chicago courts
he thought she looked exactly like
natalie wood and that was his reason for
he had a crush on natalie wood in the
movies so
he
and she does look a little like natalie
wood
so he asked her out
he was a lutheran she was a catholic he
was an only child
she was one of eight children uh if i
was attract um they had something going
and she told her she told her sisters
from the start i'm not going to marry
him he's not even catholic
but within a few dates
they were engaged and she did marry him
and he immediately
um converted they were married in a
catholic church
um mary seat of wisdom uh in her
hometown of park ridge which is just
over the uh
chicago line
she was also in her family is also very
active in opus dei which is an
organization within the catholic church
he joined that as well
he became a chicago cop
um
before he became a chicago cop
in 1968 just after he got married
he read the memoir of kim philby who was
a
uh spied for russia while he was with
british mi6 for nearly 20 years
and i was talking to a friend of his by
the name of robert loren robert lauren
is now a dentist in skokie illinois
and he told me that bob hansen kept
pressing this memoir by the british spy
kim philby upon him
and he took it and took it home and read
it and then he said that bob hansen kept
pressing say you've got to give it back
i want i want the book back so finally
he brought it back around to his house
and
robert hansen says well what what do you
think of the book
and he said i thought it was okay and
bob hansen told him and he remembers it
this day he said
you know someday i'd like to pull off a
caper like that
so he was saying back then
outwardly to his friends that he wanted
to be a spy
and after he got out of northwestern he
gave up dental school
and went on didn't like it said he
didn't like spit that was his words um
he went on and got an mba in accounting
and became a cpa
worked about three months as a cpa and
became a chicago cop just like his
father but because
because he had that mba they put him in
some important stuff right away and they
put him in intelligence
with the chicago police department and
in the chicago police department what he
did was
to ferret out crooked cops he would go
in the cops who were covering up for
drug dealers and
work of that that were on the take so to
speak
his job was fair amount fared it out so
he wasn't very popular in the the
chicago police department because you're
really turning against one of your own
no matter how bad it wasn't the most
popular job to have
but i spoke with his boss who's still
alive
and he said that they couldn't wait to
get him out of there
his boss said
that they always felt the bob hansen was
the double agent inside the chicago
police department they thought that bob
hansen was a snitch who was telling
everything they were doing to mayor
daley's office
and i said well
when
he joined the fbi which was in 1976
he said he literally marched him down
there and he said you should take the
fbi job but he said i said were you ever
approached by the fbi in interviewed by
them as a background check and did you
ever tell them that he said no never
talk
never talked to the fbi
so
one of my points of this book is
is much like the events of september
11th bob hansen was really a failure in
intelligence gathering he shouldn't have
been hired by the fbi in my view
um
after he was hired by the fbi on january
12 1976
he was sent to gary indiana which is
right near chicago about 30 40 miles
outside and he did white collar crime
but because he had that mba
they certainly had more important things
in in mind for him and they soon sent
him to new york to the new york field
office where he lived in scarsdale
new york when he bought his house in
scarsdale he paid forty three thousand
dollars for it his mother-in-law told me
that scarsdale is known as a pretty
richie area in new york but his
mother-in-law told me we always refer to
that house as being in the slums of
scarsdale if there is such a thing
when he bought that house
the person he bought it from was a
dentist
like he so they went out to dinner and
he told the dentist that he had a swiss
bank account now here was a guy
making 30 35 000 a year and he's
boasting that he has a swiss bank
account even the dentist thought it was
strange at the time he also told him
that you know i wanted to be a spy ever
since i was a little boy
and in fact
in 1979
he did become a spy for the first time i
don't know
how many of you heard this story but in
1979 he actually did a one-time
deal with the russians where he got
about twenty thousand dollars and he
gave them information
his wife bonnie caught him
counting out the money in the basement
of the house
and he he assured her well i yeah i did
do this deal because all hundred deals
with the russians but i didn't give him
anything of any real importance
um but still she was pretty uh upset
about it and she said well you've got to
go tell a priest
so he went and told the uh the local
priest and the priest
said
um okay um he didn't turn him in his
wife didn't turn him in and he said
you've got to give all the money you
received to the mother teresa charities
which
he claims he did um
nobody saw him mother teresa doesn't
keep that kind of records but over the
years his claim is that he did give
the twenty thousand dollars to the
mother teresa charities
so of course in 1985 he began spying
again
and then it was in earnest then it was
like
literally every months or every other
month there was a drop
and
between 1985 and 1991
he gave nearly 6 000 pages of materials
to the russians
now
the deals he made with the kgb
the 6000 pages were really
some of our
most precious secrets nuclear secrets
satellite secrets
and if any of you know the intelligence
field you know that after the fall of
the union uh the soviet union in 1991
a lot of the secrets that the russians
had about us were then
retailed out to countries like iran iraq
china
uh they were sold to the highest bidder
i would not be surprised if the
some of those pages are sitting in a
cave somewhere in afghanistan right now
um
so
what bob hansen did can never
ever be underestimated
and why we never saw it
and why his wife never saw it i mean
when a spouse cheats on another spouse
from then on in
the spouse has been cheated on her
antenna is way up there or his antenna
is way up there
and because he was doing so much work
for the kgb between 1985 and 1991 and
then later on from 1999
why his wife
never caught it
is um i don't know if they hear no evil
see no evil
why did he do this first of all
i believe that bob
hansen although he knows right from
wrong
his lawyer wanted to
do an insanity plea bob hansen was
pretty well
crazy
you wouldn't have known it you would
think he was eccentric the eccentric
genius at the fbi because he did develop
some computer systems for them that
even tracked
uh soviet spies but he was this
eccentric uh quirky kind of guy
but you wouldn't have thought
being the son of a chicago policeman and
a policeman himself you would have never
thought that bob hansen
would have been the mole in their midst
bob hanson did some very strange things
with his family at least i mean i
believe they're strange
when his oldest daughter was
three years old he taught her to read
which is very nice i mean great
shows how smart he was when he was four
they sat down together
and they read
their first book together wasn't nancy
drew
the book they read together was the
ultimate russian novel war and peace
1450 pages if you've ever read born
peace
that was her first book it took him
nearly a year i was told
later on when they were in teens and he
was working at fbi headquarters his
daughter was
he had two daughters going to a
parochial school over in chubby chase
maryland
he would drive in every day and let them
off at the metro center when they would
take and then he would drive on to fbi
headquarters and they would take the
metro up to chevy chase
uh when he drove them in he would not
allow them to speak
instead he played tapes
of approved soviet composers mainly
for
and tchaikovsky once in a while
i was told this by
a person who wrote to
to the same school with his daughters
who wrote in the cards carpool once a
while he played beethoven but for the
most part it was approved soviet
composers
so
little things little strange things
little strange actions
um
the fbi in the early 90s with a little
boy boys club i mean he beat up a 21
year old secretary dragged her around by
the hair
because she walked out of a meeting he
was conducting
and
he got five days uh suspended without
pay but that was it he you know never
got a demotion nothing nothing ever
really happened when she wanted to take
action against uh like like legal action
sue him
she was told you know if you want to
keep your job you know this is an
internal matter and you know don't say
anything
she had when i interviewed her
early earlier this year she said she had
great satisfaction because
she was still there and he was gone
um i don't know how long i've talked
but i will does anybody have any
questions at this point
[Music]
other books were mentioned what caused
you to to take this up as your subject
right now
i've written eight books
i did not choose to write this book what
happened was
robert hansen was
arrested around little after five
o'clock on february 18th of this year
and on february 22nd
a publisher in new york had an editorial
meeting
and they said you know
robert hanson he's on the front page new
york times front page of the washington
post
we've got to have a book on this and
who shall the author be and the next
thing you know um
i get a phone call from from an editor
at st martin's press
and uh saying to call him right away
and then about five and i wasn't at home
and five minutes later there's a call
another call my answering machine from
my agent
my agent saying
don't speak to the editor until you
speak to me but if he does get a hold of
you
tell him you'll do it if it's worth your
while
i'm a good agent
jane distal so
that's how the book came and i think
they thought of me is because
they knew i lived in northern virginia
so they
knew i lived close to him and in fact i
do i mean i live six miles away from him
and it turned out because i've lived
in reston for
uh since 1989 and before that i lived in
great falls from 74 to 89.
because of that i just
um i found out that we have friends in
common i found out that we used the same
community swimming pool i had attended
the same church although i'm not a
member of that church and we we knew
many of the same people so
i was lucky in
in being able to
if i was up there in new york or in
chicago or somewhere else around the
country it'd have been very hard book to
do but but because i was like literally
his next next door neighbor
it was easier than most than many books
i've done
yes ma'am
wife's still in vienna and
how is she doing through all this
the wife is going to do very well indeed
bernadette hansen
most people call her bonnie
um
has two children that she has six
children but two children are still
living at home she has a 16 year old son
and a 15 year old
girl the other ones
there's one son who's a law student at
notre dame there's another student who's
a graduate
student at
rice university headed for a phd
and then the oldest daughter is married
with three children
she will do very well because part of
the deal that mr hanson made well
actually his attorney plato cashieris
made
is that
mr hansen will not get the death penalty
and he will tell the government
everything they want to know
and they will debrief them over a period
of six months and he'll have to take
polygraph tests on demand
and she will get what is essentially a
widow's pension she will get thirty
eight and a half thousand dollars a year
for the rest of her life
um
that's not quite enough to live on i i
think with two children
but she has not given up the house she's
still there
her parents are
very well off i'm sure they'll
help her off
help her out
and since he's been arrested
and she's been called a saint by many
people she she
teaches part time at a religious school
at parochial school
a lot of people have from the church
have actually given her money taken up
collections for her and in fact at the
end of her street
is a public school up
not a parochial school but a fairfax
county school and the crossing guards
there liked her so much
they took up a collection for and raised
nearly a hundred dollars and handed it
to her so
she's doing pretty well
she has said publicly
to friends
that she's not going to divorce him
she's going to pray for him and she's
going to forgive him and she's going to
visit him and he'll be in ellenwood
prison
which is in pennsylvania it's about a
three three and a half hour drive it is
the same prison federal prison
where mr alder james is where john
walker is and i don't know if any of you
know the cia
gun runner to libya edwin wilson he's
also there that was in the early 80s so
there's a great number of spies
at that particular there's also a great
number of
members of the mafia
yes ma'am
why has the law enforcement community
not chosen to prosecute his wife as an
accessory when she knew that he was
a spy back in the very beginning and
could have prevented all of the
subsequent years if she had gone to the
fbi
well
you know she can always say i didn't
know
it's a very hard thing to prove they did
interrogate her for
about eight hours um and they're pretty
well
sure that uh you know she didn't know
you know whether you know you have a way
of blotting things out sometimes you
don't want to know
it's very interesting that bonnie
hansen's brother
is an fbi agent in the chicago field
office
so i mean it's a good law enforcer and
another uh brother as a priest so
it's a sterling sterling family yes
ma'am
did you interview uh robert hanson
himself i did not
interview robert hanson himself the fbi
won't anybody near him they got uh they
got very wise when after alder james was
um
arrested that a a reporter snuck into
the
alexandria city jail and interviewed him
and got a number of interviews him and
they really kept this one under wraps um
i did interview his mother
i did her many times and i didn't use
mother-in-law and i did have a source
within the family that told me all these
families
you know
quirkiness that he did i guess is the
best way yes sir
i'm really quite curious
there seems to be a missing link here
between the people that you mentioned
that are former spies
and the religious affiliations
it seems like to me they all belong to
some splinter group very conservative
religious faction and the press
mentioned that
about your subject
did you
consider any of that is in terms of why
he would have done this at some
perverted
religious belief ah absolutely i do go
into that
he did have this
i'm told and i do
it goes into catholic miracles and in
1917 i'm sure you've heard of this
particular miracle there was a miracle
called the miracle of fatima in fatima
portugal
that particular miracle is also known
among catholics as god's peace plan from
russia
what that miracle states
is that
war is caused by sin
and
that russia
was going to become
eventually a consecrated nation and a
sacred nation and was not was not going
to be communist that was the second
there's three secrets of
fatima that's the second secret
i know that bob hansen had meetings with
priests about this in fact he wrote a
paper for the fbi on it
and you you
again i want to assure you that we're
talking with somebody who's a little bit
you know mentally not sound
he believed
it's my opinion
i don't know if he told the fbi
he believed
that it was only a matter of time
before
and in a short matter of time before
russia
would not be communist anymore
and would become a sacred nation
now
russia gave up
being communist in late 1991 december 26
when gorbachev renounced it all
that's approximately just after that is
when bob hansen stopped spying
he believed that russia he was about to
get his
wish come true and that russia was about
to become this consecrated sacred nation
and all these secrets that he gave him
was moot
uh you know that they wouldn't be given
up
but what happened is if you know what
happened to russia it became the wild
west out there and it was more debauched
and
worse worse than it was under communism
and sure enough he began spying again in
1999. now that's one reason he also
needed the money he also was
pretty crazy
but that's certainly there were his
religious beliefs were part of it he
also believed
that because he was a member of opus dei
he had to send his children to opus
state schools open state schools are
single sex schools they cost a little
bit more than your regular parochial
schools he had six children he had to
send to parochial school
he's at the fbi in 1985 making between
40 and 45 000
a year that's not going to cut it he
needed that money
although you know when you really think
about it the money bob hanson got
isn't all that much he got six hundred
thousand dollars from the russians in
cash tax-free
over a 15-year period that's only forty
thousand dollars a year tax-free not a
lot of money particularly when you drop
eighty thousand dollars of it on a
stripper and other crazy stuff like that
um yes sir
what type of damage did robert hansen do
to the country's intelligence apparatus
is he more dangerous or more uh worse
damage than elder james where does he
rank in in spies that did damage to the
u.s i say in my book that he's done the
most damage to the u.s
since the rosenbergs he did give up
nuclear secrets he did give up satellite
secrets he gave away the crown jewels
in fact the thing that was so amazing
about it is if you check
he was giving the kgb reports
while they were still warm i mean they
would be dated
february 1989 and he was giving them
february 1989 in other words they had
just been rolled off the press i say in
my book somewhat jokingly that the kgb
was getting him before the joint chiefs
of staff
yes ma'am
what led the fbi to begin to
question him and and believe he might he
was someone to to watch that there was a
danger he he was a spy
well
well the question was what what made the
fbi begin to believe he was uh that he
was a mole in their midst or a spy
excuse me
i wish i could say
that it was great gumshoe work on the on
behalf of the fbi it wasn't
what happened was
in september or october
of
last year 2000
there was
a russian
diplomat
inside
the u.n who wanted to defect
but he didn't want to defect without any
money and he had access to secrets
and he sold
the
u.s intelligence community this huge
file
which is bob hansen's file
now and and defected and and has
disappeared and
you know he's living the right life of
riley some
what with his little nest egg
but when they got this file bob hanson
had thought that he was so smart because
he never told the soviet union or the
russian federation his name all his
communications were done in codes either
by
raymond garcia or b he used a number of
different names he never met with him
face to face he felt they had no
pictures of him
and he was relatively careful not to put
his fingers on the he gave him computer
discs and he gave him paperwork and he
was and he was never put his
fingers on the paper so they had all
this paperwork and discs and so forth no
name and so forth they probably might
have been helped to figure it out but it
would take years
but he made one mistake
and who would have thought
every package that he ever gave the
russians
he wrapped in a hefty plastic garbage
bag and taped it up and gave it to him
i'm sure he thought
that
the hefty bags and i would have thought
so too would have been tossed and they
would just keep the paperwork but you
know the russians they kept the plastic
bags his fingerprints were all over the
plastic bags
so
once they had
fingerprints on every bag i mean all
they had to do was surveil him then then
they read all his communications with
him and there was a lot of quotes there
he liked to quote george patton
and then people said wait a minute bob
hampton bob hansen likes to quote
george patton around the hallways when
he wants to get something done
it really wasn't hard it was just a
matter of following around and uh
and catching them in the act which they
did
from your researcher from your guesses
or or whatever
do you think that there are any direct
links between that breach and our
security that hansen created in the
september 11th
tragedies do you think there's any
any cause and effect link down the chain
that that that evidence for
we we really don't know the answer that
i'm sure it'll come out in a few years
in an intelligence report to the
congress
uh it's certainly possible i'm sure
they've asked him about that
uh certainly the secrets he gave away as
i said earlier
were given to the russians after the
fall of the soviet union's a russian
sold to the highest bidder
um
you know whether some of it
wound up in the hands of arab terrorists
and has helped them
um
we won't know probably until years from
now
yes sir i spent
air force intelligence and one of the
basic premise
of any intelligence organization is
to limit the
amount of exposure
a single person
would have to any intelligence
information
need to know as a common term
how can someone
like hansen get his hands on so much
diverse information the the way he was
able to get his hands on so much diverse
information was
although he didn't have a degree in
computer science he was a computer
genius
and he know he knew how
to hack into the fbi's computer system
and and
so he wouldn't be detected
and print out
the latest documents um and while he
wouldn't print them out actually he just
put them in a disk and and take the disc
out
besides having a top secret clearance
and he was right at the top and that too
so he had access in fact one of the
things that he did
always did
is he would word search for his name or
his address and so forth to see if they
were on to him he would go through all
the computer systems every every month
or so to see if you know his name came
up on some surveillance chart he knew
how to do all of that he devised the
systems that the fbi had
many of the computer systems that they
used to track so it was like
he was the fox in charge of the henna
house so to speak
yeah it is bad
does he have any remorse
does does robert hansen has any remorse
that's a good question i will tell you
this
in july of this year he pleaded guilty
to the charges
and on the day he pleaded guilty
there was about i was in the courthouse
and i sat on the side where the jury
normally seats so i was looking out
towards the audience
and that day there was between 25 and 30
fbi agents in the courtroom
came to see him plead guilty came to see
what he looked like you know and they
all knew him pretty much
and before and the judge said you know
how do you plead and before he
said guilty
he turned around and he looked at the
fbi agents many he that he knew and i
could see him quite clearly and he gave
him this little um
smirk for one of a better word a sort of
like a smile smirk
and it was quite in and they grimaced
they uh that was not what they expect
there was no sign of remorse in that
expression
um
it was uh it was quite a sight to behold
he didn't like the prison food in the um
he was apprehended in of course on
february 18th and by july he had lost
about 40 pounds
his lawyer played a cashieris
who defended him and also defended alder
james
told me that maybe he should go into bob
hanson's cell for a few weeks because
he's quite poorly and maybe he could
lose some that way too
any uh yes sir
did the information that he gave the
russians
directly lead to the death of any assets
uh the question is
did the information he gave to the
russians lead to the death of any
men yeah well at least two
and possibly three for sure
uh in 1979
when he did say he told his wife he
didn't really give up anything
he really did he gave up the name but
other
other double agents also gave up the
name
of a uh russian uh colonel by the name
of uh his code name was top hat and his
real name is last name is pauli polyakov
and um
so he gave up him
and in 1985 the very first thing he did
his very first communication to the
russians
is he asked for a hundred thousand
dollars he only gave him fifty thousand
and he gave up two names um
martinoff and um motorin
sergey
martin off and i can't remember the
other gentleman's first name
and also boris hewson boris hewson was
not executed um
served about nine years in a soviet
prison camp and then was led out by
boris yeltsin on an amnesty the other
two were executed however alder chambers
also gave up those names
and
alder james and another spy by the name
of edmund howard
he also gave up those names so he was
like either the second or the third uh
cooperation to the of those names but he
certainly gave him up he may have known
that they had already been compromised
and that
what he was doing was was moot and it
didn't matter he may have felt it didn't
matter because i did find this
i did find that that in many ways bob
hansen is a very kind man
as crazy as he is
and it was always even in college like
he would tutor people for free
but he was also
very
quirky and nutty
yes sir
if you could
say one thing that motivated him you
talked about money you talked he's kind
of weird uh crazy is there one thing
that you have concluded that was his
motivation
well
i don't know if any of you know the
acronym that they use for the motivation
of spies it's called mice m-i-c-e
and it's
money
ideology
compromise which is another word for
black black male and ego
of those four things
um ego and money forget about ideology i
mean there was no ideology
um
in there the fact with our spies there
hasn't been any ideology for decades
but
i think money was probably the first but
he had this
he had this fantasy life you know when
they
after they arrested him they surround
his house and search his house
inside his house
they found uh he had this locked
computer room in the basement three
computers
um he did most of his work on an ibm
thinkpad 365e
in the ibm
thinkpad
they found that you know when they
hacked into it and found out what sites
he had been visiting
one of his favorite sites was the james
bond website
and uh
you're talking about a guy who really
felt that he was nutty and fantasy and
he had actually voted for his favorite
james bond which was sean connery and
then he had voted for his favorite
james bond movie what do you think it
was
from russia with love
you know um and then of course when they
looked in the basement they found 14
guns 14 weapons including an ak-47 but
most of his fall two of the guns was the
walther ppk which was james bond weapon
of choice in all of his movies he didn't
have one he had two and it's a little
gun it's a little gun but uh
so he had this crazy uh fantasy life so
part of it was this ego fantasy thing
and part of it was the money to put his
kids through school
yeah gary i've heard that when the
search was on to to find out who the spy
was within the fbi or the cia that a cia
agent was
blamed or they the the government
thought a ci agent had done these acts
until robert hanson was caught
do you mention anything about this in
your book and can you comment i did and
that's very true and the cia agent that
they suspected and they and they put him
on administrative leave and really gave
him a hard time
looks like bob hansen
uh lived on the same street as bob
hansen at one time
so i guess they had all these parallels
not the street he lives on now but bob
hansen when he first moved to vienna
lived right near the vienna metro stop
opposite notaway park in fact where he
lived you could walk out the backyard
and walk practically right into notaway
park if you know the area and not away
park became and was his favorite drop
site that's where he made more exchanges
with the russians uh
um he kept it pretty easy on himself all
of his sites were like within
a mile or two at his house later on
there was actually one in rock creek
park but for the most part they were
close to home
yes sir
we talked about this a little bit before
uh
do you have any insight into in 1979
when he went to the gru
and offered
some secrets
why he went to the gru then at that time
rather than the kgb
at that time he was in charge of
tracking
soviet
diplomats
inside new york city not just the ones
who worked with the u.s but the ones who
work for the various trade organizations
and i'm sure he came in contact with gru
people all the time 79-1 unlike the ones
from 85 on he probably learned his
lesson that was a face-to-face meeting
i'm told
is that
um that's it i'll be glad to sign books
i'll be glad to speak with anyone after
the uh
meeting and uh thank you very much for
having me
adrian on behalf of the cold war museum
for coming out here tonight for our
lecture i'd like to present you with one
of our patches oh wow and one of our
lapel pins from the cold war museum
in closing i want to say a few brief
remarks and then we'll line up for the
book signing
on november 18th the culver museum will
be hosting a robert hanson spy tour so
if anybody would like to attend they can
log on to www.spytour.com
to find out more information
if anybody would like to find out more
about the cold war museum our website is
www.coldwar.org
and if you'd like to get on our email
list we have a sign up sheet here or
else they can send an email to info
coldwar.org and we'll respond with
questions or answers so thank you all
very much for attending we appreciate
your support
[Music]
adrian havill is author of the spy who
stayed out in the cold
it's published by st martin's press
for more information
visit them on the web at st
martinspress.com
[Music]
created by the cable television industry
now from dartmouth college in hanover
new hampshire author david weiss
discusses his new book the bureau in the
mall
it's about former fbi agent and accused
spy robert hansen
during this hour-long event the author
details mr hansen's rise to the fbi and
what eventually led him to work as a
double agent for the soviet union
good afternoon i am barry shearer
provost of dartmouth college
i'm very pleased to welcome you to
welcome you to the third of six lectures
in the montgomery endowment series
entitled intelligence the need to know
initiated by bob wilson class of 63 this
series is designed to bring an array of
experts to the dartmouth community to
examine intelligence issues which were
brought to the nation's keen attention
by the tragic events of september 11th
the lectures will continue to be offered
each tuesday through february 26th here
in filing auditorium
this series is made possible through the
generosity of kenneth montgomery class
of 25 and his wife harold who created
and funded the endowment in 1978 so that
dartmouth could bring outstanding
individuals to campus
throughout the years these guests have
enriched the opportunities already
available at the college by
complementing the regular curricular
offerings of the institution
they have come not only from the
academic world but from the non-academic
spheres as well we're indebted to the
montgomeries for initiating this
endowment
we have heard in previous talks from
mark correct former officer in the cia
and james woolsey former director of the
central intelligence agency
today's speaker is david weiss
a graduate of the university of
pennsylvania he has an mba from the
wharton school and an honorary doctorate
of literary letters from cumberland
university
he also studied at the london school of
economics
vice was a successful wall street
investment banker at goldman sachs and
company when he decided that he wanted
to pursue a career in something he loved
journalism
it is reported that during an interview
at the wall street journal with howard
simons and ben bradley
simon said now wait a minute let me get
this straight you have your mba or a
successful banker in wall street and you
want to become a journalist do your
parents know what you're doing
[Music]
it's not clear whether or not they did
but in any case it turned out to be a
good move he is a recipient of numerous
honors and awards for his journalistic
skills covering wall street and the
financial world including the pulitzer
prize in 1990 for a four-part series the
man from wall street john shad's reign
at the sec
he received numerous awards from the
maryland delaware dc press association
for coverage of the nation's capital
city and other groundbreaking journalism
he currently covers the fbi and the
justice department
mr vice's most recent success his book
entitled the bureau and the mole hit
number five in the amazon.com bestseller
list in his first week of release and is
now on the new york times bestseller
list
it will be made into a movie by jerry
bruckheimer films and disney's
touchstone pictures
in this exciting book david vice writes
that the fbi was warned 11 years ago
that agent robert hansen might be spying
for the russians but the bureau failed
to investigate for nearly a decade it
was a gargantuan blunder vice wrote in
describing one of the most damaging
espionage cases in u.s history
in a live online interview vice said
that hanson was never given a lie
detector test or subjected to
psychological examination during his
25-year fbi career
in the aftermath of his case the fbi has
begun the process of implementing
tighter screening procedures not only
when agents are hired and trained but
during their careers they have begun
with polygraphs the fbi resisted
implementing these measures for fear of
breaking the bonds of loyalty and trust
within a bureau
let's hope that the information he
shares with us today about the fbi will
be more encouraging as he speaks on the
secret story of the modern fbi and
america's silent war
please join me in welcoming david weiss
[Applause]
thank you very much for that very
generous introduction uh
it's a pleasure to be here as part of
this
lecture series it's it's great to be
back the last time i was here at
dartmouth was quite a number of years
ago i was working on wall street and i
flew up on a very very icy cold day
to try to see if i could convince a few
seniors here to come to work at goldman
sachs
and i was in completely and totally
unsuccessful that day
so my hope is that all of you who are
here today will help me feel better
about hanover and better about dartmouth
because if you don't purchase some
copies of the bureau on the mall here i
have to take all these back with me in
my small backpack to washington so i'm
counting on you after this lecture to
help me out
where were you on september 11th when
you heard the news
where were you
were you at home
were you at work
were you talking to a friend
what was the first thought that came to
your mind
on september 11th
who did you call
who did you email
what did you think about
did you wonder
if someone you knew or someone you loved
might have been killed
in that disaster
september 11th
a day that none of us will ever forget a
horrors
reach this shore
a day
for many americans
not unlike december 7 1941
when pearl harbor was bombed
people remember that day too
and where they were
when they first heard the news
both i submit to you today
december 7th 1941
and september 11 2001
represent
colossal intelligence failures on the
part of the united states of america
in 1941
after the japanese attack on pearl
harbor
the congress of the united states
launched a series of hearings
very shortly after that surprise attack
to determine
what went
wrong
why had the united states been taken by
surprise
in that attack
what happened
in the aftermath of the terrorist
bombing on september 11th
no such thing has occurred in washington
still to this day
people are
reluctant politicians are reluctant
to question administration officials
to raise any questions publicly
not only about
the campaign taking place militarily
in afghanistan
but about why
the united states
was taken by surprise
not a hearing
not a tough statement
no one
wishes to journey there
what's changed what happened
why didn't the united states know
what was coming the greatest and most
powerful nation on this earth
taken by surprise
in a ruthless
but clever
and terrible
attack
on the pentagon
the world trade center
and in pennsylvania
where some courageous passengers aboard
an aircraft prevented
another plane from landing in washington
and causing further bloodshed
inside the federal bureau of
investigation
inside its nerve center known as psych
the strategic information operations
center
there is a room
it's smaller than this room
and 24 hours a day seven days a week
under fbi director louis
free a group of people in that room
monitored
osama bin laden
around the clock
no
breaking the action there
around the clock
all day all night day night weekend
poster on the wall of that room
osama bin laden the face of evil
so how is it possible then
given the fact that preventing a
terrorist act not just responding to one
but preventing a terrorist attack
on these united states
how is it possible then
that we were taken by surprise
why
has this tragedy of september 11th
become
such a grave intelligence failure and
why is it today
that we are living
with its aftermath
some
months before september 11th
i had begun covering the justice
department and the federal bureau of
investigation for the washington post
and i was on the beat
for about a year and a half
when a story broke
and actually was about one year ago now
was february
2001
and the story was about a man named
robert phillip hanson
married
six children
goes to church every morning
confession
on a regular basis
waved the flag on the fourth of july
a 25-year veteran of the fbi
who secretly
unknown
to his family
unknown to his friends
and unknown
to the director of the fbi
had been spying for the russians
giving up
the most sensitive intelligence secrets
ever sold
by a mole within the bureau
how could this be
after all
fbi director louis free
is a very very bright man
and a solid fbi guy
he went to the same church as robert
hansen their children attended the same
school
friends in the same community
both at the bureau
both live in northern virginia
nobody had a clue
why
well for one thing
robert hansen
was a very
very
devilishly
clever spy
even the russians
imagine this
for the 20-year time span
that he was conducting espionage
even the russians never knew his name
he concealed his identity
for 20 years
he was
shrewd enough and bright enough
to hand pick
the person who would be his handler
in the russian embassy in washington a
man named victor cherkashian
he was
careful enough
to spy
and to refrain from spying on several
occasions during the period from 1979
until his arrest
in february of last year
he had self-discipline
he had a motive
and he was
in the words of one former fbi director
the intelligence communities equivalent
of a 500-year flood
this is a man
who sold the russians
the super-secret plan
for how the united states would operate
where the president would go where the
vice president would go where the
congress would go where other top
ranking federal officials would go in
the event of a nuclear first strike
the continuity of government plan
that robert hansen sold
to the soviet union
quite literally increase the risk of
nuclear war because the russians
believed that they could prevail in such
an attack
for a number of years
a 500 million dollar spy tunnel
underneath the russian embassy in
washington dc
built a taxpayer expense
a clandestine operation
the joint work of the fbi
and the national security agency
compromised by hanson
instead of being a great source of
intelligence
the russians used that spy tunnel
in a as part of a disinformation
campaign
and it gets more personal too
in his very first communication with
victor churchian
robert hanson revealed the identities of
a number
of russians who had secretly been
recruited by the united states to
provide us with intelligence
called back to russia under false
pretenses
they were put to death
a bullet to the back of the head in
lubianca prison
the gravity and the breath and the
prolific nature of his spine has no
parallel
in this nation's history
we're talking about a man with the
access
at the highest levels of security
clearance
and with the computer skills as well
who sold secrets not only from the fbi
but who gave up secrets
from the national security agency
the cia
the white house national security
council
and the defense intelligence agency at
the pentagon
no one in american history has ever done
anything quite like this
when i
first began covering this story
and i read
the affidavit in the case
i immediately saw a movie in my head
after all the story played out largely
in washington
hanson refused all russian requests
to travel abroad to ever meet face to
face
with his handler or others
he preferred a method
that
was very crude and simple and brilliant
all at once
he would leave information
under foot bridges
in parks near his home in northern
virginia
signal the russians
with masking tape
they would pick up the information which
he left in black hefty garbage bags
and
they would pay him in cash
six hundred thousand dollars in cash
over about twenty years and diamonds
but this wasn't really about money
sure money may have been a trigger
money may have been a way of keeping
score
this was about
something else
robert hansen
was a man who
from his earliest days
as a child
felt
the very
rough hand of his father
he was an abused child
whose father a chicago policeman himself
constantly
put his son down
emotionally if not physically
when young bob as a teenager went to get
his driver's license
his father actually bribed the driving
instructor in chicago to flunk his son
a remarkable act
and bob learned about it
so his feelings of alienation began as a
young man
and grew over time
after he
joined the chicago police force
he became a member of a secret unit c5
investigating corrupt cops in his mind
who was the corrupt cop
his
father went on to become an agent with
the fbi
he held the fbi
in the greatest of esteem
he loved
j edgar hoover anything and everything
about him that he knew
a strong leader someone who didn't
waffle someone who didn't give in to the
bureaucracy
but robert hanson felt the fbi didn't
recognize his talents and skills
he lacked interpersonal
skills
that would have enabled him perhaps with
his
genius
to rise through the ranks to a senior
level position
and so he felt frustrated in his career
he dressed in black
like hoover
behind his back they called him doctor
death they called him the mortician
these were his colleagues at the fbi
but they never suspected
what he was up to
several years after joining the fbi
hanson made his way
over to russian intelligence
he had always been fascinated since
childhood by all things clandestine
and now
opportunity presented itself for the
first time
20 years ago bonnie hansen
robert hanson's wife
walked in
and
saw he became very nervous
covered up the papers that he had in
front of him
she thought maybe he was writing a love
letter
to another woman
that wasn't what was happening at all
in fact he was selling secrets to soviet
military intelligence
but he told bonnie when she asked
that he was actually tricking the
russians
selling them worthless information
in exchange for twenty thousand dollars
in cash
bonnie said hmm just doesn't sound good
to me
i think we need to go see a priest
and so they did
they went to see a man named father
buccarelli
his initial instinct was
you know you ought to turn yourself in
this is a crime you've committed
i can't decide here but they
asked the priest to consider and
reconsider
what it is he would direct them to do
bonnie was a very religious woman
devout catholic member of opus dei a
very strict
movement within the catholic church
and so when father buccarelli came back
and said
what you need to do
is
give that twenty thousand dollars to the
charities of mother teresa
and promise you'll never do this again
and seek forgiveness
everything will be okay
and that's what hansen did
promised never to do it again
not the first time he'd broken a promise
in fact one week into his marriage
broke a vow he'd made
only days earlier
his wife got a phone call from another
woman in chicago
saying
he really wanted to marry me
not you
and so she confronted her husband
and he said
i made a mistake i'll never do it again
i'll never do it again
robert hansen
is
emblematic
of
a certain
breed of person who can live with
unbelievable conflict
in life something
i venture to say not one of us in this
room could do
he
developed and his mind developed in such
a way
that he compartmentalized
all these things that were occurring at
the extreme
how can you be the father
of six children
a devoted spouse
a man who waves a flag on the fourth of
july
and simultaneously
secretly
spy for the russians while you're
working for the fbi
post erotic stories about your
relationship with your wife
on the internet
and even
do something that is unspeakable
something i discovered in the course of
reporting the bureau in the mall
place a spy camera in your own bedroom
in your own bedroom
so that your best friend could watch
while you and your wife
have sex
i'm not making this up
this really occurred
and i think the most shocking thing
the most shocking thing i learned in the
course of reporting the bureau on the
mall
was that in 1990
an fbi agent by the name of mark walk
still an agent with the bureau in
chicago
became suspicious
he was robert hanson's still is robert
hanson's brother-in-law
and he learned that there were thousands
of dollars in cash at the hansen's home
in northern virginia
he knew that robert hanson worked soviet
counterintelligence
he knew you couldn't have that kind of
cash around
on a g-man salary
mark walk was torn imagine imagine put
yourself in his place for a moment
are you loyal to family
do you tell your sister what it is you
found
are you loyal to country
are you loyal to the bureau what do you
do
mark walk made the hard choice
he went to his superiors at the fbi
and he said
i believe you need to open an
investigation
into
espionage on behalf of the soviet union
carried out by robert hansen
never told bonnie
but he told his bosses at the bureau
the information was passed
from the chicago field office of the fbi
to headquarters in washington
there's a very short chapter in the
bureau on the mall
it's called the fbi's blunder
unfortunately i think you know why
the bureau failed to follow up on that
information didn't come in through an
800 number
it didn't come in
through an anonymous tip robert hanson's
own brother-in-law turned him in in 1990
and the bureau dropped the ball
unfortunately
and it is i'm sorry to say somewhat
reminiscent
of what happened prior to september 11th
when information came in from
minneapolis
to fbi headquarters that there were some
people
seemed rather suspicious because they
wanted to learn how to fly planes but
they didn't want to learn how to take
off or land
it wasn't clear what to do with that
information either
one right after september 11th
bonnie hansen
was aghast
she was mortified
like the rest of us she was very upset
about what occurred
but unlike the rest of this
she feared
that her husband would be blamed for
what happened on september 11th and why
was that the case
according to u.s intelligence and bonnie
knew this
a software program
that robert hanson sold to the soviet
union
was subsequently taken
and sold by an individual russian
to al-qaeda the terrorist network of
osama bin laden
and according to us intelligence
the possession of that software
facilitated osama bin laden's ability to
evade detection by the united states
bonnie feared that her husband would be
blamed
for the loss of life on september 11th
the fbi called her to say
this was a complex event
there are many facets to it
you don't need to spend any more
sleepless nights
than you already have over the terrible
breaches your husband has caused
directly we're not going to publicly
blame
robert hanson
for what has happened here
so then
i want to tell you for just a moment
sort of the story behind the story
when this story
broke and i reported on it for the
washington post and i saw that movie in
my head i had said to my wife for years
gee i'd like to be involved in making a
movie someday
when we walked out of out of the theater
she would laugh
maybe
and i
knew this was it
it seemed to me to be a story of
character
of treachery
of international proportion
of global dimension
and
finally a story of family
and the dynamics
of what occurs when one man
betrays his children
his wife
and his country
and so i asked our 13 year old daughter
lisa because i was very busy covering
this story for the washington post
i said lisa i need for you to burn a cd
for me please
i need some really good music
because i think it's about time for me
to pull a couple of all-nighters
and i didn't know if i could stay up
through the night
myself
without at least a little music to
listen to
so
lisa did it i popped the cd in
and i pulled two all-nighters
wrote a proposal for a movie
sent it to hollywood
and before i knew what happened
i had sold the rights to make a movie
based on a book i hadn't written without
a publisher
so i then turned around and
began to look for a publisher
who might be interested in this
unfortunately i work at a great
newspaper the washington post that's
supportive of people
taking time to dig into important
stories
to go beyond the daily news and take
things to the next level
but when i went to the publishing
community in new york
it seemed that all the publishers
had long time timetables in mind well if
you turn in a manuscript
we'll publish a book in a year 18 months
whatever
yeah there's a couple of other books
that have been signed up on this subject
already yeah we're not so sure
maybe yes maybe now and at the time
i became very frustrated because i knew
i wanted to do my best i didn't want to
compromise quality i didn't want to
compromise fairness or accuracy
something i pledge to everyone whether
it's in newspaper reporting or in
writing a book
and my test for fairness and accuracy is
what i feel the story were fair if it
were written about me
based on what i know
i asked my colleague
and mentor at the washington post bob
woodward
i said what's the fastest simon in
schuster ever turned around one of your
books
knowing of course that i'm not bob
wooper
and he said about three to four months
so i suggested to the literary agent
that he find someone who was willing to
publish a book in about three or four
months
and fortunately there is one publisher
left among the majors only one in new
york
that is not part of a large conglomerate
and
that publishers grove atlantic atlantic
monthly press
and they said sure we'll we'll turn it
around if you can produce this book
but we want to put something special in
the contract
i wonder what that is
i said if you don't turn in a manuscript
that's completely acceptable
to us
by this fixed date in september
you have to give the entire advance back
all the money back
and that's it you never see it again
well the agent handling this became very
concerned he said to me this is
unreasonable
in writing they're only willing to
commit to publishing it within one year
they want you to give all the money back
if you don't
report and write this story in
four or five months
and they're saying they're going to turn
it around in that amount of time
he said i guess it's a deal breaker
i said no
i said if they're crazy enough to ask
somebody to give back their entire
advance
under those circumstances that tells me
they're really serious about publishing
this book
so i went forward
and
dug into the story
worked 18 hours a day with the help of
two wonderful research assistants
and a very supportive wife
and three children
and
took that room on the third floor of our
house that
we had turned into a nice playroom for
the kids
and made it into the robert hanson
bureau on the mall room
and we began to dig and dig and dig and
one thing led to another and uh finally
i submitted the manuscript just after
september 11th
publisher
had made a commitment i had made a
commitment
the fellow who was the hands-on editor
had made a commitment only he was stuck
in london and then stuck in newfoundland
and then back in london
so i had nowhere to turn in the
manuscript
i said what what are we going to do we
got to keep moving here we're going to
get this book out i want to make sure
the book is out in time for hanson
scheduled sentencing in january
so he said well why don't you email it
one chapter at a time
me here in london
at canon gate books
the editor-in-chief of canon gate will
then download this one chapter at a time
print it out and give me a copy
so that's what we did
and
my good fortune in the process of doing
that the editor at canon gate
took a look at this and said i want to
publish this in great britain
and so the book is is being published
around the world not only in the united
states
and
robert hansen
himself
is now
in the process of being debriefed
the events of september 11th caused
his sentencing to be rescheduled from
january until this may
he's being questioned by
fbi
cia
and those from other intelligence
agencies that have a direct interest
in this matter
he is still
a man who can hide in plain sight
he is still a man
who is a master manipulator without
appearing to ever manipulate anyone at
all
his wife upon reading
some of the correspondence he'd had with
the russians asked him did you really
mean it
when you wrote to them and you asked for
an escape plan to moscow were you really
going to leave me
and he said no no no no
no
that was just to make them feel like i
was a real spy
and
you're everything that's love to me or
everything that's life to me without you
bonnie
there'd be no reason for me to go on
living
and bonnie hansen accepted that
as well as her husband's apology
she prays for his soul every day
visits him
and
her children
as you might imagine with six ranging in
age from a daughter in high school
to a daughter with children of her own
who's in her 30s
have
their own discussion and debate going on
about all of this
what does it mean
for their family what does it mean for
their children what does it mean for
their children's children
robert hanson
as a young man
had a role model and an idol kim philby
kim philby was a british spy
mi6
ultimately defected to moscow
more typically we hear about someone who
wants to grow up and be michael jordan
or
the next great rock star
but here is a man who grew up who has a
boy
actually had a spy as a role model
25 years at the fbi not a single
polygraph test
the fbi was looking for a mall
along with the cia
from 19 from the mid 1990s forward
knowing with great certainty
that there was another mole out there
after alder james was arrested
ames a c.i.a
spy
for the russians
handled by the same man victor's your
cashion
said your cash and had
one spy over at langley
one spy inside the bureau
and
it was very clear after alder james
arrest
that there was another mall because ames
knew nothing about certain things that
u.s intelligence had learned the
russians knew
so the hunt began the hunt for the mole
and it went on and on
the cia in the aftermath of the aldr
james case instituted mandatory
polygraph testing
on a regular basis for all employees
the fbi on the other hand
for a variety of reasons
resisted polygraphs
except for newly hired employees
so the new recruits at quantico
at the lowest level of security
clearance
go through physical examination
psychological examination
polygraph and the rest but the higher
and higher robert hanson went
in the fbi
nobody ever asked him
any questions
that he had to answer
under oath or with a polygraph that
might have detected something now
granted
polygraphs are not foolproof people beat
polygraphs all the time polygraphs
aren't even admissible in many legal
situations
but like a blinking yellow light
polygraphs do serve as a deterrent
to espionage
might make somebody stop and think twice
so the fbi in the aftermath of the
hampton case among other things
has begun to polygraph on a regular
basis its employees
something that had been strongly
resisted
in part because the fbi
is a very
solid organization which much like a
fraternity is built on trust
an fbi director louis free was concerned
that introducing polygraphs might hurt
that culture
of trust
in addition there was a problem that had
occurred at the cia
when they began polygraphing people it
turned out they asked them questions
about their personal lives and their
work lives
the needle was very steady when they
asked them about their work lives
but when they asked them about their
personal lives
the needle went kind of haywire
a lot of people
apparently didn't tell the truth when
they were asked questions about their
personal lives and so a lot of valuable
cia
operatives
because of unresolved ambiguities on
polygraphs
now sit taxpayer expense
and langley unable to work for the cia
louis free didn't want the same thing to
happen to the fbi
so when the fbi ultimately did in the
aftermath of the hanson case
begin polygraphing employees
the beer only went so far on the
personal side stuck to the work stuff
more closely
let's remember
that
it would have been very easy
for robert hanson to go on spying
undetected
for a longer period of time
if the fbi had not run
what in the end under louis free's
direction
was a very difficult operation
to nail the mold
there were some misfires to be sure
there was one employee at the cia
who was
accused of being the mole
whose daughter
who also worked at the cia was taken
into a room she was shown a map
we know your father is the mole
she was told by her interrogators
because here's the map
we see where his dead drop sites are we
know there's been activity in there
we've seen the russians around there
turned out the cia
agent
lived very near robert hansen
and liked to go jogging through that
park
that was his jogging map
and a terrible mistake was made
in that instance
but ultimately
the
cia the fall of 2000
got the original
kgb file on hanson
and turned it over to the fbi
the original documents
the russians are so good at spying they
don't allow copies of documents to be
made that are such a sensitive nature
i think a government built on deception
breeds good spies
brilliant spies in some ways be very
difficult for the united states ever
to run us by for 20 years
the way the russians did hansen and not
know his identity not give in to that
normal human impulse to hide behind the
tree and maybe take a look but remember
if you stuck around to take a look there
was a big risk
not just that hansen might see you but
that someone from the fbi might be
following you
if the fbi was on your trail and you're
a russian in washington
and then the fbi
intelligence expert following you might
see hanson there blow the whole
operation they cared much more about the
value of the information than they did
about knowing his identity
think for a moment about that
that
withstood
the collapse of the berlin wall
the disintegration of the soviet union
economic political and social turmoil
and hanson resumed the spying
in 1999 when vladimir putin came to
power in russia no coincidence
putin
as i'm sure many of you are aware was a
high-ranking kgb man
himself
so in the fall
of 2000
the fbi got a file
and it still wasn't clear
from that file who hansen was he used
aliases in all of his communications
with the russians ramon garcia
was the name he used most often they
also called him b
but robert hansen had forgotten to do
one thing
he didn't wear gloves in the cold
and the russians had saved one of those
black hefty garbage bags
cia got the bag
gave it to the fbi
fbi took fingerprints off that black
garbage bag
and identified hanson
but
the bureau still couldn't move in on
hanson and arrest him what are you going
to charge him with who are you going to
put on the witness stand
nothing but a circumstantial case
so the fbi recalled hanson
from
the state department where he had been
detailed
put him into an office
told him he was being promoted
and
watched him 24 hours a day seven days a
week cut off his access to sensitive
information
bought a house
up the block from hansen in vienna
watched him there too
and waited
until hanson made plans for his next
dead drop
and on february 18th
2001
hanson woke up
went to church with his family
same church
as fbi director louis free they would
sit on opposite sides hanson's family on
the left side the free family on the
right side
he came home after church
his friend jack hoshar was there
they chatted outside
played frisbee
with their dog named sunday
and
before
too long it was time for jack to go to
dulles airport
and so hanson said let me
let me get a few things together jack
and then i'll take you to the airport
let me put those intelligence documents
together
and
he handed
jack coshauer
a book before he left the house now he
did not hand him the bureau on the mall
because that hadn't been written yet
but he handed him a book by one of his
favorite authors
a man by the name of g k chesterton the
book was called the man who was thursday
it's a very very interesting book
it's a book hansen identified with
strongly
and when he gave that book to jack
hoshaur
his closest friend his friend who he had
let watch
things that other people shouldn't watch
he said
these words
things are not always the way they seem
and when the news came out two days
later
jack koshar had those words ringing in
his head
things are not always the way they seem
after he dropped jack hoshar off at
dulles airport hanson went to foxton
park in northern virginia
he left
that hefty garbage bag full of documents
underneath the footbridge
the russians had left him fifty thousand
dollars in one hundred dollar bills not
far
away here was a man
who
truly had a fractured ego seeking
recognition
affirmed over and over again in
correspondence by the kgb
the friendly folks at the kgb who wrote
to him and always addressed him with
dear friend
dear friend
and hansen left those documents under
the footbridge and on his way walking
back to the car
he was surrounded
by fbi agents who told him to freeze
at fbi headquarters inside
psych
was fbi director louis free inside that
nerve center
presiding over the arrest
of robert hanson
at the moment of his arrest
as they slap the handcuffs
on
robert hanson asked a question which to
this day still haunts the fbi
he looked at them and he said
what took you so long
what took you so long
it's a remarkable story the bureau and
the mall and what i've tried to do
is tell you the story not only of robert
hansen in this book but also the story
of fbi director louis free an amazing
man
they both joined the bureau around the
same time
they had so many things in common yet
one became the director
the other became the biggest spy in
american history
and their lives were joined together
finally
on that
day
when free presided over his arrest
now all of you who are here today
i need your help
because i am now consultant
to the movie
and i need to help
hollywood figure out who plays louis
free
and who plays robert hanson so now all
of you here please consider yourselves
consultants to the consultant
because i'm not sure
exactly who ought to play louie and who
ought to play hanson
challenging part
challenging parts
and if you don't have the answer today
please log on to www.bureaunthemold.com
where i answer questions and accept
suggestions and
try to correspond with anyone and
everyone who has thoughts or ideas about
this
look forward to answering your questions
again i want to thank dartmouth
montgomery endowment
it's a privilege to be here with all of
you today thanks
[Applause]
mr we happy to answer questions and
afterwards again it will be
an opportunity
and he'll be signing books up front i do
want to say since this is being taped by
c-span if you do have a question when
you're recognized please wait until your
hands and microphone before you ask the
question
[Music]
hi thank you very much that was very
interesting i think i heard that on npr
so it was interesting to hear it again
did you say it was the cia who finally
got the um
the
um folder on him
that's correct the cia
operating operating in
moscow right and how did they get it
moscow right and how did they get it
when i began covering the justice
department and the fbi for the
washington post
i promised
a couple of things to the folks at the
fbi and
at justice i said i would never get in
the way
of a legitimate law enforcement
operation and i said that i would never
put anyone's life in danger
or give up anything i knew to be a
sensitive national security secret
and this is leading me to where you
think it's leading me
next question
it's a great question the details
i mean
at the at the most general level i can
tell you that there was a source
developed
money changed hands
information was
sold someone took an enormous risk
and the cia succeeded in getting those
original papers back including
actually one tape recording
that was among the documents
and which on a voice-enhanced basis also
aided in the confirmation that it was
robert hanson
yes
having having read your series in the
washington post it seemed um that hansen
didn't do this for the russians he did
it almost against the fbi is that your
conclusion that he was so
disenfranchised
i think that this was not motivated
whatsoever by ideology
he didn't do this for the russians he
didn't do it for the communists
he did this to be the best spy possible
he did this to get back at his dad
to get back at the fbi
he did this to feel like a player
think about this for a moment a man who
feels overlooked
a man who's been put down since he was a
kid
suddenly made himself into such an
important
player that he was communicating
directly with the head of the kgb
at the highest levels of the russian
government and so he didn't do it
for ideology he didn't do it because
anyone forced him into it he wasn't
recruited he volunteered
and yes an answer to your question he
did it in some ways out of ambition
and out of a drive
related to ego
he wanted to be
james bond
and he was better than bond
fascinating story but it leaves me more
uncomfortable than ever how what took
them so long you know you started your
talk about
the um that there was information known
about september 11th etc and yet
it seemed like nobody
everyone was asleep
i mean why is that the case and has it
changed or don't you know
well it's it's i think it's the question
on the minds of every american
you know
do we really know do we know where osama
bin laden is now
no we don't apparently if public
officials
are telling us the truth and there's no
reason to disbelieve them
i think
that the events in the hanson case
reflect
the fact that
the
bureau
had something of a hollow middle and
still does unfortunately what do i mean
by that
terrific
new recruits
hungry young talent
joining the fbi
extraordinarily bright committed people
at the top of the fbi running various
divisions
but in between
a great deal of inexperience
and
in the middle management layers
the fbi does not have as deep a bench as
it wishes it did
and
the result of that
is that
the fbi
doesn't always know what it knows
people are fond of saying well it's the
unknown unknown you can't plan for the
unknown unknown
the hard part is the bureau doesn't
always know what it knows
because
knowledge
requires analysis judgment
language specialists and more
so
i think that all of the resources of
this government in the aftermath of this
tragedy and of this country
are being devoted to
trying to prevent anything from this
like this from ever occurring again
but it's also clear that reform is
needed
and that was clear even before september
11th
and fbi director free was in the midst
of trying to make changes
fbi director mueller is doing the same
now
others in the intelligence community
share the sentiment there is a
tremendous commitment i think by a very
experienced enabled administration to do
everything in its power
but in the end
human intelligence
in terms of obtaining information and
developing informants
and human intelligence in terms of
analyzing information
ultimately
is the key
to
unlocking the door that lets you prevent
these types of acts
now the fbi does a very good job of
preventing a lot of activity that you
never hear about
kind of like the lawyers who say well
the best cases are the ones that never
made it to trial or that the public
never heard about
so there is work that goes on behind the
scenes
that around the millennium you remember
the millennium everyone was afraid
at the millennium that something
terrible was going to happen
the fbi working with other
federal agencies
and working with
law enforcement intelligence around the
world did an outstanding job in
thwarting a number of planned attacks
in connection with the millennium
so
i i think you have to recognize
that this
terrorist plot
that occurred
exceeded
the expectations of its perpetrators
and
it is very very difficult i think for
people in positions of leadership
to do anything
to this day
but focus on trying to prevent something
like that again the reality remains
that the fbi is outstanding at
investigating crimes and other problems
after they occur
but not before now prior to september
11th
the fbi which had developed a global
network under louis free the fbi has
had built a permanent presence which it
has now in over 40 countries around the
world
but the fbi was still trying at that
point
to fight terrorism through the u.s legal
system
now the military is involved
and a much more aggressive approach is
being taken
and
i can only hope as an american
and as a husband and a father
that this approach will succeed
over time
and that the kind of resolve that we've
seen after september 11th
will find its way into an improvement in
our intelligence system worldwide
i'd like to know whether
anybody in the uh in the cia after the
aldrich ames case
and in the fbi after the hanson case
have been disciplined as a result of
their failures most especially in regard
to the brother-in-law's information
very interesting question has anybody
been disciplined in the aftermath of the
hampton case given the disclosure
prior to publication of the book
before the bureau on the mall came out i
let attorney general john ashcroft
and senior fbi officials
know
of course about a number of the things i
discovered including
mark walks disclosure in 1990 which the
current leadership was not aware of
and so in the aftermath of publication
of the bureau on the mall
the attorney general has ordered a
special investigation
into what happened to that information
at this point in time that investigation
is incomplete
and so it remains to be seen
whether anyone will be disciplined
whether those who were involved or
responsible or even still with the
bureau after all that this was
this was 1990.
so in answer to your question
no single individual has been held
directly accountable so far but i think
we have to await the outcome
of this investigation to see what will
happen
uh you indicated that hanson had sent
material i think he said software to the
russians which eventually ended up in
the hands of al qaeda
and it may have helped them in planning
for the attack of september 11th can you
elaborate on that
well i can tell you that
the information i don't think
based on
u.s intelligence the information that
hansen sold
wasn't utilized directly in the attack
but did over a period of time
facilitate bin laden's
ability to evade
and avoid monitoring
by us officials
so
indirect bearing but not
no direct cause and effect i would say
i mean let's also remember the fbi had a
room devoted 24 hours a day to watching
bin laden so
you know there are a lot of factors at
play i think here in this in this
instance and
you know the the bureau on the mall
is a book
that
tells a narrative story i mean it's a
true story it's written like a novel
and it it takes you through
not only the lives of hanson and and uh
free
but it takes you through very precisely
what hansen betrayed what he sold so at
the back of the book there are three
sections that i added as appendices
the first is the betrayals of a spy
second
that lists all the things he sold
the second is the emails of a spy
and the third in his own words sexual
fantasies of spy
i've noticed a lot of people read this
book from the back to the front
okay maybe just one last question please
okay and um earlier hearing about the
hanson case i've been uh amazed by how
much he knew
and wonder how
how can you give us any idea of how many
people are at that level in the
fbi i don't think that there are
a dozen people
i mean he was in the perfect position
to carry this out
i don't think there are a dozen people
who would have had access to the same
mix of information and also
he knew how to cover his tracks
there was one thing that occurred some
years back he told
one of his superiors at the fbi
that this computer system at the bureau
was vulnerable
to someone hacking from the outside who
could get classified information
that the fbi had
and the supervisor didn't
really listen to him and hanson became
kind of agitated
because remember he's a man who has a
lot of compartments in his brain and
when he's doing his day job
he's trying to tell the bureau there's a
problem
so what did he do
he hacked into the computer himself
without asking permission of a man named
ray mislock
ray was in the midst of
reviewing a classified document
and putting it together himself
bob hanson walked into his office
handed ray mislock the document
and said see
i told you the system was vulnerable
and he said how did you get this and he
said well you know
i knew
the system was vulnerable i've tried to
tell people now i've had to show you
that it's vulnerable
and
after that
as he would go
trolling
through the fbi
electronic archives and of information
through the cia the nsa
through the national security council he
could always say
well i was doing it to see
if the system was vulnerable or not
so we had a great cover story
a brilliant spy
a clever man of technology
and
in the end i think
this
case will be celebrated
in russia
as one of the greatest
intelligence coups
ever
pulled
off because uh of russia's ability
to break all of its own rules
allowing someone to volunteer allowing
them to remain anonymous allowing them
to sell secrets for so many years
and so it'll be a case that's taught in
the textbooks
school children in moscow
and while we have our thriving democracy
here
and the russians have a government built
on deception there the next generation
of spies there will be born
of great handlers and others
and i will guarantee you that
no matter what efforts are made here
spying
and the spy game
the second oldest profession
known on this planet
will continue thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
perfect
david vise is a pulitzer prize-winning
staff writer for the washington post the
bureau in the mall is his first book
it's published by grove atlantic you can
visit the book's website
thebureaunthemold.com
for more information
[Music]
at the bottom of the hour a look at
william f buckley jr pied piper for the
establishment
first david vice talks about his two
most recent books
dave advised how does a reporter who has
written a book about robert hansen
turn and move over and do a sports book
right afterwards well
the robert hanson story the bureau on
the mall is a story of adversity over
triumph sweet redemption
book about gary williams juan dixon and
maryland winning the ncaa basketball
championship is triumph over adversity
so one is the odds over triumph the
other is triumph over the odds so
between the two of them it's brought my
life in balance
how did you get involved in both issues
well i got involved in the bureau and
the mall as the reporter at the
washington post covering the fbi and the
justice department so i was on the beat
the day the robert hansen story broke
and i immediately saw a movie in my head
and i actually wrote a proposal on that
one and sent it to hollywood and before
i knew it i sold the rights to make a
movie based on a book i hadn't written
without a publisher
and it's being made into a motion
picture and then i turned around and
found a publisher and
worked hard on what has become a
a fascinating journey for me and i think
a compelling book for lots of readers
and
the basketball book i got involved in
that i think because i've
been a big college basketball fan my
whole life and i was really moved by
uh juan dixon story uh juan grew up in
baltimore with no parents
both parents died of iv aids and he led
this team to victory
uh helped them overcome tremendous
problems going back to 1986 when len
bias died from a cocaine overdose so
sweet redemption is set against the
backdrop of the death of lim bias and
the entry of gary williams and
a real story of
sweating it out and persevering and
ultimately a story of redemption
back to the to the robert hansen story
how difficult is it to write a
contemporary story versus a story about
an event
in history because everything's changing
as you're writing right well i'll tell
you it's a great question
it is a challenge to write about a story
that is still unfolding
that's what we do every day at the
washington post in the newspaper but to
write about a story that's still
unfolding in a book
poses unique challenges
and because of the timetable of this
book and because of the nature of the
story i actually started writing while i
was still reporting the book
and then i went back and made changes
based on new information that i gained
from interviewing members of the hanson
family and from interviewing fbi and
justice department officials and so
very very challenging to do and i also
asked the publisher to give me the
opportunity to go back up to the minute
and make revisions and changes and then
i wrote an afterward
for the paperback edition of the bureau
on the mall because i wanted to be as
up-to-date complete and timely as
possible
do the american people know everything
there is to know about the hansen story
as much as we can now the american
people do not know everything there is
to know about that robert hansen story
what we do know is that he's the most
damaging spy in american history that he
was an extraordinarily complex man
uh you know he it's a story of of
daily mass weekly confession and nightly
betrayal i mean it was such a clever spy
that even the russians never knew his
identity and he spied for 20 years went
to the same church as fbi director louis
free but there are many secrets that
robert hansen still has not divulged
according to the justice department
hampton was not truthful in his
debriefing he's now in prison for life
and as a result of that rather than
going to a place like allenwood which
would be a more comfortable federal
place to spend the rest of your life he
is in a maximum security prison in
colorado and that's largely because
based on a review of information a team
led by the fbi determined that he was
untruthful in the course of his
debriefing did not live up to his plea
bargain in your opinion did this
incident shake up the intelligence
agencies enough
this incident
shook up the fbi considerably
the notion that there could be a traitor
within the fbi's midst was unthinkable
and in fact the fbi knew that there was
someone selling secrets to the russians
the fbi was completely convinced that
person worked for the cia and not the
fbi and so it shook the fbi to its core
and it has led to a fundamental
reevaluation of internal security at the
fbi your next book mr vice my next book
after the bureau on the mullen suite
redemption i don't know i'm covering aol
right now in the aol time warner story
right now i think i'll stick to the beat
writing newspaper stories for the
washington post and the robert hanson
story the bureau on the mall that's
being turned into a motion picture for
the big screen so i'm working on that as
well thank you very much thank you
john mcmanus is president of the john
birch society and author of the book
william f buckley jr pied piper for the
establishment
it's a critical examination of the life
and career of the conservative writer
and editor that's where i got my
training as an investigative reporter
but the first
job that i had when i came out here was
to work for michael mann on a on a
dramatic television series called crime
story and it's ironic that i'm here so
many years later 20 years later almost
to the day to talk about the greatest
crime and unsolved mass murder in
american history um
the morning of 9 11 i happened to be in
los angeles and my son our son
christopher was at stuyvesant high
school which is like two blocks from
ground zero and there was actually an
initial report on cbs radio that
stuyvesant had been hit and you can
imagine his mother and i just
independently across the country for one
another just you know we're beside
ourselves and at the end of the day when
it was clear that he was okay
i inquired about another friend of mine
uh who was louis garcia who's the chief
fire marshal for the city of new york
and i had met louis several years ago i
had written a novel about a fire marshal
a fictional uh mystery story called
first degree burn and i had done a
benefit for the burn fund of the fdny
and a number of the fire marshals had
come that night and one of them was
named ronnie bucca and you'll you'll
hear me talking about him tonight and
ronnie bucca i remember i had signed his
book this is fiction you're the real
thing and when you hear his story
tonight which is part of this epic story
on the road to 9 11 you'll understand
why
but ronnie was missing that morning and
i found that out a few days later
and ultimately
uh
shortly thereafter i just decided to
apply the skills that i had learned at
abc news uh as an investigative reporter
to answer two questions that every
american wanted to know how did this
happen how did the greatest intelligence
failure since the trojan horse really
not just since pearl harbor with a 40
billion dollar a year intelligence agent
series of agencies how could this
catastrophic event on the u.s homeland
have happened
why
why couldn't it have been prevented how
did we miss this
and uh could it happen again
those are the those were the two
questions and i began kicking over one
rock and then another i ended up going
to the philippines where i interviewed
the chief interrogator of ramsey youssef
was the original world trade center
bomber and as you'll see in the story
tonight he was the true architect of 9
11. i ended up meeting judith reagan in
the year 2002
she was kind enough to let me try my
hand at this level of fiction
non-fiction and the first book uh i did
was a
a thousand years for revenge
which focused primarily on the new the
two bin laden offices of origin you know
up until 9 11 as you know the whole war
on terror was fought as a series of
legal cases in these two primary offices
the fbi's new york office known as the
nyo and the office of the u.s attorney
for the southern district of new york
sdny now the sdny is the greatest
prosecutor criminal prosecutor's office
in the world it has produced people like
rudy giuliani
louis free who later went on to become
the fbi director uh patrick fitzgerald
who is currently
prosecuting as you know scooter libby in
the cia leak investigation has been the
special prosecutor
and dietrich snell who later went on to
go on the 911 commission andrew mccarthy
it's the best of the best if my son ever
aspired to be a criminal attorney this
is where i would want him to work and so
it was in this series of legal cases
investigated by the fbi prosecuted by
the southern district that the war on
terror was fought
and the main repository of knowledge
about al qaeda up until 9 11 was focused
on these two offices in new york the
oldest terrorist task force in the
country the jttf the joint terrorism
task force was in new york so we're not
talking about the wichita office of the
fbi or the keokuk iowa regional office
of the fbi we're talking about the best
of the best
how had the best of the best failed in
failing to detect this and in the
beginning when i started out this this
investigation which is now lasted more
than five years and
three books
you know i said to myself as i always do
as an investigative reporter peter are
you trying to fit a predetermined uh
story have you already decided what the
story isn't are you just trying to fit
the evidence into it or are you going to
let the facts take you where they will
and that is the question i ask myself
every single morning when i wake up i
audit myself i you know my job as an
investigative reporter is to comfort the
afflicted and afflict the comfortable if
you will as h.l menken once said and my
job is to deal with the seven ace of the
iceberg that lies beneath below the
surface
it is the seven ace of the iceberg below
the surface that sunk the titanic
and 99 of the news that you get in the
course of the day is news that the
people in power either in government or
corporate america want you to know it's
the seven days of the iceberg below the
surface that does the most harm and it's
this remarkable story about how our
primary uh u.s domestic counterterrorism
agency failed on the road to 911 that
has been my life's work since uh you
know two days after uh the greatest mass
murder in this country so without
further ado i'm gonna try tonight i
happen to go to see al gore up in the
santa barbara film festival i'd seen the
uh um the film once and i saw him
actually do it again and i was inspired
to actually do a powerpoint although
this is the macintosh version version of
that uh and uh so i i don't know if if
i'm going to do justice you know if i
can do for terrorism what al gore has
done for global warming but as you can
tell already i have kind of a new york
personality so this is going to be a
little it's going to be like al gore on
steroids tonight okay it's gonna you
know so i fit about four hours of
programming into about 60 minutes and uh
and i'll achieve that by skipping every
third word or um you know and we'll have
questions at the end so if you can give
me show cut me a little slack and show
me some patience tonight because this is
the first time i've tried to tell the
story uh and the print story verbally
and with pictures
we'll take it from there okay so now i'm
going to put my glasses on
and uh i'm going to take my jacket off
because it's hot
and i'm going to just
i better turn off my cell phone right
isn't that
what they say when you're in a movie
theater okay
we're in a kind of a movie theater and i
want to thank by the way borders this is
the second time i've had the benefit of
doing a reading signing at borders that
c-span has taped we did the first one up
in santa barbara for a thousand years
for revenge kate schwab was the manager
of the store then they just did a
remarkable job and i can't thank uh lita
enough for yosi ellison and the other
great people at this store for helping
all right
uh
triple cross uh why did i end up writing
three books uh well the first book that
i wrote focused on this new york office
and in this book i proved that
ramzi ahmed youssef the original world
trade center bomber this is an engineer
trained in wales i called him the mozart
of terror he is he was had the most
diabolical mind you can imagine he went
from building weapons of mass
destruction to be moved from a location
by truck as in the original world trade
center bomb some believe actually that
he counseled terry nichols in the
construction of the oklahoma city device
as other evidence that he may have been
involved in a plot to bomb the israeli
embassy in bangkok and he went from
building these massive bombs
to
coming up with this ingenious but
diabolical scheme to create what i call
bomb triggers little explosive devices
that he would smuggle onto the first leg
of a two-legged jumbo jet flight from
asia with american tourists get on the
plane build a little device put it over
the center fuel tank of the plane get
off the plane and then when the plane
would go across the pacific boom the
device would blow into the fuel tank
destroy the plane so this takes a an
epic criminal genius to come up with
that kind of uh you know mass murder uh
scenario and that was ramsay youssef
the
uncle of ramsay yousef as it turns out
is none other than khalid sheikh
mohammed known in the trade as ksm
he is the man that the fbi calls the
mastermind of 911 but as i will
demonstrate to you tonight and again i
offer i hope you challenge me i hope
there's some fbi agents in the audience
who can
you know bring it and you know challenge
me on any any point you want
the uh
the architect was his nephew he set the
plot in motion in manila as you'll see
and it was only the uncle that carried
out the plot
this is what we call in the trade the
ron jeremy shot
this is this is khalid sheikh mohammed
when he was arrested in march of 2003 he
is one of the high value the so-called
high-value detainees that president bush
talked about in
around the fifth anniversary that he's
had moved to guantanamo and that they
hope to have military trials for but i i
seriously doubt whether any of these
people will ever be brought to justice
we'd have to rewrite the constitution
because when they were captured they
were tortured they were in off-site
locations other countries and if
anything even resembling constitutional
rights were abandoned uh for the sake of
this war on terror so khalid sheikh
who became by the way a principle source
of the 911 commission report many of
their findings khalid sheikh i doubt
he'll ever see a courtroom and if he
does if he's convicted if the court even
this strict construction supreme court
would uphold the conviction uh that's
one of the problems that we find
i opened this book by saying that 911
has become a cold case
2973 people between new york
pennsylvania and and the pentagon those
on board the planes
and
the the bin laden off the the bin laden
alex station at cia has been closed in
the last a year
osama bin laden himself has never been
indicted for 9 11. as you know this
administration over the years since 9 11
has degraded the importance of bin laden
and dr al zawahiri the two principles
behind al qaeda because they just simply
in my opinion failed to catch them but
al qaeda as i'll demonstrate tonight
remains a top-down organization as
tightly organized as a panzer division
and they mean great harm to the united
states now
you heard me mention earlier ronnie
bucca this is a picture of ronnie booker
this is actually his mass card uh this
is a picture taken from him in 1987 and
ronnie book just to give you a little
background he was an ex-green beret he
was a firefighter a member of rescue one
now rescue one is the oldest heavy
rescue company in the world they do up
to 900 working fires a year it's their
job to go in follow the fire suppression
units into a building put their masks on
their scots bottles and go in and bring
the bodies out
in 19 in the mid 80s he was responding
to a fire in the upper west side of new
york where there when he went to the top
of the tenement building five story to
vent poke holes in the roof and a
lieutenant was trapped on the floor
below ronnie was charged with trying to
rescue him he went over on the fire
escape and typical of new york there
were what we call scissor gates you know
on the windows to protect the predator
to keep the predators from coming in
only now this lieutenant was dying so
ronnie reached over with a halogen tool
which is a forcible entry tool and tried
to pop the gates and he fell five
stories onto his back his spall was
broken on the second floor by a conduit
but he broke his back his hands his
knees he was not expected to live
let alone
return to service and in one year not
only did he go back to the fire
department but he went back to rescue
one and he was after that known as the
legendary flying firefighter he could
have retired on a three-quarter tax-free
pension but you'll see in a moment when
ramsay youssef set off the bomb at the
world trade center in 1993 ronnie that's
a picture of him that night he went into
the trade center he loved the tower the
twin towers when they were being built
his father would take his brothers to
see the construction
he considered this an affront on not
only his city but his country and he
went into that building that night this
is a disposable camera that took a shot
he went right to the edge of the b2
crater where ramsay yusef had placed a
1500 pound urea nitrate uh fuel oil
device in a yellow rider truck and that
device blew it was thank god it was not
placed against the seawall where if it
had been all of the hudson river would
have interdicted lower manhattan come up
the subway tunnels it would have made
911 look like a disney movie okay and in
fact only through the grace of god did
yusuf put the put the device in the
wrong place hoping to topple tower one
into tower two in 1993.
he created a four-story crater blew
through four stories of 11-inch thick
rebarred concrete ronnie had a friend
named kevin shea used to call him round
and he would call ronnie square like
round peg and a square hole the
nicknames and ronnie had become a fire
marshal by then but kevin responded to
that fire and he went over he and his
partner gary guido were walking along
through pitch black smoke not realizing
he went over dropped four stories into
that crater he was rescued and that
night ronnie went to see him at beekman
downtown hospital he said don't worry
ron we're going to get this we're the
fire department this is the biggest
arson fire in american history we're
going to we'll be in this we'll be in
this investigation
and sure enough because of the class
bias that exists in particularly in new
york the fbi excluded the fire
department from the investigation so
ronnie bucca went to the public library
he worked back-to-back mutual tours
which is 24 hours straight i don't even
know if you can begin to understand what
it's like to be in you know to be worked
24 hours back to back he would sleep in
firehouses go to the new york public
library educate himself on the history
of islamic terror he also it was an
active duty army reserve
in the army reserve he had a top secret
security clearance
and he was assigned to a military
intelligence unit at diac the defense
intelligence analysis center at bowling
air force base so he's down there on
weekends looking at the intel and
understanding what is going wrong with
the fbi in new york and becoming more
and more angry uh he focuses ronnie
booker very early on on the blind shake
omar abdel rahman you will hear me talk
about him tonight again and again and
again the egyptians are the key to al
qaeda below bin laden and this is about
egyptian egyptian egyptian and ronnie
bukha in 1999 i mean on his own he
didn't this is not what he did this was
just on his own he was beautifully
obsessed with the belief that these men
were going to come back
he found out he found this video of this
individual ahmed amin refi do you see
this man right here around the blind
shake holding the blind shake that's
from abc news if you actually see the
video it's startling he's moving the
blind shake through the crowd holding
his arm whispering in his ear like he's
his handler this man ronnie booker found
out was a accountant who'd been working
in the fire department for 25 years he
also found out that a year before the
world trade center bombing he had
obtained the blueprints of not only the
world trade center but the bridges and
tunnels coming into manhattan
he had lied multiple times to get a a
second id to get into metro tech the
fire headquarters where all the modern
plans of the trade center and other
buildings were
ronnie put this together on his own with
other fire marshals brought it to the
fbi to the joint terrorist task force
and he was blown off they you know they
didn't take him seriously 1999 if he had
done that if he had focused if the fbi
then you'll see that would have been
there maybe dozen
opportunity to have focused on the al
qaeda threat if they had done that then
the towers might still be standing but
um ronnie bucca was blown off by the
joint terrorist task force and you'll
find out what happened to him as we
proceed today now
i was trying to figure out when i'd
written my first book and you'll see i
had written a second book the first book
documented negligence second book
documented gross negligence on the road
to 9 11. and i was still i i couldn't
quite put it together i was beginning to
see evidence of actual obstruction of
justice by people in the bureau and the
justice department and i couldn't figure
it out why and one morning i woke up and
i said ali muhammad he is the rosetta
stone he's he's literally worked for a
time for the cia in 1984 in hamburg he
literally came to america past the watch
list ended up enlisting in the army
worked for two years for the green
berets at the john f kennedy special
warfare school at fort bragg north
carolina he worked from 1992 on as an
fbi informant on the west coast
all the time learning the fbi's entire
playbook on al qaeda
this is my moment of
you know going back and looking at the
you know trying to sync the visual story
with the epic story so
i realized one day i'd written about ali
muhammad in each of my first two books
i'd had like maybe a page and a half
about him and i and then i realized that
if i could figure out the story of ali
muhammad maybe i could understand how
the fbi failed now i'm just going to
read you a section uh uh because this is
after all called a reading and signing
so i figured i don't want to disappoint
you so i'm just going to read one little
section of my book just a page to give
you an idea of like the way i write and
what this book is about and by the way
this book is so heavy you could use it
to press your shirts i mean it's about
670 pages but it has over 100 pages of
documentary appendices everything you're
going to hear me say tonight can be
documented by either the justice
department file a federal court case
interview with uh active duty or former
retired government official or a
mainstream media source there are 50
pages of endnotes in this book virtually
every
other line is documented with some kind
of a footnote because i'm taking on in
in in doing this investigation some
important people i'm naming names i'm
doing what the 911 commission failed to
do and i want to be precise about it and
i want you to feel comfortable when you
read my work anyway this is
this is just an excerpt from the book
in the years leading up to the 911
attacks no single agent of al-qaeda was
more successful in compromising the us
intelligence community than a former
egyptian army captain turned cia
operative special forces adviser and fbi
informant named ali muhammad spying
first for the cia later the fbi muhammad
even succeeded in penetrating the jfk
special warfare center while
simultaneously training the cell that
blew up the world trade center in 1993.
he went on to train osama bin laden's
personal bodyguard and he photographed
the u.s embassy in kenya taking the
surveillance photos that bin laden
himself used to target the suicide truck
bomb that killed 224 and injured 4 000
five years later in 1998 muhammad
accomplished all that fully nine years
after the fbi first photographed the
cell he trained using automatic weapons
at a firing range on long island
he lived the quiet life of a silicon
valley computer executive while slipping
off to afghanistan and the sudan to
train some of al qaeda's most lethal
terrorists in bomb-making and
assassination trade crap he was so
trusted by bin laden that ali was given
the job of moving the saudi emir from
afghanistan to khartoum in 91.
muhammad twice played host to al-qaeda's
second in command listen to this dr
ayman al-zawahiri who traveled to the
united states in the 1990s to raise
money for the jihad he used his army
vacation to hunt down elite soviet spets
knots commandos in afghanistan
later toyed with gullible special agents
in new york and san francisco while he
learned the inner workings of the fbi's
al qaeda playbook in the annals of
espionage few men have moved in and out
of the deep black world between the
hunters and the hunted with as much
audacity as ali muhammad known to his
al-qaeda brothers as ali amriki or ali
the american
a deep penetration al-qaeda sleeper he
succeeded as a triple agent gaining
access to the most sensitive
intelligence in the u.s counterterrorism
arsenal next to ramsey youssef the bomb
maker who plotted both attacks on the
twin towers muhammad remains the
greatest enigma in the war on terror
blazingly slipping past watch lists he
moved in and out of the u.s with
impunity for years marrying an american
woman becoming a naturalized citizen
seeking top-secret security clearance
from a silicon valley defense contractor
and working for the fbi while servicing
the top echelons of al-qaeda the story
of ali muhammad holds the key to the
full truth about how bin laden planned
finance and executed the 9 11 attacks
he's also a living witness to how the
best and the brightest in the u.s
intelligence community were repeatedly
outflanked for two decades from the
death of egyptian president anwar sadat
in 1981 through the attacks of september
11th my conclusion in my last book
cover-up
was that the fbi had buried key al-qaeda
intelligence to avoid a scandal believe
it or not over mafia evidence and i'm
going to get into that tonight but as
unbelievable as that story seemed this
investigation took on an even stranger
twist in turn when ali came into focus
for example almost from the moment the
bureau opened him as an informant in 92
ali's main control agent for the fbi on
the west coast became embroiled in a
grisly triple homicide case that
distracted him from fully appreciating
muhammad's lethal dedication to stealing
america's secrets patrick fitzgerald
himself called him the most dangerous
man i've ever met and soon as i began to
fill in the blanks i encountered
evidence more astonishing than any
fiction i'd ever written
so that's my little
excerpt from the book that'll give you
an idea of the the book has that kind of
energy i try and write in the simple a
way as i can and write like a journalist
like a reporter which is my stock and
trade move the pros
i don't like to have people linger i
like them to move through
the the you know turn the pages so with
that in mind let me take you through
this journey tonight and i'll and again
i'll try and do the best i can thinking
picture and word
so you saw ali muhammad is the key
and if this was going to be a movie if
we were going to make a movie out of
triple cross the the paradigm would be
citizen kane a movie where you focus on
this kind of reprehensible character who
is the central focus of the film but a
character so evil and audacious that you
just can't take your eyes off of him and
i tried to figure out myself as i was
going through this every day i get up
and i get a new revelation about how
muhammad is i cannot believe that nobody
is going to believe this and that's why
i went to the trouble i did documenting
the story if you remember in citizen
kane
it opens with him dying charles foster
kane who is based you know on william
randolph hearst and he he drops this
little snow globe and he says rosebud
you know did i do that all right was the
okay that's my orson welles
impersonation she says roussbod drops
shatters and a reporter begins to be the
narrative protagonist in the movie
seeking to find out what does rosebud
mean with the notion that if i can find
out what rosebud was i can get an
understanding because why would a man so
great living in this castle xanadu san
simeon why would his last word be
rosebud what does that mean so in the
movie if you remember there's a reporter
he's in shadow for most of the film he's
not a central character wasn't one of
the mercury players you know that you
would have known
in most of the film he's going around
talking to people and as i as i began to
this journey this last what i hope is my
final book in this 9 11 trilogy i saw
myself in the role of protagonist
seeking to try to find the answer to put
the dots together the rosebud question
on this man who is the rosetta stone
behind the 911 attacks
uh why should we care okay that's
something i remember when i was
developing as a reporter at abc news one
of my mentors was weston great man and
his he always he told me about two
things sign posting regularly in the
course of an investigative story because
people are seeing it for the first time
remind them now here we are guys here we
are let's remember what we just learned
where here's what it means and the other
thing he said why should we care why
does this why does any of this matter
looking at picture of the 911 commission
and the reason that we should care is
that this is the last official body to
investigate the biggest mass murder in
american history and as i documented my
book cover-up the 911 commission utterly
failed they failed for several reasons
one they focused on the years 1998
forward the last couple of years two
there was no accountability they never
intended to find anyone negligent on the
road to 911 in any of the agencies and
why because half of the staff of 75 was
consisted of alumni the fbi the cia the
nsa the white house or members of the
oversight committees in the senate and
the house that failed to do the
oversight job to protect us so the 911
commission report while it was a
bestseller got nominated for a national
book award tells you only a fragment of
the story
as an example there is only one real
paragraph and i'll read it to you later
on ali muhammad this astonishing story i
hope your jaws are on the ground tonight
when you leave here i hope you're just
going to be like what you know and that
story this one little paragraph about
ali muhammad in the 9 11 report one of
the most amazing things i found and i i
spent that's what cover-up was about
half of the book documented the 911
commission i had a source inside the
commission i used to meet him every
monday he was my deep throat he was a
former i don't want to say his
background because i don't want to
identify him but he would he he met me
and he was just disgusted he said
they're cherry-picking evidence they
have a preconceived script peter none of
the democrats and republicans by the way
on both sides of the aisle wanted to
give the american public something that
would appease them but they never really
wanted to get to the depth of the
problem and so he was ready to quit i
encouraged him to stay on the inside and
uh and one of the things that that that
was discovered
that uh the jersey girls were an
inspiration for me by the way they they
i when i met them i had met them not
until i'd written my first book patty
cazzazza kristen breitweiser laurie van
hauken uh mindy kleinberg and then you
see this picture monica gabriel is kind
of like the fifth jersey girl she's from
new york lost her husband rich that day
they really inspired me these women and
they introduced me to
cooperativeresearch.org
paul thompson absolutely an incredible
american
mr butler paul thompson was a stanford
grad went to new zealand kind of an
expatriate and then after 9 11 just
began compiling massive amounts of open
source information he read every article
every book and this guy is has an
encyclopedic mind and he has this
remarkable website where you can go and
click and these are all open source
mainstream new york times london times
articles and that he has put together
every time there's a new piece of
information he just updated it with
stuff from my book triple cross
i helped him i introduced him to judith
reagan
who deserves a lot of praise she's had a
lot of criticism of late but she's she's
done right by me over the years and
judith reagan met him and instantly got
him she said wow and so we i wrote the
forward for this book i helped paul get
the deal together and this is called the
terror timeline this is uh his version
of a more capsule version of what's on
his website but it's individual people
like that and when i have my own website
peterlands.com i get fbi agents every
week that discover my work and call me
up nsa people say peter what can i do
how can i help and i go as long as i i
vet them and i find out they're legit um
they all contribute to the dialogue and
some of the real breakthroughs i had in
this particular book came from people
active duty people in the government um
now back to why should we care you know
how in august it you know there was the
plot exposed by mi5
where now you can't carry liquids onto a
plane this is it this is what you're
allowed to bring now so obviously our
livestream lives changed after 9 11 with
all the security and with some draconian
measures like the the patriot act which
i contend was unnecessary and we can get
into that later but this this happened
last august because the brits mi5
discovered this plot the plot that they
discovered was an updated version of the
bojinka plot here's a new york times
piece threats and responses manila
plotters echoes of early design use
chemicals to blow up airplanes okay
here's another plot where they basically
say it looks like al qaeda might be
behind this absolutely al qaeda is
behind it this plot is a mirror image of
the bojenko plot that ramsay yusef
created the plot remember i told you he
was going to put these little devices on
planes put them over the fuel tank and
get off the only improvement on this
plot if you can use that word with this
kind of diabolical activity is that they
now had enough suicide bombers that were
just gonna they didn't have to do a two
leg hop they could just have these guys
get on and plant the devices and go down
and the plot was going to happen over
the atlantic but it was a mirror image
now why should we care why does it
matter you see this this is an fbi 302
memo there are dozens of these memos on
my website peterlands.com
this particular memo i'm just going to
have to get up a little bit closer and
point out oops excuse me i'll get this
right okay let me do my little thing
here this section of the memo
talks about yousef had a plan to blow up
a plane
how did the fbi know about this this is
part of a treasure trove of evidence
that the fbi got in 1996 now as could
only happen as my cousin greg as could
only happen in new york okay in new york
where else could this happen ramsay
youssef the original trade center bomber
after he's captured and rendered back to
new york he's in the mcc the federal
jail in lower manhattan and he is
literally you know uh
talking he's in a cell next to a mob guy
named greg scarpa junior on the other
cell is a guy named abdul hakim arad a
fellow terrorist yusuf breaks a bed
strut away from the walls starts passing
notes to murad through yusuf for 11
months this went on and this this junior
wise guy greg scarpa risked his life
first he did it to help get some
downward release time but eventually he
he was doing this for his country and he
exposed over 11 months a uh evidence
that proved for example active al-qaeda
cell in new york city applied to hijack
a plane to free the blind shake other
things you'll see in a minute crucial
intelligence
among the intelligence he writes a note
how to smuggle explosives onto an
aircraft
you see this little section right here
acetone peroxide acetone peroxide is the
exact ingredient that was going to be
used in the plot last august so 10 years
later this evidence as you'll see in a
few minutes was buried by the fbi
called a hoax and a scam even though
it's contained in dozens of their own
fbi 302's even though they gave skarpa
jr camera to photograph the notes and
then they set up a phony mafia front
company allowing yusuf to make outside
calls they took him so seriously that uh
you know they'd spent 11 months then
they called it a hoax and a scam for
reasons we'll get into in a minute and
they buried it greg got 40 years in
prison for mirrico violations they threw
away the key that evidence surfaced last
august you see what i'm saying so the
truth has to come out eventually you the
truth will not stay buried and if you
ignore the truth and if you bracket the
truth which is the essence of what i'm
saying about the fbi they would cover up
as rory o'connor who reviewed my book
said it was a conspiracy to cover up
incompetence okay it wasn't an oliver
stone shadow government conspiracy
they were embarrassed as and it happens
every day in industry right you make a
mistake in a company you don't want the
public to know in this case we're
talking about national security and they
over the years began to and ali muhammad
is the classic case they would bracket
the intelligence so that other agencies
wouldn't understand the full al-qaeda
threat and the consequence
was 9 11. now sheikh rahman i told you
about him the blind shake he runs
through this story like a hot circuit
cable why should we care because as cnn
reported in december and i was on fox
news to discuss this the blind shake is
dying he's in a hospital in missouri he
has already asked his followers to
revenge his death for the jihad
guarantee you there will be violence
there will be violence i know it will
happen worldwide whether it will happen
in this country i hope not but be
careful traveling if you see any news
reports that the blind shake is dead
mark my words tonight be careful because
he is the central spiritual icon of the
original world trade center bombing the
1993 day of terror plot which is a plot
to blow up the bridges and tunnels into
manhattan the un and fbi headquarters he
is the spiritual icon behind the 98
embassy bombings the 2000 attack on the
coal
two weeks before the cole was attacked
bin laden had a famous video fatwa with
a yemeni dagger he had the sheik's son
there who said go to the spilling of
blood for your shake and remember
el-sayed no ser we'll get to him in a
minute this takes the takes the story
all the way back to 1990 and shows you
how entrenched al qaeda was in the u.s
and new york city in particular in the
late 1980s and the taliban one week
before 9 11. this man was so considered
so important the taliban in afghanistan
had remember they had eight missionaries
they offered to exchange those
missionaries for the blind shake the
presidential daily briefing to president
bush on august 6 the famous pdb that the
911 commission the white house tried to
hide and it became a big issue what does
it say here there's a plot uh a u.s
aircraft to release the blind shape okay
so that information showed up in one of
the memos that greg scarpa jr the mob
guy got december 30th
1996 and and and yet they buried it and
then it was important enough to give to
the president a couple of weeks before 9
11. so you get you're starting to get a
little sense here thank you richard
now another thing that was in the august
6th pdb ali muhammad
they talk about al-qaeda members living
on the west coast former uh army officer
this is a reference to ali muhammad
although it doesn't mention him by name
that's the memo that was given to the
president just before 9 11. now i say
that you know it's not fashionable to
quote the french but pluses please
the more things change the more they
stay the same this is a story that you
have to stay on day in and day out and
unfortunately my brothers and sisters in
daily deadline media and this is how i
started at the newport daily news in
newport rhode island as a cub reporter
for 50 bucks a week you don't have time
to do what i've done here investigative
reporting is nothing more than having
the time to do the story i stand on the
shoulders of giants i couldn't have done
this without and i credit right in the
beginning of the book james risen ben
wiser the new york times reporters for
the charlotte observer i mean the
raleigh news observer the san francisco
chronicle a number of reporters had
written about ali muhammad before me and
i stood on their shoulders to begin to
build the grid for this but daily
deadline reporters don't have the time
now what
what would they have found if they had
the time to look back
and and and when i said earlier there
was gross negligence by the fbi here's
how the story really starts july of 1989
you see this this little photograph is
actually a photograph of dozens of
surveillance photos taken by the fbi
special operations group the best of the
best they're the group that got gotti
okay so it doesn't get any better than
these guys in terms of surveillance they
follow a group of mes which is fbi speak
for middle eastern men from a mosque in
brooklyn out to long island over four
weekends they're firing ak-47s automatic
semi-automatic weapons
and half a mile north of the hamptons in
the middle of the summer of the men
photographed all of them trained by ali
muhammad this man this man and this man
were later convicted in the world trade
center bombing this man was convicted
with the blind sheik and the plot to
blow up the bridges and tunnels and this
man el-sayed no ser is the man who
spilled the first blood by al qaeda on
american soil november 5th 1990 all of
them trained by ali muhammad who was
then at fort bragg north carolina coming
up on weekends to train these men
i have a timeline because this is such
an epic story in the middle of triple
cross those of you who are like oh my
gosh this is a 670 page book forget it
you know there's no way i can read this
book well we have what we call the
little golden book of terror in the
middle this 32 page color timeline which
is the beginning of you'll see that
that's the first page of it and what it
does is it takes you through all the
faces and the importance of this is
several there's several reasons one you
see how many times the same guys would
show up time and time again on the radar
of the fbi also it helps you to break
the story apart and if you forget who is
that guy mahmoud muhammad mahmoud you
know there are many variations on these
names you go back and it's key to the
story the page number in the book so
it's easy to follow this epic story
which begins 25 years ago with the
murder of anwar sadat 1981 okay
oh boy i just built coffee all over the
thing but
okay fine that's par for the course all
right
the computer is elevated okay
so sadat is murdered on
1981 uh and a group of radical egyptian
officers jumped off a truck and slit and
you know cut him down nobel peace prize
winner who got the nobel prize for
making peace at camp david with with
menachem bacon his
that unit a member of the unit was ali
muhammad he did not get arrested why
because even then he was on an officer
exchange program at fort bragg north
carolina cut to
his main
rabbi i hate to use the word rabbi you
know because the chosen people will find
it so offensive but i mean as in mentor
as in spiritual guide dr ayman
al-zawahiri now this guy who you
recognize is the number two guy in
al-qaeda whenever you see
video fought wise
little beard he is from one of the
wealthiest families in egypt one of his
grandfathers is the ambassador to saudi
arabia another was the chairman of el
hazar university the oldest university
in the arab world there's a street in
cairo named al-zawahiri he was jailed
that's him over there in jail after the
saddad assassination for three years he
became the press spokesman every night
he'd go on the air you know uh you know
they'd interview him and he would talk
got radicalized ran the egyptian islamic
jihad one of the precursors to al qaeda
he saw ali muhammad this talent in this
guy when ali muhammad was thrown out of
the egyptian military
i think we're okay we'll just stop up
everything later on thank you so anyway
he adopted ali muhammad and this will
give you an idea of this is 1983. this
is how early these men saw that someday
they were going to project themselves
toward the united states so he gets it
he gets ali a job ali gets his own job
at egypt air the state airline for a
year he's learning all the counter air
piracy counterterrorism measures he then
1983 here's what happened over on the
left you have the bombing of the u.s
embassy in april looks just like the
oklahoma city it was a truck bomb
pancaked down killed x number of
americans uh then you had the marine
barracks bombing in in uh in october uh
sunday morning then you had uh captain
william buckley who was the cia station
chief uh was captured by all this was
done by hezbollah okay so the caa is
freaking out they need arabic people
speaking people with this kind of
islamic radical mindset ali walks into
the cia station in cairo and offers his
services they vector him toward hamburg
he works for a time they send him into a
mosque and according to legend he blows
his own cover but here's what's curious
he ends up getting past a watch list and
he gets on a twa flight into america and
on the flight he meets linda lee sanchez
a woman 10 years older than him the
guy's a stud you know he's really
handsome she talked to me for the first
time i have a 100 pages of interview
transcript with linda lee sanchez for
the first time she revealed how she met
him how he kind of posed he got up and
kind of turned around and pulled out a
little crossword puzzle book started
doing arabic showed off his body they
get married at a drive-through wedding
chapel in reno nevada six weeks later
now he's in the united states he's in
silicon valley watering her lawn now
he's got a place a base okay
what does he do he enlists well first of
all that's the house and this guy here
khalid dahab was an ex
medical student who began running he was
one of the heads of ollie's sleeper cell
ollie set up a sleeper cell right in the
middle of silicon valley in 1985 okay
that's the house linda's house now he
enlists in the u.s army listen to this
i'm not kidding you now he had been a
major in the egyptian military he's a
stone commando i speaks four languages
including hebrew but he goes in as an
enlisted man because he would not be
subjected to the same vetting that you
would see at officer candidate school
where does he end up fort bragg north
carolina at the john f kennedy special
warfare school where the elite green
beret officers trained look at what
colonel anderson his co later said to us
when we talked about ali muhammad i
think uri would have a better chance of
winning the powerball lottery
than an egyptian major in the unit that
assassinated sadat would have getting a
visa getting to california getting into
the army and getting assigned to the
special forces that just doesn't happen
oh but it did and he was so good he was
he wasn't even a naturalized citizen at
that point so he didn't have a security
clearance but he got the top secret
memos anyway as you'll see in a minute
and
they were using him to make training
videos and one of the training videos he
actually says it is the responsibility
of every muslim to change darul haarp
which is the state of a country without
islamic rule to dar al islam in other
words we have a larp in america because
we have a democracy as in iran they have
a government run by the mullahs it's an
islamic state it is the responsibility
he's saying to these officers meaning he
didn't mention the u.s he's talking
about saudi arabia or another apostate
state in his mind or egypt but he's
telling them that's treason baby no
matter how you slice it he's putting on
a video for officers to to look at by
the way he would come up weekends to new
york he'd go to this mosque in jersey
that you'll see in a few minutes and he
would show his training videos to the
boys to the brothers they called it the
jersey jihad office now
the origin of the network that became
al-qaeda was what's called the office of
services for the mujahideen this was the
palestinian scholar name named abdul
azam he created this thing and during
the war against the soviets this was the
war we were on you know we were this was
our support for them we gave these guys
three billion dollars in weapons okay to
fight the evil empire and we defeated
the russians with the they did with our
help and however we we didn't realize it
when they turned their attention on us
we were the next infidels for them to go
after and abdullah azam had this network
of fun you know brick and mortar
outposts all over the world he's funny
one of them was in brooklyn at this al
kipha this al farooq mosque on atlantic
avenue he's bringing in millions of
dollars a year in cash so after the
soviets are gone now they have a fight
the fight is do we use it all the money
to for like a taliban like government
afghanistan or do we use it for the
worldwide jihad all the egyptians around
him the egyptians including the blind
sheikh muhammad atef al-zawahiri around
bin laden sided with bin laden because
they had other plans they wanted to use
the money for the big picture egypt the
united states and abdul azan and his
sons were mysteriously murdered in a car
bomb november 1989 on the way to zhumah
friday prayers unsolved murder but we
know who did it baby okay osama and dr
alzawari no doubt in my mind now they
have this network the jersey jihad
office is at the al-salam mosque in
kennedy boulevard
and the al-farooq mosque in brooklyn
these two mosques you know where this is
atlantic avenue and this is from this
mosque on those four weekends in july
that the fbi followed these guys so now
the soviets leave in 1989 february this
is july
our enemy is defeated they went
hightailed out of out of afghanistan
what are we doing protecting these guys
because that's my first explanation and
others who believe that the first time
when they gave ali muhammad a pass was
ah he's you know he's helping our guys
out you know well they're not our guys
anymore okay so what is what's the fbi
doing over four weekends photographing
people shooting automatic weapons half a
mile north of east hampton you know and
uh and not doing anything they closed
the investigation down okay now
it would have been fine except the next
eruption came the night of november 5th
1990. this guy el sayed no sir egyptian
okay el sayed no ser is a janitor in the
courthouse building across the street
from from 100 the law and order
courthouse okay he
uh this is by the way one of the
surveillance photos
six foot two egyptian muhammad salem
you'll see them they keep coming back
again and again one of the fbi photos
you see them mahmoud abba they call them
the red as the egyptians would say has
crusaders blood you know it's got red
hair and selema a little palestinian
okay
egyptian egyptian egyptian around bin
laden okay now the blind shake arrives
july 1990. uh in uh july of 89 they
photographed these guys
a year later the shake shows up okay uh
1990 rabbi meyer kahane many of you know
was a radical right-wing jewish leader
founder of the jewish defense league was
so extremist in his views he was pushed
out of the israeli knesset but he was a
world leader and no one deserves to die
and he's giving a speech on november 5th
at the marriott hotel in lexington
avenue when el sayed no ser posing as a
sephardic jew rushes in using a handgun
that same gun photographed by the fbi
and calvert in 1989 guns him down okay
now look at the rap sheet at this point
photograph by the bureau of 89 a member
of the islam islamic group known as the
elgama islamaya which is the blind
shakes radical group the fbi knows this
okay
this is a photo that i got courtesy of
shannon taylor one of the eyewitnesses
that night this is the first blood
spilled by al qaeda in america
he's trained by ali muhammad now
abdullah abu lima and salemma they are
the getaway drivers that night and when
the fbi goes to nosira's house in new
jersey they pull 47 boxes of evidence
out they arrest these two guys as
material witnesses they let them go the
next day okay 47 boxes including arabic
writing which says the destruction of
the enemies of allah by exploiting their
civilized pillars their high world
buildings there's pictures of the world
trade center there's uh 14 receipt for
1400 rounds of ammo there's
oh look at this top secret memo from
fort bragg north carolina you see what
this is the position of every single
special forces and navy seal unit
worldwide december 5th 88 their latitude
and longitude the russians would have
paid a million bucks for this one
document at the height of the cold war
they find that in boxes and the guy who
kills rabbi kahane they also find top
secret memo joint warning order look at
all these this is arabic writing from
ali muhammad all these sinks are getting
this water who who in their right mind
would have access to this the cops
should be asking the fbi should be
asking they call it a lone gunman case
here's another thing they find which is
going to show up in a minute the meters
are brothers they find a federal
firearms license from some guys called
merterza they turn out to be albanian
islamic immigrants living in connecticut
one of them was a cop
lunopoli a remember i told you about the
joint terrorist task force the original
one they're now 60 some odd all over the
country the prototype is the one in new
york linopoli is this detective and it's
a combination of local nypd and fbi
agents okay
napoli is a principle source of john
miller's book the cell you're going to
hear me say a few critical things about
john tonight he's not here to defend
himself although you'll see later on he
has a bully pulpit he's now the chief
public relations officer for the fbi uh
but in his book the cell lew napoli is a
principle source and lou napoli comes
off as kind of a heroic figure when abc
did their mini-series the path to 911
they happened to buy my book they bought
john miller's book and they bought
another one called relentless pursuit
they turned napoli they turned loonopoly
into one of the heroes of the piece okay
but let me give you an idea of lunap the
quality of lou napoli's work uh first of
all remember when i told you ronnie
booker went to the feds in
1999 and told them that there was
essentially an al-qaeda mole in the fire
department who would obtain the
blueprints of the that he had on the arm
of the blind shake and that loonopoly
was the cop that blew him off okay now
loonopoly look at this fbi 302 memo from
right around the time a week after the
the kahane murder what does it say he
goes up to high rock range in
connecticut now remember i had four
weekends in my first book i had the fbi
is photographing on four weekends in
july he has two years every saturday and
sunday they fire two thousand rounds a
weekend in connecticut the most densely
populated state in america the
investigation ends lew napoli doesn't
seem to want to pursue this okay
now uh
yeah you see the details on this talking
about the matures merturza brothers okay
now this is again this is the this is
the guy rafai on the arm of the blind
shake and louie napoli spurns ronnie
bucca they try no ser is a lone gunman
the feds are not interested now put it
together he kills a world figure they
find two guys at his house the getaway
drivers
they find 47 boxes of evidence including
stuff how is that a lone gunman shooting
in anybody's semester but they tried it
locally in in morgan thought the
district attorney's office okay another
thing that happened a few months later
second murder after the blind shake hits
town
there's a
egyptian
egyptian right egyptian egyptian named
estafa shalaby he has been running the
center that i told you about the you
know the network of el kifa centers at
the alfa rook mosque this is his house
there's no picture of him this is his
house he starts to be threatened by the
blind shake who wants to take over this
massive cash import you know business
from the you know the center he starts
denouncing him in ma so the guy's
worried he contacts ali muhammad ask ali
muhammad to get get him back to egypt
ali gets his wife back to egypt ali
pretends to be his friend one morning
just the night before he's supposed to
fly to egypt he's p his family's waiting
he never shows they walk into his
apartment he's been stabbed garretted
bludgeoned to death there's thousands of
dollars missing from the el casa from
the apartment they find two red hairs in
his hand could it have been abu lima the
six foot two we don't know it's still an
open homicide in the 6-1 precinct in
brooklyn ali muhammad according to steve
emerson one of the great experts we
interviewed for this book believed that
ali acted like the harvey keitel
character in pulp fiction he was the
cleaner he came in and sanitized the
scene okay now another important figure
and i'm going to try and i'm not talking
fast enough i got to really do every
second word now wadi alhaj
very important figure is going to show
up
wadi alhaj is a lebanese convert to
islam who is shows up first of all he
sells guns to abu lima he shows up that
his voice is on the shelby's message
machine at the time of the murder he
shows up in new york he visits el sayed
no sir at rikers island okay you're
going to see in later how important wadi
elhaj is so and also why why am i saying
this remember i told you the 911
commission focused on 98 forward this
stuff is happening in 89 and 90. you
cannot fully appreciate the depth of
al-qaeda's villainy and their plants
into the depths of their roots into this
country without going back at least 12
years so what did i do that that's some
of the transcripts the 45 000 pages of
trial transcripts i read all the
southern district cases i read every
single book on the subject i read uh 10
000 articles from paul thompson i've
assembled now it's it's actually like 50
volumes but that's the last time i took
a picture of what this has grown to this
body of work
and uh
it's well i did what is known as data
mining i went through i with a little
imac and filemaker pro and google i
typed up a database and every time i
would come up with an islamic variation
on a name i'd put it into my database
any variation walid al nor eleanor
whatever okay and i began to connect the
dots and the most astonishing discovery
that i found in the course of this
investigation for triple cross i'm going
to tell you right now sphinx trading
remember i said egyptian egyptian
egyptian okay sphinx trading is located
at 2828 kennedy boulevard in jersey city
now i had the 45 000 pages of federal
transcripts on disc easy to search but i
didn't have the nosair case it was a
local i told you morgan thought the d.a
tried it so i you think hey it's a
famous case you're going to new york you
just go like that and you get the
transcript
turns out new york is is is beautifully
arcane in the way it's kind of set up so
i got i had to locate each of the
individual court reporters three of them
two of them happen to have the 2500
pages of the transcript the first 500
pages are missing because the women went
to broadway to be an actress i mean this
is how arbitrary this is and i get
finally i get the da i'd worked there
when i was in law school in the office i
called in a note they gave me the 500
cost me three grand to put this
transcript but i'm reading this
transcript and what do i see that el
sayed no ser the killer of rabbi kahane
has a mailbox at 28 28 kennedy boulevard
now when you know i'm not that old i
have a few senior moments but i went
28-28 the blind shakes mosque is 28 24.
there it is the masjid al-salam the
so-called mosque of peace now you see
this building see that it's like like
three stories you see how it goes down
two stories right there in a minute
you're going to see that sphinx trading
it's in the same physical building it's
a check cashing money transfer they do a
couple of million dollars a year and
transfers to the middle east sphinx
trading
there are mailboxes so el sayed no serra
this is dot number one in this three dot
story i'm going to tell you el sayed no
ser the killer of a world figure has a
mailbox there the fbi knows about it
1990. see the money transfer as they do
okay so right no sarah hasn't now i go
and i get the certificate of
incorporation for sphinx trading founded
december 15 1987. what do i see remember
follow the money it's rule number one
for any investigative reporter walid
abdul al-nur and muhammad al-atris
waleed al-noor aka abdul noor and
muhammad alatris they're the two
founders of the company you with me okay
martiza um
wait how do i how did that happen okay
it slipped in there forget that you know
we'll cut it out in the editing anyway
now
mccarthy and fitzgerald two of the
senior feds what happened was they had
the world trade center bombing in 93 and
i should in a minute you're going to see
how they could have stopped it they had
a guy named salam on the inside making
500 a week this beautiful agent nancy
floyd recruited him he was like right
next to the blind shake on his arm and
some head of terrorism a new guy takes
over with no experience pushes him out
so they end up paying one and a half
million dollars after the fact to do
what he could have done for 500 a week
and stop the trade center bombing a true
story is this ana ginotis oh wow look at
oh man i'm sorry geez okay
all right one of my oldest friends is
here anyway
okay so what happens uh no sierra comes
back i mean uh salam is re-recruited and
he rounds up this plot to blow up the
bridges in three months okay so
fitzgerald and mccarthy now are going to
prosecute this day of terror case 1999
they have a list of 172 unindicted who's
on the list um mohammad jamal khalifa
brother-in-law osama bin laden okay you
see this waleed al-nur oh the meters of
brothers are on the list the guys that
with the range in new jersey and
connecticut that the firearm license
finding so they're starting to connect
the dots that's the point of all this
look at this wallet elenor the founder
of sphinx trading that's the second dot
in the chart that means senior justice
department prosecutors are aware that
this little mailbox store is a den of
iniquity and this mosque in the same
building is this nest of vipers okay
there is not a word on sphinx trading in
the 911 report and where do you see how
sphinx trading pays off at the end of
this lecture if we ever get there is
everything working are you guys happy is
it going is it playing for you all right
i didn't know please hold the applause
till the end okay fbi
this woman is one of the great heroes of
the war on terror but she should have
gotten a corner office in the hoover
building and she was ultimately set up
investigated for four and a half years
and suspended because the guy above her
who got rid of salam who was one of the
great you know empty suits on the road
to 911 didn't like her and she was
suspended for two weeks lost her shield
and her gun for insubordination this
woman isn't this is her mentor len
prednishenkis first latvian first fbi
agent ever to have a green card latvian
emigrate for 25 years he was the main
speaks fluent russian was the main
counterterrorism agent in new york
against the u.n the soviets in the u.n
nancy was his protege okay when i met
him i had heard about her and he's
retired he said to me i'll tell you
something peter he said i'm old school i
don't think women even should be fbi
just until i met nancy floyd okay she's
just a little pistol from texas and she
was working russian foreign
counterintelligence you know going to
what they these little hotels around
times square where the russians were in
flagrante de litto you know hoping to
catch them in a honeypot and turn them
and she meets this guy ahmad salam he is
a good ex-egyptian intelligence officer
as opposed to ali muhammad a bad one
this guy loved america he was a
naturalized citizen what what happens
the american dream for him is he's
working as a cab driver he's in this
hotel as a combination security guard
desk man at night elevator operator and
nancy walks in and they
strike up a friendship he starts doing a
little ins type jobs for her one day he
says there's a man in this city more
more lethal than the worst kgb hood omar
abdel rahman the blind shake she's such
a right r-a-c-k no it's rah and and so
she goes to her boss there's no head of
terrorism at the time in new york
terrorism was like the weather
underground back then okay so she goes
to her boss and she he's willing to quit
his job for 500 a week and we'll give
him six weeks to see if he can
infiltrate the shake so give it a give
it a shot or boy get out of here you
know one of those things okay so what do
you think he does it in two days there's
a new york times picture of the new
bodyguard for the blind shake this is
how close he got to the blind shake good
guy the the the blind shake is he's
going to he's going to detroit with a
van curtis of the fbi and the blind
shakes asking him to kill mubarak and
trusting this guy okay he's going up to
visit el sayed no serra is now in attic
he's been convicted of gun charges and
the rabbi is dead no sarah's asking him
to blow up locations around manhattan
while this is happening though while
this good agent is undercover in new
york exposing al qaeda the bad agent
becomes an a an fbi asset on the west
coast and the west coast isn't talking
to the to the east coast okay his he's
got a guy named john zent one of the
greatest empty suits and i say this and
i john i bring it baby you are one of
the greatest empty suits in the history
of the fbi and when you hear his story
i'll understand why that's the man is
supposed to be watching ali muhammad now
ali as i told you is coming up to the
jersey jihad office the el faro mosque i
told you about you see a little bit
wider shot you see sphinx trading down
the same building okay same deal sphinx
trading okay mailbox store okay now
salam is inside the cell okay his his
brother-in-law is a guy named elga
brownie uh elga brownie actually gets
twenty thousand dollars from bin laden
goes to afghanistan meets bin laden just
to show you how much al qaeda is
interested in to these guys back then he
gets twenty thousand dollars for no
serious defense at his trial they target
what's called the twelve jewish
locations plot the diamond center the
you know diamond district etc okay and
uh and salem is right in the middle he
meets hampton l the other guy
photographed at calvert and by the fbi
who's offering to supply him with bombs
now lunopoli remember i told you about
him the guy that's spurring ronnie
booker john antisev fbi agent his
partner they're supposed to be watching
because nancy's working russians this is
not her thing she just got this guy in
and they are never around now he's not
wearing a wire that was the deal because
he had family in egypt he would go in as
an asset that means every night he has
to vomit out his stuff that he's seeing
because he can't remember it these guys
are never around so he calls nancy they
meet at the
tgi fridays at 26 federal plaza she
works at 10 at night goes up types of
cereals reports and goes home to
connecticut
and then gets up at five in the morning
comes back and works russians all day
this is the kind of person this woman
should have gotten a as i said a corner
office in the hoover building now enter
carson dunbar former jersey state
trooper with no terrorism experience
works his way up as a desk man a desk
jockey in the new york office a paper
guy not no street virtually no street
experience never investigated terrorism
he comes in he doesn't like slim he
doesn't like nancy she's a kind of a
pushy woman so he basically you know
basically pushes pushes this guy out and
he quits and they gave him they give him
six weeks to get out of three months to
get a new job he's out because he says i
he wants him to wear wires i can't wear
a wire i'm out of here so salem
withdraws then they call the sheikh
calls afghanistan
and who comes in ramsey youssef
september 2nd 1992 with him is muhammad
al-jaz a member of elfitta terrace he
has a suitcase full of bomb books
recipes suicide tapes you know insane
intending to be caught make a big noise
so ramsay can slip through ask for
asylum and that's exactly what happens
he gets the last bud bet at the ins
center at varric street and this guy
walked a world-class bomb maker they had
a they had an undercover guy salam now
he's gone now they got the real thing
ramzi the mozart of terror okay
what do they find in so uh uh you know
this guy is josh's
they find manuals from fort bragg pages
from fort bragg manuals that are
identical to what ali muhammad was
giving to just to know
one of the things they find is a book
that on they misinterpret they think it
says the basic rule on it that's what
they think is on the cover of the book
el josh brings in it really is the base
al-qaeda it's written right on the book
september 2nd 1992 right in front of the
fbi's eyes but uh you know now the one
the train the bombing cell i told you
about now they start working in jersey
at pam rappo avenue in jersey city nancy
meets him at the subway sandwich shop to
get his last 500 bucks in cash in the
presence of another agent he says nancy
this is october youssef came in in
september they're building this bond
something's going on i don't know what
it is but do me a favor nancy please
follow these two guys now how many times
have you seen their pictures tonight
they were the guys at calverton they
were the guys with nosair do you see
what i'm saying lou napoli uh they even
joked that they would lead antiseven
wild goose chases into connecticut they
searched uh abba lima's apartment posing
as khan ed workers couldn't find
anything so they obviously know who
these guys are and and and and salem
pleads nancy just follow them if you do
they will lead you to whatever is going
on she said i'll do what i can but i'm
out of it you know dunbar doesn't like
me i'll pass it on so
look at look at this is what i just told
you photographed arrested with no sierra
not believing it followed subpoenaed by
anna 792 if not he says if you do not
follow these men don't call me when the
bombs plural go off okay all right
napoli says the red and selema beat feet
to new jersey i called him i said lou
why didn't you follow these guys they
were highly visible during this time
salemma had three traffic accidents
yusuf went to the pakistani mission to
get a passport i mean i you can't even
you know there's a number of little
instances in my first book where i show
how visible they were and he says they
beat feet to new jersey i said what do
you mean he said well you know it's new
i said don't you watch the sopranos lou
you know you're telling me you can't go
to new jersey or the fbi that was just
an excuse dunbar wouldn't approve the
surveillance okay so they didn't follow
these guys and if they had this is part
of my book that shows how visible these
guys were the red six foot two now stuck
out like a sore thumb living openly in
new jersey with his wife and five kids
next to his brother another six foot
with crusaders brought in the same
apartment complex i mean how hard would
these guys be to find the fifth
battalion liberation army yusuf the day
he goes into the building with the truck
he has a letter on the fifth but taking
credit for the bombing they mail it as
on their way out okay
it's typed on the on the uh
computer of this guy in adelaide all
right also photographed at calvary
also trained by ali muhammad that's the
whole that the fi that kevin shea fell
into four stories the day six people
dead including a pregnant woman and a
thousand people injured the first true
attack now if you and that's ronnie
booker going in there that night that's
his story that's his picture now listen
to this this is where ronnie bucca
went nuts and this is why he worked in
firehouses back to back to try and find
out who these men were on ayad's
computer in new jersey yusuf the night
he flees to kennedy airport did the fbi
lock down the airports that night now
he's in the first class lounge of
pakistani watching channel 2. channel 2
is the only station on the air because
the other ones had their transmitters on
the trade center they're on the empire
he's watching his fbi is saying serbian
terrorists and he's like what
screw you know sorry whatever you know
blank that you know i want credit for
this so he calls uh ayad and has him
type this on to the threat letter to
send out the letter again here's what he
says our calculations were not very
accurate however we promise you that the
next time it will be very precise and
the trade center will be one they wrote
that the night of the trade center
bombing and the fbi had it in one week
they knew they were coming back for
those buildings okay so when lou napoli
when ronnie book is talking about the
towers and bringing him information in
1989 about a guy with the blind shaking
on the arm in the trade center
blueprints and he blows them off what
does that say
salem is re-recruited i told you they
pay him 1.5 million he does it as an
undercover tape and he rounds up these
guys in three months in this day of
terror plot the blood the george
washington bridge the tunnels the u.n
the blind shaking 11 others charge they
call it the landmark judea terror plot
mccarthy summons ali muhammad now ali
muhammad should have been tried he
trained most of the guys that are on
trial where is he he's in the home of
this guy remember i told you wadi alhaj
he's in africa because he's already
taken the pictures of the embassies in
93 that they're going to set the bombs
off five years later and they're
plotting the plot he's hanging out in in
uh you know in uh with wadi in kenya
nairobi and mccarthy calls him to a
meeting in california mccarthy flies to
meet ali muhammad and ali says i'm
running a scuba diving business in kenya
leave me alone and and nothing happens
they let them go back ali fbi agent told
me was even upset that the fbi didn't
pay his airfare okay you with me all
right now the trial 172 unindicted you
see remember again waleed al noor sphinx
trading all right egyptian egyptian so
dot number one is the mailbox in 90 dot
number two elenor on the list in 94.
from 92 on he's an fbi informant now
remember i told you his control agent is
an empty suit this is the yule family
wonderful father airplane executive his
daughter tiffany mother glee and the son
dana okay danny ewell plotted to kill
with another guy to have his parents and
his sister murdered in cold blood as
they came home from thanks from easter
dinner one day into their house for the
eight million dollar inheritance it was
a stone menendez brothers deal okay you
know you know what i'm saying and uh the
local fresno cops john souza and chris
curtis these incredible detectives knew
it from almost from the beginning the
kid had lied about his resume but the
alibi that
that the kid had that day was that i was
with my fiance monica zent and her
father john who's an fbi agent her
father is the alibi witness who's ali
muhammad's control agent is the alibi
witness on this triple homicide that's a
picture of her that they found later in
a safe house with the eyes shot out by
somebody we don't know
okay now 1993 the system works ali
muhammad is captured in canada trying to
smuggle in this terrorist name marzuk
the mounties have them he has they have
them they're sweating him like a law and
order type interrogation scene you know
up until midnight and finally writes the
name john zen here call john zen calls
vouchers for him they let him go okay
john zen writes a letter to the fresno
bee and and says dana is innocent now
you never in the course of an
investigation for a crime question
another law enforcement agency he calls
them incompetent effectively and he
basically says i know dana's innocent
he's declaring the kid innocent six
years later after they had the murder
weapon they had i mean it's one of the
best investigative stories i've ever
read they they have they they have the
murder weapon they have a co-conspirator
who flips they've got this kid dead to
right she'd get a bank loan i guess
again john zen shows up as a character
witness at his trial refusing to admit
he was wrong this is the man who the fbi
put in charge of guarding the most
lethal terrorists ever to infiltrate the
us intelligence community and this he
goes on after he's out because of john
zen to do the surveillance for the
african embassy bombing now
okay i'm going to bore it start now i
got to make this fast
this is the question as old as watergate
all right what do they know and when did
they know it
now we're getting to the point now in
1985 with all this i mean everything
i've told you is absolutely true the
calverton surveillance the number of
dots the the nosare the misstep on the
kahani murder
leaving ali muhammad on the loose
everything i've told you is absolutely
true now we're into 1995. okay what did
they know and when did they know it
muhammad moves al-qaeda to the sudan in
1991 the entire entourage of bin laden
his wives the shura council they're all
moved they trust who to do this ali
muhammad he does all the logistics he's
the guy that sets up the terror camps in
khartoum he writes the manual on terror
the you know the smokinggun.com that you
can download he writes or translates
most of it he lives in bin laden's house
in 94 trains his personal bodyguard this
is the terror manual that he writes okay
now
now 1994. you have to understand there
are two parallel courses to the story
parallel course number one is ali the
espionage agent because in any great war
you need two things you need you need
operations people to do the dirty work
the wet work and then you need an
intelligence brain to understand the
enemy and that's what ali did and ramsay
was the other operative so now he's got
to sell in manila yusuf and in the cell
is his uncle khalid sheikh wali khan and
uzbeki beloved bin laden this is uh his
brother-in-law muhammad jamal khalifa
named on that same list that patrick
fitzgerald named with waleed elenor and
this is a guy named ridawinis moudin a
cleric known as himbali he shows up
later six years later at the famous 911
planning session in january in kuala
lumpur again
the photograph by the cia with an fbi
agent having looked at the photographs
an fbi agent who was in manila later who
should have known who this guy was okay
now they have a fire in their bomb
factory and there are three plots going
on in 1994 into 95. okay
look at yusuf he's the man of many
aliases he changes his appearance he
uses the windows uh atlas on his toshiba
laptop to pick names
he does a wet test remember the plot i
told you put the bombs little bomb
triggers on airliners using a casio
watch he does a wet test aboard a
philippine airlines flight december uh
11th 1994 gets on board and manila goes
to cebu in the southern philippines puts
the bomb together puts in a live jaw
cushion see 26a just as he was wrong
about the trade center bomb you know
where to put it he was two rows back
he'd gone two rows forward when he got
off the plane would have blown okay well
this is the damage in the plane anyway
blows a hole through the floor kills the
japanese national seat now they know
it's going to work now they're going to
do it times 12. that's bojinka that's
the precursor to this plot exposed last
summer by mi5 this woman this is a story
by the way where women i say egyptian
egyptian egyptian now i'm going to say
women women women there's so many
opportunities where women along the road
on the road to 911 if if women had been
listened to the towers would be standing
nancy floyd is one of them this woman is
another one aida farascal her story is a
woman with a couple of kids her
husband's a police officer gets killed
in the line of duty she quit whatever
she's doing enters the police department
goes through training becomes one of the
most decorated police men in the history
of the philippines only she's a woman
the night of the they have a bomb
factory yusuf and his cohorts and they
have a fire in the bomb factory january
7th
they're getting ready to do bojinka the
pope and a plot i'll tell you about in a
minute and there's a fire she goes to
the apartment building and this is her
this is my uh i interviewed her she's
showing they captured murad youssef's
partner who fled he's he's heading back
to get ramsey's laptop and he took off
like a shot and they she's posing as the
a cop fired one off behind his ear and
he tripped over a root that had been
uprooted in the typhoon and she said to
me peter she said if god had not had the
typhoon with the root uprooted he would
not have tripped and we would not have
caught it
beautiful lady anyway uh she was the
unsung hero heroine of that story okay
this is the guy they capture youssef's
oldest friend a by the way a pilot
trained in four u.s flight schools
schenectady new york newbern north
carolina alpha tango in texas and
california commercial pilot he scouted
the trade center in 92 he came to
america grew up with ramsey now this
individual is colonel rodolfo mendoza he
is the richard clark of the philippines
this guy is the one of the most
knowledgeable men on al qaeda you could
ever imagine okay i heard about him
right after 9 11 telling people we had
told the feds we told the fbi about all
this stuff and he got his you know what
handed him they shipped him off to this
crummy little town four hours north it
was a rooster crowing in the background
during our interview okay totally
uncorruptable great cop
they torture this guy the first couple
of days they have them they waterboard
them nothing this is an example of how
torture doesn't work these guys go down
they go in so he walks up to the table
and he they have they starve him for a
couple days they have him in a barracks
cuffed to a bed with a hood over his
head you know sensory deprivation and
food deprivation and he puts a big mac
with a value meal with fries and a coke
on a table in front of him he gets up
salivating you know and they take the
hood off and he's like he says tell me
something my friend says mendoza my only
issue is whether to turn you now to the
mossad or tomorrow uh on the mossad the
guy is freaking out he doesn't want to
go to israel for obvious reasons he said
uh but if you tell me something i will
let you eat this sandwich 100 beef no
pork i assure you okay
so now the guy says there's something
about the world trade center that
anybody could have read and mendoza
takes the sandwich he takes a bite and
he leaves no stop please stop come back
i tell you so he gives them something
that nobody would have known so they
dropped a new burger in front of him and
that was the beginning of their
relationship and over 60 more days he
peels back the layers on this guy
initially he told him about a plot to
fly a small plane into the cia
and that story which is the only
transcript of the interview that ever
came out was entered into the bojinka
case it's in the 911 report it's in the
joint inquiry and everybody like condi
rice later would say well how could we
have extrapolated 911 from a little
plane to the cia how could you blame it
well guess what he gave him the entire
911 plot he gave them the world trade
center the pentagon
a nuclear facility cia headquarters the
sears tower in chicago the transamerica
tower and i didn't know i had that in my
first book in my new book i found out
the seventh target was the white house
and he gave it all to them it then in
1995 and they gave it all to the fbi in
1995. second plot they were going to
kill pope john paul who was going to
arrive in about a week they're going to
put pipe bombs along his parade route
this is the bojinka plot you see you
know that i told you about precursor to
the plot last summer
and by the way that see that picture
that lab report which i got from a
source and this is an example of an
investigative reporter people trust me
they send me things that lab report was
fedex from an ap reporter to the bureau
assistant bureau chief in washington and
the fbi invaded a fedex facility in the
midwest and confiscated it as under
national security even though it had
been entered into two court cases prior
to that okay but that's in the book
that's the casio watch and this is the
plains as missiles plot plot number
three okay the planes operation what do
they know and when did they know it now
this is a this is a chart that i have i
got from the philippines i came back
with 200 pages of heretofore classified
documents it's got ramsay yusuf khalid
sheikh mohammed under their aliases
abdullah kimarad over here uh it's got
the constant jaya the cut out company
that they used in malaysia with with uh
wali khan and abdul and muhammad jamal
khalifa the brother-in-law of bin laden
is the bankroll bank man now no form fbi
no foreign memo from 1995 caa nuclear
facility or targets this proves uh i
mean not ca fbi no foreign means no not
to go to foreigners this proves that
they had the information from them and
this time for this book i heard about a
guy named rafael garcia iii he's the
bill gates of the philippines he was
hired by the philippines because they
didn't trust the cia to de-encrypt
youssef's laptop
the official story was they flew it to
redmond washington some microsoft d
encrypted it etc but before they did
they hired him to clone the hard drive
he cloned the hard drive i had two
face-to-face meetings with him in santa
barbara in the course of this book and
he told me absolutely every single thing
i had on my first book was dead on
colonel mendoza everything he said was
dead on and he said peter but you missed
one thing the seventh target was the
white house and when zacharias masawi
the alleged 20th hijacker copped a plea
and pled guilty to 911 he said uh the
white house was my target my goal to
free the blind shake is this starting to
place a chance bruce l m shows are we
starting to see how these patterns time
and time again recycle okay
now
i'm moving here i'm moving
you're still okay everybody's still good
you know not too antsy that's the donna
josepha that night yusuf and ksm escape
from went to islamabad yusuf there's a
massive human cry he's the most wanted
man on earth they put a two million
dollar reward his picture on matchbook
covers they drop all over the mid-east
because everybody smokes a young south
african a mistake parker youssef tries
to recruit him that's a picture when
they capture him he's going to try and
put bombs and toy kai this guy was the
energizer bunner bunny of terror he
wouldn't have stopped and they finally
came into this little 20 room guest
house called the zukaza and they grabbed
them not the fbi diplomatic security
agents because that's a reward program
and dea agents
he's captured okay ramsay finally got
the mozart of tara ksm escapes you know
what i find out he hangs around the
guest house long enough to give an
interview to time mag a stringer for
time with his own name khalid shake and
he talks about ramsey there's a
hurricane when they came in the
mastermind of 911 hangs around long
enough the fbi guy brad garrett gets
there late and he's in the wind okay
only to perpetrate his nephew's plot on
9 11. okay khalifa now big one muhammad
jamal khalifa again see how the system
works periodically like remember i told
you canada they grabbed you know wali
ali muhammad the canadians the system
worked and then he was vouched for by
this guy's that here muhammad jamal
khalifa the brother-in-law look at the
ties to this guy he's got a new by the
way they love apple products these guys
they all have power books and he had a
newton pda no except for ramsey out of
toshiba you know but anyway bin laden's
brother-in-law
okay that's pretty close to the source
he ran al-qaeda front in manila he had a
pda with evidence linking him to the
blind shake cell in new york in the
manila cell he had a death sentence
hanging over his head in jordan he
seized on december 16 1994 where morgan
hill california the same town as john
zen ali muhammad's guy people believe
steve emerson told me he believed that
they was going to see ali mohammed so
they get him oh man what a victory in
the war on terror they've got this guy
with all this treasure trove of evidence
and he's motivated to talk because
they're going to kill him in jordan he's
already been convicted right in absencia
well this is a memo from philip wilcox i
have to
read it basically
how do we do this
like a professional
he says
in fact he's engaged in serious
terrorist defenses i further believe
that mr khalifa's release in the united
states under these circumstances would
endanger u.s national security and
significantly damage u.s foreign policy
interests particularly with respect to
the um
of hashemite kingdom of jordan okay so
he's saying how dangerous this guy is we
got to hold on to him who who uh what
what happens jamie gorilla does she look
familiar she's deputy attorney general
she later goes on to the 911 as one of
the 10 commission not just one of the 10
one of only two along with philip zeliko
who goes into the skiff that can look at
all the classified material
she on behest of warren christopher
secretary of state pushes to get him
extradited to jordan the jordanians want
him why i mean why would you let this
guy go he said he's the brother-in-law
of bin laden who by now believe me 95
they know who osama bin laden is and
because of jamie gorilla's effort he is
extradited where a witness recants they
drop the sentence and he's in the wind
he's now running a seafood restaurant in
jeddah saudi arabia okay all right and
mike shoyer who ran alex station at the
cia told me that when he arrived in
saudi arabia he was greeted with a
diplomatic car and a minister-level
government official from saudi arabia
came up and embraced him he got in the
car and took off okay
all right now that's jamie garrell do
you think there's a word about this in
the 911 report no now here's where i
here's where i have to say a word about
the competition a little bit now the the
looming tower okay
where is it i have it in here somewhere
i'm going to hold it up anyway the
looming tower this great book it's a
great book by lawrence wright of the of
the new yorker i quote him in several
places in this book this was on the new
york times list for six weeks this
summer he interviewed most of the same
fbi agents that i did he talked to many
of the same but he just accepted what
they had to say pretty much as gospel
okay
there is he interviewed khalifa for the
book not a word in this book about what
i just told you about jamie gorilla not
a word now how can you tell the story of
mohammed jamal khalifa and not talk
about how he was captured in america and
how he was forced out by senior members
of the justice department how could that
not be if you're a journalist doing your
job
he also accepts that he he actually said
i'll read you a passage from the book he
hears what he says and this is the
official justice department line is that
this al qaeda thing is just recent and
these guys back in 89 they were just a
loosely organized group of muslims they
weren't really al-qaeda he says ali
jihad and al-qaeda were still separate
entities in the spring of 1993 and
al-zawahiri had not yet signed on to bin
laden's campaign against america
absolute 100 boulder dash okay these
guys i've shown you since 1989 trained
by ali muhammad the man who lived in
midlands house uh the blind shake the
takeover of the al-kifah center that was
an al-qaeda clubhouse in february of
1991 they had a brick and mortar outpost
in new york city and you're going to see
in a few minutes why i'm saying that
through a witness that patrick
fitzgerald himself interviewed now
anyway oh jamie gorilla after this she
then comes up with a famous wall memo
saying that we should separate foreign
counter intelligence the the agents who
are looking to stop the future threats
from past uh criminal investigators like
take the two sides of the fbi's brain on
al qaeda the guys that know the most
about al-qaeda separate them from the
ones trying to prevent the next attack
insane she even says it's not admits it
goes beyond what's legally required i
believe that memo was was was
essentially sent out to help to
obfuscate some of what i'm telling you
tonight this negligence that happened
with the fbi but that's my opinion
there's no mention of muhammad jamal
khalifa's extradition in the 9 11 report
the thing i just told you
now ali muhammad audacity knows no ends
he brings this is uh dr al-zawahiri the
guy you now know with the little beard
next to bin laden he brings him into
america twice for a tour of mosques on
two separate coasts this is the
equivalent of heinrich himmler the head
of the ss being brought into america in
the middle of world war ii and doing a
tour of german
churches okay and this guy's in there
and uh uh i guess john cent who is this
control agent must he must have been
tied up with the yule murder case during
that period that's another astonishing
thing and a measure of ollie's audacity
now this is the part of the story i'm
getting to the end and i hope quickly
and this is the part i just don't want
to depress you because when you read the
when you read my work you know it gets
you angry and it's like oh my gosh you
know and but there's light at the end of
the tunnel and this story that i'm going
to tell you which will lead us hopefully
toward the end is the story that's going
to give you hope and this it will lead
to i think the great the greatest
possibility of a new investigation into
9 11. and i have to start the story in
1964 with the mizburn case mississippi
burning goodman schwerner and cheney the
three civil rights workers you saw the
movie
they were
captured and killed by the ku klux klan
they found their station wagon okay they
didn't know where they were okay they
had no idea so j edgar hoover himself
recruited this guy he was much younger
than this is him when he's in his like
40. greg scarpa senior he was a young
[ __ ] of the walk in the colombo crime
family in brooklyn he goes down captures
a local official threatens to separate
him from a very important part of his
body
and he is he gives up the kids and
they're buried in the earth and dam okay
now in the movie they they used an
african-american agent played by my
favorite actor baja jola it wasn't it
was the mob guy okay now that is the
columbo crime family de vecchio was
involved in a a competition with vic
arena jr who was the acting boss of the
family there is a war from 1991 to 92
14 people killed including this
beautiful woman mary barry this young
kid patrick porco and a number of these
guys okay and
it is now believed and not just by peter
lance who wrote about it in cover-up but
by a four-inch thick fbi internal
affairs investigation report and by the
d.a of brooklyn charles hines that our
lindley de vecchio this fbi agent was in
a corrupt relationship with with scarpa
scarpa did 30 days in jail in 30 years
and it is alleged that he was leaking
key information with the motive for him
so he could kill his competition and
take over the crime family so the fbi
would have a man on the national
commission of organized crime remember
the famous scene of the godfather with
don barzini and the heroine and all that
that's the national commission okay now
who could make this up who could make
this up
ramsay youssef is sitting the guy in
between remember i told you that 11
months of treasure trove of evidence
including the plot the bojinka thing
that surfaced last august this is the
son of that killer greg scarpa jr who
was the marijuana king of staten island
he was not a major guy his father was a
psychotic they call him the grim reaper
so so yusuf is passing these notes or
kites including for example uh now no
way could greg have written this this is
ramsey's schematic of the casio watch
with the c106d capacitor which the feds
later called his signature at trial
months later no way greg could have done
this on his own without ramsey yusuf
they then
take it so seriously this information
they set up the fbi a phony mafia
company called roma corporation roma
corporation
allows yusuf to make outside calls he
thinks he's calling the mob they patch
his calls to the middle east okay all
right that's how seriously this is an
fbi 302 memo all of this is on my
website that show who's in the room with
scarpa who's a party to this treasure
trove dietrich snell later goes on to be
the senior council of the 9 11
commission who investigates the origin
of the plot patrick fitzgerald alan
corcella who's running the
criminal investigations of the colombo
war in brooklyn and valerie caproni
chief of the criminal where is she today
general counsel to the fbi the top
lawyer in the fbi he where is he he's
the assistant uh chief lawyer for eliot
spitzer democratic governor of new york
we know where he is he's putting the
feet or maybe not to the fire to the
feet of scooter libby okay
now this is uh this is a memo talking
about a plan to hijack a plane to free
the blind shake this is from 19 uh
december 30th 1996. that's the same
thing that i referenced that showed up
in the pdb to president bush and
crawford texas that's how important it
was and yet
because of this de vecchio scandal they
were afraid the feds were afraid that if
they gave credibility to scarpa the son
he was going to later testify that his
father was in this relationship there
were 75 cases in the colombo war
originally when the lawyers got
a word of this unholy alliance between
alleged between the hitman and the g-man
they brought it to the judge and 14 guys
walked so now they're thinking oh my god
60 cases millions of dollars careers
around this we got to make an ends means
decision here we have to decide this
al-qaeda thing is going to blow away we
got we're going to put ramsey away for
240 we got the blind shake 240 years all
these other mutts they're gone baby it's
over you know like that okay as they do
in new york
and yet these are real mafia cases we
really want mob guys to get out of jail
because of tainted evidence under the
exception to the rule against hearsay
for co-conspirator testimony he's a
co-conspirator he can testify right but
what if he's not what if he's an agent
provocateur of the fbi this makes the
departed look like you know as great a
movie as it is and i loved it this is so
real this is real okay so what do they
do they decide
uh it's it's gonna go away this is a
memo that james calstrom sent to louis
free on april this is the memo it's in
my book and he basically says in the
memo well i got to do this
okay okay there is insufficient evidence
to take prosecutive action against de
vecchio the failure of the justice
department to provide an opinion
continues to have a serious negative
impact on the government's prosecution
of lcn lacozinosta figures in the
eastern district and cast a cloud over
the new york office so he's basically
saying shut this thing down louis they
should despite all this treasure trove
of evidence despite the acetone peroxide
all the stuff that later surfaces the
11-month treasure trove they call it a
hoax and a scam they come up with a
story that scarpa must have made it up
okay and they bury it and they bury him
he gets 40 years in the super max prison
in florida for rico not a single
homicide sammy the bull killed 19 people
he got five years this guy they threw
away the key okay de vecchio he uh he
there's a two-year opr internal affairs
on him it's closed he retires with a
full pension after taking the fifth when
have you ever heard of that an fbi and
he answers i don't recall 44 times after
a grain of immunity if you and i did it
once we'd be jailed for contempt why
should we care because this is what
happened last august baby and this
affects you and i today you can't bury
the truth you cannot bury the truth when
it comes to national security
by 96 he'd been perfecting the embassy
plot i'm going to just blast through
this thing now because you know it's
getting late 96 fitzgerald now has
really been charged by president clinton
with getting this guy they form the bin
laden squad they rededicate squad i-49
in the new york office which lawrence
wright writes about with great in great
depth not deep enough in my opinion okay
now they have alex station at cia mike
shores running the station named after
son dan coleman from from uh from i-49
is seconded they call it he's down
there's the fbi has a guy there okay the
looming tower that's what i i was
telling you earlier the egyptian just
that's the quote i read you i read it
out of sequence forgive it maybe they
can cut this out in the anyway my
brother lawrence you know i feel brother
you just took that you creamed the
surface here and he blames wright blames
the cia for 9 11.
believe me the cia has made a lot of
committed a lot of sins over the years
but the fbi is
is singularly responsible for failing to
stop this metastasized al-qaeda presence
in new york city jamal and now how do i
know this okay now you're about to say
peter come on
jamal l foddle baby okay you see this
guy
no one's ever seen his face it's an
artist rendering with the face blocked
up
1996
right around the time they let de
vecchio retire right around the time
they bury this treasure trove of
evidence okay
this guy walks into an embassy in
eritrea and gives it called a walk-in
gives himself up he is a treasurer his
guy is so important that fitzgerald and
coleman fly to germany just to debrief
him okay now who is he who is jamal
alfano he worked at the al farooq mosque
and i remember the mosque where they
followed the guys remember shalaby the
guy that got murdered guarded he was his
boss he goes back to 1987. he fights in
afghanistan in 88 with who wali khan the
the buddy of ramsay youssef from manila
okay he works in uh the cartoon he works
in cartoon with wadi el hajj the guy
that was also in new york on the phone
message the night of the shalabi murder
he's working directly with osama bin
laden he embezzles 110 000 from al-qaeda
and they let him live but they want him
to pay it back so he splits okay they're
smart you know i want to kill the guy
i'm not going to get the debt paid so
yeah you can work it off he splits and
patrick fitzgerald now has the blueprint
in the best possible witness you can
ever have that totally confirms
everything i've been telling you about
al qaeda's presence in the united states
dating back to the late 1980s at this
mosque in brooklyn where ali muhammad
would come from fort bragg on weekends
and train these men ali muhammad
meanwhile is supporting the embassy
bombing plot that he put into motion in
august of night of 97 dan coleman
searches wadi elhaj's house in nairobi
what does he find ali muhammad's name
and phone number in sacramento
california fitzgerald flies to
california with a couple of fbi agents
has dinner at a restaurant across from
the state house hoping naively to turn
now you know i'm half
a good part of me is irish okay not
exactly half but
the most important the writing gene okay
and i love the irish people and you know
fitzgerald was lionized in vanity fair
as miss son of an irish immigrant
doorman and the bin laden brain and the
scary smart intelligence and all that
which is all true went to harvard law
school got to love him and he's he's a
great prosecutor no doubt
but he naively thinks at this point this
stage of the game 1997 october months
after they find evidence that this guy
is involved in some kind of plot in
africa he sits across from him in a
restaurant thinking he can turn him
here's what ali muhammad says to him and
ali muhammad at this point is a
naturalized u.s citizen he sworn an oath
to this country he is a honorably
discharged army veteran with a pension
that he's been collecting in the army
reserve and he says i love bin laden i
don't need a fatwa to attack america and
i have a number of sleepers that i can
make operational like that and he went
like that to paddy fischel
okay fitzgerald walked out of that
meeting and he turned to jack clooney
and fbi said that is the most dangerous
man i have ever met we cannot let him on
the street and yet he left him on the
street for ten more months only to have
the bombs go off in africa in the exact
precise location where ali muhammad took
the pictures in nineteen ninety three
courtesy of john zen who spout for him
to get him out of canadian custody so he
could go and shoot those photographs
take the pictures biladon and 94 pointed
said that's where i want the bomb to go
and they went off in the exact location
now that is co-conspirator testimony of
the highest order right i mean what a
beautiful co-conspirator he would be
what a witness for patrick fitzgerald so
the bombs go off in africa 24 people
dead 224 4 000 injured
they wait a month to arrest ali muhammad
they rate them they wait a month okay
okay see
now ali is arrested september 10th three
years almost to the day before 9 11.
he's held as a john doe why because they
don't want the media they're terrified
if the media finds out what i have in
this book they'll embarrass the fbi for
everything that they've done over the
years and failing to stop him they he
cuts a deal with fitzgerald escapes the
death penalty he's now in custodial
witness protection he has never
testified nor will he ever testify so
what did they get in return that's what
i'm trying you know you cut a deal you
get something right and when they had us
versus bin laden the case with against
the for the african embassies they used
del fatal not ali muhammad the best
witness one week after 9 11. and here's
the worst part he knew the entire plot
and they had him for three years you
hear me he knew the plot so because jack
cloonan flies back from kenya they have
ollie down in sunny florida and some
kind of custodial wouldn't they bring
him up to new york he's at the mcc jack
clinton flies from the air right from
the airport 11 o'clock at night goes in
tell me how they did it he wrote it all
out for him i told him to separate the
blades from the box cutters wrap them in
something i don't want to give it away
in in their carry-on luggage i told him
where to sit in first class of course he
knew the 9 11 plot he's living with bin
laden in 94 ramzi yusuf began the plot
in 94. not but in the 9 11 report now i
have to read again okay this is the only
thing about ali muhammad after
everything i've told you tonight about
ali muhammad this is what they say
the embassy bombings as early as
december 93 a team of al-qaeda
operatives have become casing targets in
nairobi was led by ali muhammad former
egyptian army officer had moved to the
u.s in the mid-80s enlisted in the army
and became an instructor at fort bragg
he had provided guidance and training to
extremists at the farooq mosque in
brooklyn including some who were
subsequently convicted in the february
attack in the world trade center 93. the
casing team also included a computer
expert whose write-ups were reviewed by
al-qaeda leaders
that is the body of knowledge in the 911
report the national bestseller nominated
for national book award why should we
care because today the fbi has failed to
reform the reason i wrote this book that
i worked 14-hour days for nine months
straight to get this book out is because
the bureau has not fundamentally changed
since 9 11. they've moved the deck
chairs around the titanic there are can
you believe this 13 arab speaking agents
today five years after 9 11. they spent
170 million dollars on a virtual case
file system to do what i did with my
little imac and filemaker pro connect
the dots they've already scrapped it
they're 57 million dollars in the hole
two weeks ago new york times had a story
they're saying 2009 and before they can
get it together now
this is america if bill gates and steven
jobs of apple if president bush called
them tomorrow they'd have a system in 90
days you know it it's america man we put
a man on the moon they it's it's reminds
me of the line and a few good men tom
cruise give me the truth you can't
handle the truth because if the fbi
types what's in their files in their
database and gives it to a bunch of
neutral computer programmers they go
connect the dots imagine that imagine
the snakes that are going to crawl out
of those files okay so that is what
we're talking about we're talking about
what lies beneath we're talking about
the seven eighths of the iceberg below
the surface now here is the ultimate
peter lance no money i mean really i
mean no don't get me wrong because the
you know judith gave me a decent advance
on this book don't get me wrong but i
don't have subpoena power okay i have
nothing i don't you know i'm not the fbi
i can't flash the badge and go in i
can't intimidate witnesses
all right i go back and i date a mine i
get that transcript i know sarah and i
find sphinx trading and i find dot
number one that no sarah had at 90. and
dot number two that patrick fitzgerald
knew about it and and named waleed al
noor to the list right 2828 kennedy
boulevard check cashing mailboxes two of
the 911 hijackers got their fake ids in
that 100 square foot store in july of
01. and who do they get them from
mohamed elattras okay the same guy who
was the co-incorporator now all they had
to do was do what they did at the
ravenite social club of john gotti for
seven years they had a plant or a perch
across the street they photographed
every single living italian sicilian
going in and out of that place they
tried three times to convict gotti
finally they put a microphone in the
apartment of a mafia widow upstairs
where he would conspire with sammy the
bull and they got him they got the
teflon done and good for them glad they
did okay
but if the fbi had applied ten percent
of the energy that they spent busting
the mob
focusing on gotti to al-qaeda the towers
would be standing in lower manhattan
today as god is my judge
and that's what
that's why i'm here and that's what you
have to read if you want to read if you
want to get the truth
you can handle the truth we have to
handle the truth we're americans
look at el actress that's him being
arrested the same guy co-incorporated
was the guy that did the thing now nancy
floyd and john miller's book to sell
never mentions nancy floyd that's like
that telling the story of john
dillinger's takedown in chicago without
mentioning melvin purvis the fbi agent
when nancy floyd when 9 11 the path they
bought my book they reduced her to like
an assistance role lew napoli's driving
the action john miller becomes a lead
character in the thing that's john
miller today he's the he's the chief
flack for the fbi so what i'm getting at
is you're not getting the truth from the
mainstream media day in and day out and
the last thing and i'm almost done guys
okay
and there's there's not that many of you
we're having a little wine and uh
champagne party at suite 1902 at the
century plaza this
you're all invited because you stayed
here this long okay
free wine free wine there brother okay
yeah okay the security guard's coming
right you're gonna all right now
operation able danger i able danger was
what i did with my little computer on
steroids okay it was this
it began in 19 december 99 and they did
10 000 databases a day they use search
bots open source data insurance records
they would like they'd start with the
blind shake they'd say okay he's living
in uh he's got this mosque in kennedy
bulb then they'd search everybody in the
neighborhood and they'd run them and
then you know it became like six degrees
of kevin bacon like times a hundred
quickly do you understand what i'm
saying then they would call the data
they break it down and they began to
make connections this is a plot this is
a chart they reduced everything to what
they call link chart this is a link
chart showing the original world trade
center bombing cell see the blind shake
see abu alimah ramzi yusuf is where is
he he's right there okay ali muhammad
ali muhammad is right there you see the
direct link of ali muhammad this is a
chart as of of august of 99 before they
really got into the data mining okay
with me now look at this chart this is a
chart three weeks march uh 21st of 2000
look at this chart and imagine if you're
an army general that's paid for this
program and you look at this chart what
does it show
i mean this is i didn't make this up i
mean this
and it's a wonderful thing when you're a
reporter and you think you're right and
you hope you're right and you and then
you see something like this that totally
vindicates what i've been saying all
these years this is the blind shakes new
york cell you see the shake and all
these guys this is the yusuf manila cell
youssef is in both you see maraud that's
khalid sheikh an earlier picture that's
uh wali khan
now this is ahmad salam you see him down
here trying to penetrate now look at
this this is the inner circle of
al-qaeda you have osama bin laden
al-zawahiri muhammad atef egyptian wadi
alhaj the guy from the embassy bombing
muhammad jamal khalifa the
brother-in-law and who is in the inner
circle inner sanctum of al-qaeda ali
mohammed
so imagine you're a u.s general and i
interviewed kurt weldon poor guy i don't
agree with him on a lot of issues but on
this one he was dead on he was targeted
by the bush administration he's a
conservative republican they opened a
big they had the investigation going two
years but they splashed it right before
the election he got he lost his seat he
was going to become chairman of the
house armed services committee if the
republicans had won so they risked that
seat to get rid of this guy because he
was saying that they were onto these
guys and the able danger people
decorated army officers said we had
these guys in early 2000 we had atta we
had el shahu flew 175 we had alma darno
has me the two muscle hijackers okay
what is this
what do what do you see here
ahmadar and el hazmi that's salem el
hazmi they had khalid ahmadar and walip
el hazmi the salem's brother they're
living why wouldn't they have had them
they're living openly in san diego they
have a season picket ticket to sea world
they buy a car they have their phone in
the name in the phone directory they're
hanging out at the mosque playing soccer
every day that you know they're living
oh they're living in the home of an fbi
informant named abdusad or sheik why
wouldn't they have had these guys okay
and and the 911 commission totally
denied it dietrich snell denied it the
prosecutor from patrick fitzgerald's
office denied denied denied that they
could have had this morning this guy
lieutenant anthony colonel anthony
schaefer deckary won the bronze star in
afghanistan for hunting bin laden he's
set up on three trumped-up charges
involving a couple of hundred dollars in
expenses they take his security
clearance away okay nancy floyd i told
you four and a half year opr she's
suspended they take her badging her gun
because of supposed insubordinate and
worse if you're a woman imagine this the
temptress and the spy they leak a story
to the new york post that she's having
sex with salam which is totally untrue
because he so mistrusted the bureau he
bugged the agents themselves and none of
the tapes have even a hint of that she
was a professional and where what
happened to ronnie bucca that the
morning of he's not in a fire
suppression unit he doesn't even have to
go near the towers but he's been waiting
waiting for these guys to come back
because he saw that message on that
computer way back when working in army
intelligence he rushes down to lafayette
street he goes he knows the towers like
the back of his hand he goes up to the
78th floor of the south tower
higher than any firefighter in either
tower that day with a battalion chief
oriole farmer they charge a standpipe
hose they got pressure and they die with
their boots on baby they went down the
cruelest irony of all in 9 11 is that
this guy warned people that they were
coming back for years and when they
found his remains he was identified
because of his gun because he's a fire
marshal he had taken his nomex turnout
coat and put it over people to protect
them from the flames
it doesn't get any more heroic than that
and one day he had told people long time
ago we took their castles this is from
the crusades baby and they're going to
come back and take ours there is light
at the end of the tunnel and here's what
it is in the end we're almost at the end
the de vecchio story i published this
story in in this book cover-up the
brooklyn d.a read it he called me in a
year later he said peter is there
anything just changed to dissuade you i
said absolutely not de vecchio was
indicted on four counts of second degree
murder march 30th 1996 they tried to get
his case sent to federal court last
couple of months ago would be buried now
it's going forward baby a new chance to
get to the full truth behind 9 11. this
is the chart from the district attorney
in new york as justice cardozo once said
sunlight is the best disinfectant okay
that's it
[Applause]
five minutes for questions
just i know we're running in fact your
tape is probably all right go ahead just
quick and then we can run over and have
some wine and champagne
and you want to get up and talk to them
i'm an old air force officer so i have a
little bit of credibility here and uh i
want to thank you
uh you're very compelling and your book
is incredibly compelling uh
i don't you fear for your safety
no because i'm well known at borders i
just hang out in butch
to protect me
yeah but you're talking about a lot of
people that feel they're untouchable
it's true but you know what you just got
to go for it what are you going to do
you're going to hide in the crown of
america
all right
thank you if we if we get so afraid in
this country to tell the truth
sir
you look like you're from the bureau
no okay go ahead no i'm not in
dereliction of dirt duty uh colonel buzz
patterson wrote about uh a pdb that he
saw on clinton's desk in 1996.
no no talking about planes as missiles
and nobody
nobody has investigated this it's right
there in his book
have you talked to him about this and he
says also all these pdbs are preserved
you don't have to take his word for it
you have to find somebody who will go
and get this and and see if he's wrong
or if he's right absolutely yeah
absolutely you know the thing is that uh
the um the presidential daily brief of
that went to bush and crawford there was
a similar one to clinton in 1998 about
the blind shaking this threat
they absolutely knew the planes as
missiles plot i interviewed a diplomatic
security agent who took the file from
boogie mendoza brought it to the league
at manila gave it to the fbi legal
attache knew that it came to new york i
mean that no foreign memo was proof that
they had part of it uh and it's just
it's it's on to the toshiba laptop this
rafael garcia has no reason to lie and
he spoke with such specificity about
these targets they were all they had he
had all three had the pope plot he had
bajinka and he had the the 911 plot but
he didn't they didn't talk about the
911. and maria rasa i want to throw a
shout out to her the courageous bureau
chief in manila for cnn not working a
princetonian a filipina america another
woman okay and she had done this story
on september 18th and that's the story
where i first saw colonel mendoza they
only ran it twice remember everybody had
a flag on their car back then nobody
wanted to knock the government nobody
wanted to believe that the government
could have failed and when the
philippines police started saying we
told the americans they they got cut off
at the knees and colonel mendoza was
exiled so
i'm just trying to get out here and
document the record and with each book i
get more and more and more information
the fbi head in manila at that time
robert hefner i get that from a village
voice article from yeah that's a great
he interviewed rafi garcia i cite that
article in my book yes did you ever get
a chance to talk with retired fbi man
robert hefner i tried to find him and i
couldn't but you've given me a good
assignment now you're very knowledgeable
brother do you know how to reach him
no all right we'll talk okay all right
thanks anybody else this gentleman here
in the white shirt do you mind getting
up uh yeah sure you were about to allude
to uh twa flight 800.
well yeah okay he can hear me you were
going to elude twa flight 800 and i just
wanted you to go there yeah i have a
whole section of cover-up like the first
half of cover-up not only deals with the
de vecchio story but it talks about one
of the pieces of evidence that came out
in that treasure trove of evidence from
11 months was what i believe is a
probative probative case circumstantial
but probit of the twa 800 the crash of
july 17 1996 was bojinka fulfilled i'll
try and give you the quick headlines but
i encourage you if you go to
peterlands.com you just download the
timeline that's in this book for free
just follow along and if you believe
that there's credibility in my work then
get the books okay but tw 800 number one
ramsey youssef is on trial for this plot
he's with greg scarpa he's giving memos
at the fbi are recording we're going to
put a bomb on a plane to get a mistrial
why well if a bomb goes off identical to
the one in the philippines he could say
i've been in jail for a year reasonable
doubt maybe somebody else did it okay on
the eve of the most damaging evidence
going into trial the confession of murad
to colonel mendoza in the philippines
which they're going to get a conviction
uh tw 800 identical 747 uh to the one in
manila that he did the wet test on takes
off bound for paris shortly after
clearing long island airspace there's an
event everybody agrees an event in the
area of the center wing fuel tank the
fuel tank explodes the plane is
decapitated part of the plane continued
rising with the engines turning now the
missile theorists the people who believe
in the missile theory argue that that's
wrong and that it was the missile that
shot the plane down but let me just give
you my evidence of a bomb so the fbi
that the next day james calstrom the
head of the new york office having seen
this evidence from ramsey threatening an
airliner puts a thousand agents out on
long island the good old u.s navy this
is a reason i don't believe there was a
navy missile went astray because why
would the navy have dredged up 96 of the
plane if they thought they were going to
be culpable okay they assembled the
plane in calvert and long island
ironically in the old grumman 810
warthog factory where i shot when i was
at abc news
there's no uh missile piercing in the in
the fuselage however in the area between
the 17th and the 25th row of the
remember i told you the 26 rows where
you sub planted the bomb and it was two
froze back they find rdx high explosive
nitroglycerin the exact explosive ramsey
youssef's pajama device and uh and
p-e-t-n the new york times is about to
run a story that on on august 21st
1996 about a month after the bombing
evidence of bomb on plane calstrom goes
to a meeting in washington with jamie
gorelick and louis free i don't know who
else is in the room he comes back and
does a 180 degree turn tries to get the
new york times story killed the story
runs the next day then he comes out and
says well there's many reasons though
you could have explosives on a plane
absent a bomb they're like what what are
you talking about so they act actually
said find out where this plane is we got
to explain the explosives absent a bomb
listen to what they find a month later
mid-september they find out the plane
has been involved in a canine test with
a bomb sniffing dog in st louis six
weeks earlier they claim that the
officer got on planted the test devices
for the dog to qualify him somehow spill
the the explosives got into the carpet
it's it survived weeks underwater a
power cleaning at the dock etc but guess
what my brother brother bob laughed at
that as many people would but guess what
everybody folded the next day the new
york times bought it newsday which won a
pulitzer prize bought it nobody sent a
reporter to st louis to interview the
cop guess what i did i went to st louis
herman burnett great man he was about to
retire and i walked into american
admirals club and i handed him my first
book i said herman every single telling
of this story from this point on they
make you more and more negligent they
they practically act like you poured
bushels of explosives and ground them
into the you know carpet with your feet
and i'm giving you this book and your
your grandchildren should not go down
with you in history being a goat on on
this crash okay
if you believe in me i want to talk to
you he read the book i called him up
later and he said peter i did the test
on another plane and i demonstrate
beyond a reasonable doubt that there was
a second 747 it gave 52 gate 50 was the
fatal flight gate 52 was an identical
plane made within three n numbers 25
years earlier he did the test on the
other plane and how do we know that i
got the gate the gate report from twa
that day he got off the plane at noon by
all accounts including the fbi as he was
getting off the plane flight attendants
were just coming on that plane that he
that was the fatal flight twa 800 left
fully catered and fully crewed with 220
people for honolulu and 45 minutes later
the other plane didn't leave for until 1
45 he did the test on the other plane so
i have removed i show motive opportunity
yusuf through the patch through called
khalid sheikh mohammed and doha gutter
we know that khalid sheikh now how to
build the device all ramsay has to do is
say put it on a plane in athens why
wouldn't the fbi have known what they
were saying because they had an arab
speaking agent he's speaking urdu and
baluki and they don't even know what
he's saying in real time i believe he
told khalid to have the device planted
have it timed to the exact moment before
the most damaging and the next day he
asked judge duffy for a mistrial exactly
as he predicted he would with greg's
garbage junior i rest my case you had
interviewed tenet who was the head of
the fbi
or the cia right all right not sure i
heard you interview that who was head of
the fbi and i couldn't louis free
i thought it was
i you can only talk to so many people i
didn't interview tennant because my book
focuses on the fbi i mean it's it's an
epic enough story as it is just to focus
on one of the big five agencies louis
free that's a good question maybe even
with all due diligence maybe i should
have gone back and here's what i would
have asked louis free if i had the
opportunity louis if you're watching
tonight or this morning wherever they
hear this
director free tell me one thing okay
why is it that you spent an entire
chapter of your book
and he went after clinton tooth and nail
and i have you've heard me tonight been
very critical of the clinton
administration so i you know take no
prisoners when it comes to democrats or
republicans but
louis freed blames the kobar towers
bombing entirely on hezbollah and he
suggests that clinton was negligent in
not forcing the saudis to like cough up
the suspects et cetera ramsey youssef
tells greg scarpa jr right after that
bombing and it's on fbi 302 memos that
we were involved he said i tried to
scout the uh to get the the the tanker
truck that did the bombing ali muhammad
had brokered a summit between muginaw
the head of hezbollah and and and bin
laden which is the equivalent of the
capulets in the monaco's meeting in the
fbi's own files and what don't you think
the 911 is one of the few things they
said that was dead on at the end right
at the end they said yes new evidence
that al qaeda was involved in the cobar
towers bombing so i would have asked
louis free louis either you'd not
looking at the intelligence in your
files or you've gone along with this
hoax and scam story to bury this
information james calstrom by the way
the former addict of the new york office
who made his bones on tw 800 who became
famous who got a job at merchants
national bank in delaware and he got
louis free a job that's where louis free
is working today and and calstr became
terrorism czar of new york state under
governor pataki james calstrom when i
interviewed him about the tw 800 thing
and i told him about the bomb sniffing
dog he said okay but there was no
metallurgical evidence we didn't find
metallurgical evidence i said who's the
who did you uh who's your authority well
billy bill tobin william tobin a chief
metallurgist there's no metallurgical so
i call tobin you know what i said bill
what did you use as a model to measure
indicia of bomb damage on this flight he
said what do you mean what i use i said
well there are only two bombs that have
ever gone off prior to tw 800 on a 747.
he said what do you mean two bombs i
said pan am 103 over locker b scotland
where toshiba boombox of semtex blew the
plane to smithereens and bojinka the
ramsay youssef test and he goes what's
bojinka i said what i said you're
telling me that you concluded with the
ntsb that a spark in the fuel tank
caused this plane to go down you that
you said there's no indicia bomb damage
and you didn't use the model of ramsay
youssef's wet test how would i have
known about that he says i said well
you're from virginia did they give you
an office at 26 federal plaza that
summer yeah yeah i was up there well did
you see a bunch of tv trucks across the
street that was called the bojinka trial
bill it's the third biggest news story
in new york after the twa in the
democratic convention how could you have
not known so the chief metallurgist of
the fbi who james calstrom cites as the
authority of no metallurgical evidence
is consistent with a bomb tells me he
didn't even do didn't even know about
bojinka now what is that if that's not
gross negligence i don't know what is
okay i gotta do one more another person
okay because we're limited
are you happy did you have a good time
tonight
thank you all right anybody else
anybody else out there
wait this gentleman well we'll talk
after you come over and have a glass of
wine
all right let me ask you to end on a
philosophical note because
you've told in a compelling story with a
great deal of passion
and i've had some experience in
government myself
and
there seems to be a problem with people
who
want to find the truth like yourself
and people who
want to what we call cya
and who maybe basically are incompetent
or who have reached the pinnacle
in the peter principle of their ability
but they still want to go higher
and then they want to be protected
what is what you've said
in your view and maybe it's an
impossible question
but what does it say about democracy
in having a functional government where
we know what's going on
and we're able to resolve the problems
and solve them in a way that these
things don't continue to happen
because these people that you've written
about continue
to do cya right and right reach their
level of incompetence and want to go
beyond
beautiful question excellent question it
goes to the s thank you it goes to the
essence of what this book is about this
this cover-up the bracketing of
intelligence that happened as i said was
just to protect the bureau and justice
from multiple embarrassments over the
years now why i we have to take a model
from the fire service uh you know ronnie
book i've i told you i had his mass card
on the wall every morning when i when i
worked jimmy kelty a fire marshal once
told me he had started off as a police
officer and he became a firefighter and
then a fire marshal and in new york
there is
antipathy bordering on hatred between
the reds and the blues okay and i write
about it my first book first degree burn
and jimmy kelty started off you know
they take all the exams and whoever
calls them first they go so he had
started off as a cop and he walked into
a station house during the nap
commission the police corruption scandal
was serpaco and he got patted down by by
a lieutenant and he was ostracized for
months nobody taught him the job he said
when he finally got into a fire house he
walked in and the lieutenant hugged him
and he said i'm going to teach you
everything i know about this business
because you will pull me out of a
building someday and he said when we
screwed up on the job we would go out
for beers afterwards and there wasn't
any recrimination finger-pointing you're
wrong you're wrong you're wrong we
didn't humiliate the guys because we
needed them and so the point is the the
law enforcement mentality which you
which is embodied in the fbi and it
comes down from hoover which ran the
agencies in a way that people were
afraid do you know len prednishenkis
that hero that man that that's helped us
against the russians all those years
he said peter
the best day of my career was when i hit
my kma date i said what's your kma date
he said it's the kiss my date and that's
the first day after 20 when i can retire
so why is that such a big deal he says
because if they try and open an internal
affairs investigation on me i can put my
papers in and retire before it happens
and imagine being a 20-year veteran in
the fbi and being that afraid of being
investigated and and so these agents
start off really wanting to do the right
thing clarice starlings of the world
coming out of quantico like nancy
bright-eyed bushy-tailed you know they
want to do good for their country okay
and i celebrate the street or the brick
agent my work and they day after day
after day management the suits
collectively known as the you know they
call them management and there's ig
reports this document this they start
penalizing these guys and so they begin
spending what percentage five ten
fifteen percent of their time when
they're supposed to be looking for the
bad guys looking over their shoulder and
just phoning it in baby and nancy floyd
has three more years god bless her till
she retires she's in denver now you know
and i got a christmas card from her and
she goes three more years you know and
she was
one of the best they had thought outside
the box worked two jobs nobody could
tell her no and she she reminded me that
scene in the french connection where
popeye doyle and uh eddie egan are at
the restaurant you know they they can't
go home and that's how they found the
sal boca the mob guys late at night
because they couldn't go home you can't
work in the fbi in new york and take the
train home with orange county at five
o'clock and
break terrorists because these guys
don't sleep by a nine to five clock they
remain a threat and here's one of the
great greatest uh faults of patrick
fitzgerald in my opinion when he was
told by ali muhammad that he had
sleepers in this country and he
ultimately cut a deal with him not one
of those sleepers has ever been wrapped
up and believe me if they wrapped them
up by now you would have heard about
them you could argue maybe in the first
couple of years they would have watched
them but a after 9 11 they would have
made big publicity out of any of them
where are those guys now where are they
ahmad
ahmed amid rafael an accountant buries
himself in the fire department all those
years only to get the call to get the
plans to come on the armchair on the
blind i couldn't make this stuff up
we remain at risk and yet patrick
fitzgerald before christmas had a big
victory they got a guy allegedly trying
to blow up a mall in chicago and he was
so broke he had to trade stereo
equipment for the grenades and they call
that a major terror bust we remain at
great risk i want to see you know what i
want to see happen the secret service
should have this job the secret service
tomorrow if the secret service got
counterterrorism we would be
exponentially more safe they do a great
job of protecting the president they do
counterfeiting investigations they did
the salt lake city olympics they're
already in place we'd have to create a
new logo we didn't have to start a new
agent just give them the funds and guess
what you know they have a database baby
because they've been watching the whack
jobs threatening the president for years
give it to the secret service and you
and you can hug your children in the
morning and know you are exponentially
safer the bureau was the wrong agency
then it's the wrong agency now
that's it
[Applause]
peter lance author of triple cross how
bin laden's master spy penetrated the
cia the green beret and the fbi and why
patrick fitzgerald failed to stop him
learn more at peterlands.com
[Music]
[Music]
larry berman reveals the double life of
journalist and north vietnamese spy
fomzun ahn in his new book perfect spy
mr berman recounts fomzun ons travels in
the united states during the 1950s were
on used to his study of journalism as a
cover while collecting information on
the us
on would later return to vietnam and
report for time magazine during the war
where he befriended american reporters
such as david halberstam throughout his
time working amongst the american media
on continued to send intelligence
reports to the viet cong
larry berman discusses his book with
robert kaiser associate editor of the
washington post
hello i'm robert kaiser of the
washington post and i'm here today with
larry berman the author of perfect spy
a remarkable book about a remarkable
vietnamese called farmswan on
who both of us knew at different times i
knew on when i was a correspondent young
correspondent for the washington post in
vietnam in 1969 and 1970 and saw him
again briefly in 1994. mr berman didn't
meet him until 2000 but spent a lot more
time with him than i did and had the
really great fortune of getting him to
talk about one of the most extraordinary
spying careers really of the 20th
century and that will be the subject of
our discussion
today
it seems to me that mr berman and i are
at unfair disadvantage and we have an
unfair advantage excuse me over viewers
because
we know the vietnam war this is mr
berman's fourth book on the subject uh
and we know a lot of the characters in
this story and most of you don't
so i thought we might begin by asking mr
berman to
give us a little primer first of all to
explain who was from
now well
hopefully at the end of an hour i'll
we'll still be discussing who the real
fans
might have been
but the phantom that i write about
uh was born in 1927.
in uh in southern part of vietnam uh and
during the entire early part of his life
lived under what we would call french
colonialism
vietnam was a colony of france uh and
during this period of time he had seen
uh great inequities in uh in in wealth
and in landowning and and the like uh
and uh over time uh as the vietnam
movement began to take shape
and the fight against the french began
and the french were defeated of course
in 1954 dmvn foo
this young man was recruited into the
vietnam viet minh party led by ho chi
minh a movement a nationalistic movement
that was aimed at ridding france uh
reading vietnam
of its french occupiers
he joined the vietnam in 1944 he was 17
years old that's correct how did that
happen well he was recruited uh the viet
minh were very active uh in recruiting
young people in the south uh on was one
of the very first people recruited and
one of the first selected
to be what would eventually become a
strategic
espionage unit of the vietnam forces and
what was your sense i know you didn't
meet him until many many years later but
why do you think they were drawn to him
particularly
well i think they were drawn to
uh
almost all of the young vietnamese that
they could find who they could enlist in
this what was a nationalistic patriotic
movement for their country's
independence to rid their country of all
foreign armies uh and in particular uh
the french
occupation and on was really attracted
to that i mean this really had a great
resonance for him as it did for
thousands and thousands of other
vietnamese but what eventually really
attracted the vietnam was the fact that
he spoke english
and he learned english very early from
british missionaries actually and uh
this was a very important element in his
selection to be a strategic uh espionage
agent
now what was his role during the what
the vietnamese called the french war up
until 54 what did he do
well he had he he was a small time
player uh he
he his job was basically to give reports
uh on the status of french shipments and
the like and to also report on on on
where munitions were and things like
that but it was nothing we would
consider to be heavy spying or anything
and what was he doing for a living
he was like all viet men uh
struggling to make a living on told me
that he would often
at night be a cyclo driver
and he would take people around and
things like that in the traditional uh
vietnamese mode of transportation the
ciclo the cyclo is a bicycle cab that's
right a three-wheeler we've both ridden
and then
uh
so
now explain this tell this extraordinary
story how he ended up at a at a new
college in orange county california
which obviously was the great the great
shaping coincidence of arn's life that
he got to california before the
americans were significantly heavily
into vietnam tell that story yeah well
here i here i think this is one of the
most interesting parts of the book but
also yvonne's life which is
that the french are defeated in 1954 at
the mbn foo
and between 1954 and 1955 and even into
1956
uh the viet man are watching and they're
seeing that the united states are
beginning to replace the french both
with respect to money the creation of
the bank of vietnam
uh the support of president uh zm uh and
also these early advisers who are
showing up in vietnam first ten let's
explain the presidency ziem
is the
man many readers know is president diem
this is a idiosyncrasy of vietnamese
pronunciation but d-i-e-m
the first president of an independent
south vietnam that's right
who would eventually be removed in
office in a cia
indulged coup in 1963 on november 1st of
1963. but here the viet man are watching
all of this activity and they suddenly
realized that uh america is replacing
the french and that one
france and that once again the
vietnamese weren't going to be allowed
to determine their own their own their
own future uh that the struggle for
vietnamese independence was going to
again involve a fight against a foreign
occupying nation now this is only 1955.
to me this is the most interesting part
of van's life really and here are these
vietnamese
viet men they're looking overseas and
they're saying to themselves uh who are
the united states who are these guys how
are we going to learn about them
and they looked at pham sunan and they
said you know we're going to send on to
the united states we're going to raise
the money
first we have to he has to get a
sponsorship to go to the united states
uh but we're gonna send to the united
states and we're gonna make him our
american expert we're gonna send him to
a college we're gonna have a major in
journalism he's gonna spend several
years there he's gonna learn everything
he can he can about the americans and
he's going to come back here and tell us
because we don't know very much about
them and one of the first thing on does
in his role as an espionage agent is he
becomes very close and best friends with
the leading american anti-communists in
vietnam and this included the legendary
colonel edward lansdale who would
sponsor on's visit to the united states
and actually was the one who recommended
that on go to orange coast college in
costa mesa california
and so in 1957 this young vietnamese kid
well he's not that young really he's 30
years old by then uh arrives in costa
he's older than most undergraduates at
the time he arrives in costa mesa to
study journalism and he begins his
two-year stay in the united states under
the sponsorship of edward lansdale the
asia foundation
and
a whole group of other people who wanted
to see him succeed little did they know
let's explain lansdale was a cia
operative of a special kind and the asia
foundation was sort of a cia front at
that time absolutely yeah and their man
their man to fight communism that is the
reason they selected on
was they found in him the perfect person
they believed has come to the united
states train in journalism go back and
work for newspapers in the south to help
combat the communist menace uh and i
just find that to be in hindsight of
course uh just unbelievable uh this is
of course a book full of ironies of this
kind and a story i mean it's just
amazing isn't it how many times you say
to yourself whoa you couldn't make it up
that's what i often i often say and then
he ends up and think of how lucky on was
i mean they didn't send him to uh you
know
a horrible place i mean he lands in
newport beach
and he's hanging out from 57 to 59 in
costa mesa the first by the way and this
is an important point he's the first
vietnamese in orange county now today of
course orange county is the heart of the
largest of vietnamese american
population uh in our country but back
then what two 000 vietnamese actually in
excess i think almost 300 000 uh but uh
back then he was the first and of course
the greater irony is that the first
vietnamese to arrive in orange county
turned out to be a communist agent which
and we we shouldn't spend a lot of time
on this but it's intriguing in your book
what his undergraduate career was like
but there's an aspect on which you have
been very diplomatic about in writing
but he was obviously quite a skirt
chaser throughout his life
and he made some american girlfriends in
in california
too uh but he really fit in didn't he
manage to charm these american kids who
as you said were much younger mostly
than he was but he came really a big man
on campus uh well everyone was
interested in him uh you know people
refer to him as ho chi minh and uh and
other other jokes about this but the
fact of the matter is that uh ahn had
this very amiable quality about him he
turned out to be a great
conversationalist but back then he was a
good conversationalist i interviewed his
former college roommates i interviewed
one of the women who he proposed to
and of course he had a weekly column in
the newspaper and on always said
that the greatest thing about his two
years in america was that the american
people taught him this new way of
thinking they opened up a whole way of
of approaching the world and he's he
always said the communist party could
only teach him
certain things
but the freedom that he
he felt and and and lived in america the
spontaneity all of that uh he thought
was one of the most valuable lessons of
his life now you've talked about how he
joined the viet minh did do you think he
felt himself to be a communist in any
meaningful way at this stage of his life
yeah that's a really great question uh i
think ahn considered himself to be a
vietnamese patriot and a nationalist
he really did not go to
many communist party meetings what the
communist party in vietnam would become
after the war
was not the party that ahn ever thought
that he had joined
as part of the revolution he saw himself
fighting for vietnamese independence
and he never thought himself for example
as a member of a stalinist brigade or
never thought of the influence of the
soviet union uh on vietnam which
wouldn't come too much later
he was always wary of china as most
vietnamese are in this very tense
relationship between
china and and vietnam but uh ahn saw
himself as fighting for the independence
of his country against all foreign
invaders and when that ended
his country would be united and his
mission would be over and in ahn's
rather naive view of the world at the
time
everyone would just get along
i think it's a very important point
readers want to follow up on this
i always recommend neil sheehan's
brilliant book bright shining lie
which has within it about a 50 page i
guess history of the of the communists
in hanoi and how they became communist
and
jopp and von bond and the others became
communists originally as bright young
middle class and upper middle class
french trained intellectuals
it's an intriguing story and i in my
opinion they too
were nationalists first and saw this
political affiliation as a vehicle to
promote the independence
of vietnam but it's a
americans looking back now can be
tempted to be i think to oversimplify
this story because i i suspect
knowing on as i did that in
1956 or what did he go to 57 57 when he
went to california the idea that ho chi
minh was an active agent of the common
turn and somehow you know when they have
on guard of world communism would have
been nothing to that that just didn't
resonate for him i don't think i i can't
read minds or go back in a time machine
but it just seems to be unlikely that
that
the idea of uh ho and his comrades as a
somehow agent some soviet power in asia
didn't make any sense to a vietnamese
like on at that time and you know i
think the most important thing
for for
viewers to recall about on is that from
19 literally from 1950 or 51 you could
pick the date through the end of the war
in 1975 on of course had you know no
direct contact with anyone we would
consider the communist party he was
living a cover amongst a free people or
people fighting to be free uh and uh so
he was really on the other side and uh
for the duration of the and you know for
the duration of these these years of
night of 30 to 50. stunning part of the
story to me and
you have this wonderful revelation that
i mean one of the many consequences of
the fact you just cited is that nobody
trained on how to be a spy
so david albertson our wonderful
colleague who died recently in a tragic
accident gave him a copy of a book tell
about that yeah uh i asked on you know
where did he learn how to do this and he
said well uh you know i didn't know
anything about spying but david
hoverstamp gave me a book to make me a
better reporter and it was on spying and
he gets up and he pulls it off of his
bookshelf it's the original copy and
things are underlined on
on on how to be a good spy the
importance of a cover
the key to having a good liaison agent
and the like and how to you know sort
out your information and the like and
ann just took me through the book and he
said i learned it all from this book and
then i learned it from trial and error
and i had a little bit of luck but i had
really no one to teach me because there
was no and then he would go into this
big thing we have no american fbi or cia
or anything where people can you have to
go to school for two years mine was on
the job training human intelligence is
what he always referred to it as the
best the human intelligence
now let's go back to the chronology he
comes back from california and he does
become a journalist of a kind
yes and i think it's important also that
after his two years
in california majoring in journalism at
orange coast college he goes to
sacramento interns at the sacramento b
uh becomes very good friends with the
mcclatchy family who own the bee and a
very influential family in publishing in
california and then drives across the
united states convinces the asia
foundation that he wants to see america
so he drives across the united states in
his own car that he is bought on campus
47 yes
a mercury
and then he interns at the united
nations uh and so and then he hears he
gets word in a secret coded message that
uh things are very bad in his country
that is the amongst the viet cong or the
uh
uh the the the crackdown by the the zm
regime is so strong and so effective
that virtually his entire network has
been locked up and on doesn't know what
to do
because you know should he go back to
vietnam and maybe someone has given up
his name already and if he diminity
lands he'll he'll uh he'll be executed
or taken off to prison and tortured he
considers going to cuba he considers
going to
all over but then ultimately he decides
his mission is too important and he goes
back to vietnam hides out for a month
and then gets a job at vietnam press
hired by winter
it's a very interesting story about how
he is hired and why but the key is is
that he's recommended to winter by the
leading anti-communist
in vietnam at the time a man by the name
of dr twin uh who
believes that ahn is the perfect person
to help fight communism in in our in in
now vietnam and he goes to work for
vietnam press and eventually south
vietnam now south vietnam and then he
will go to reuters
uh to uh the uh the new york herald
tribune and eventually by 1965 he will
be hired by time magazine as times
correspondent at the correspondent for
time magazine and what tell us what his
job was for time magazine what was his
role
well ahn was four time the only
vietnamese
journalist at the time who was fully
credentialed
you were you were you were in vietnam
and you know this better than i as a
correspondent and a war reporter fact is
that most of the vietnamese who work for
american
news outlets and alike they were
stringers or or they didn't have any
official status but on had an official
status that time and this is very very
rare uh and uh he was basically the
go-to guy uh reporters official status
being member of the bureaucracy member
of the bureau right on the masthead of
time magazine on the masthead of time
magazine he would approve the maps uh
the drawings in time magazine
people ran copy through him all the time
he contributed to copy and most
important uh the american reporters who
would come to vietnam and of course even
though he worked for time
on was also working and advising a whole
range of other uh journalists uh the new
yorkers robert chaplin for example but
also international reporters like john
claude pamonte and others everyone
relied on on because of two things
he he appeared to understand
the americans so well he could explain
what the hell they were doing in the
country and perhaps certain actions and
that because he had spent so much time
with the americans but also for the
americans he could he could explain
vietnamese history vietnamese culture
vietnamese society and he could also
explain the war because his english was
so good he was such a great
conversationalist and he loved to talk
and
if people took the time and listened to
on they would
sometimes sit as many people have told
me for hours
as he would begin in the f 500 500th
century and take them all the way up to
1971 if they were willing to listen and
so he was a very reliable uh resource
for for all reporters in vietnam
uh and what was the significance
of his status
as a journalist to his role as a spy
well of course that is that is the big
question and and and uh being a
journalist um gave on access to
uh first of all a lot of sources that he
ordinarily might not have uh he for
example and in the book there's a little
a picture of his uh of his card that
allowed him access into mcv which is the
military assistance command vietnam's
training areas and the likes so he uh he
had access into military headquarters
right right but uh being there and
listening to these debriefings and uh
just being able to make sense of it and
like would be very very important uh but
on's real work as a spy and the things
that he contributed to uh what vietnam
would describe as their victory over the
americans came not so much from him
being a journalist but from his contacts
with
his con his contacts in the commune in
the intelligence community primarily the
vietnamese central intelligence
organization which was the counterpart
or was modeled after our own cia and
on's job uh was to be involved in the
creation of this organization in 1961
and 1962 and he remained literally a
consultant for the south vietnamese cio
and so he would get all these top secret
documents from the south vietnamese as
well what was in those documents what
would have been helpful to the north
well i think
certainly uh i think on's most pivotal
role uh concerned uh his contributions
in 1961 and 1962
that culminated in the battle of opbach
in january of 1963 a very small but
critical sort of turning point in the
war the way the war was covered the
beginning of a credibility gap and also
amongst the communist side
a real sort of invigorating um
event because it proved that uh
the vietcong forces could stand up to
american counterinsurgency the
helicopters the ues and the last april
62
january
of of of 63 is is op box
but let's a-p-b-a-c
uh it's the opening section of neil
sheehan's book is a vivid description of
this donald kneel was theirs that when
it happened
it's an extraordinary event really in
military history for just the reasons
you decided that
here the u.s had brought in all this new
equipment all this new doctrine and
training they thought they'd figured out
how to cope with these
cheeky guerrillas
from the vietcong and instead they got
clobbered didn't they and only uh two
uh members of the viet man or by now the
vietcong
and the communist side received
accommodations and medals for their
contribution to the victory one was the
battlefield commander and the other was
farm soon on who was working for reuters
magazine so now the question was abused
new zealand
reuters news agency and the question is
what could on's contribution have been
well for a period of two years on was
sending up documents on the entire
american counter-surgency campaign the
new way of american warfare and what
would happen is those reports uh and
photographs of those documents would
eventually make it all the way to hanoi
where general jiap and his military
planners
were able to develop a counter to the
american
program of this new warfare known as
counter insurgency and general jiaop
thought that ahn's reports were so
cogent uh so to the point that he
proclaimed thanks to fam tsunan we are
now in america's war room uh which i
believe was true where did he where did
he proclaim that job uh ziap has
proclaimed that in several uh
publications both in vietnam uh and uh
and it was most recently done in a
biography of [ __ ] uh written by uh by by
one by whose name is uh miss winbot i
believe
and
when did we when did we understand this
aspect of han's career when when did
people outside vietnam grasp
that he had played such an important
role at that time well it wasn't too
well after the war uh on's cover which
the reason i even call the book perfect
spy is that i believe on's cover was was
so perfect that is to have lived this
role that he had lived for so long
and never to be caught
to me is just just extraordinary his
cover was so complete that in april of
1975 he and we'll probably talk about
this he evacuated his family to the
united states
so it wasn't until
1976 and 1977 that people began to have
an inkling that perhaps on wasn't who
they thought he was and that was because
he recalled his family and any
vietnamese were calling their family
from the united states to vietnam in
1976 or 1977 at a time when millions of
vietnamese were trying to get to that no
one was going back
and indeed the family first had to go to
paris wait nine months and eventually
went back to vietnam and then a picture
surface that's reprinted in the book of
of on
with general giap and
quite ironically also with bui tin who
later would break with the party
and uh become quite a critic of the
government as as on would later become
as well uh but uh this was in hanoi uh
with general jia pinning a medal uh and
promoting on to the rank of general uh
and hero of the people's army and then
the gig was up and everyone knew that
fam soon on time correspondent
journalist was actually all the time uh
general of the people's army
now let's talk about
living that double life it seemed to me
tying down about this in 1994 but more
in more detail reading your book
that
one of the reasons he was able to pull
this off
is that it wasn't really very hard for
him he wasn't living a big lie
in his own mind he loved the journalism
he loved the charming people he loved
the traveling around and hustling for
facts that we all do in the newspaper
business
uh the only thing that he was doing the
extra was sitting down late at night
with his invisible ink and writing
writing these reports and then sending
off copies of documents and so on but in
fact
literally apart from those moments when
he was doing those
nefarious things the rest of his life
was quite sincere he didn't have to
pretend day by day in in the the the
things he was doing were false somehow
to him they weren't they were natural
and fun for him i think what do you
think of that
well i think
in a i agree with most of what you said
i'm not completely there because i do
think there is this fine line to be a
very important question has to be asked
that is was on in his job as a
journalist
enjoying this life which he clearly did
was he at any time using any of his
close friends as source material for his
reports back to hanoi i mean did he
uh did he from these long conversations
with david harvestam neil sheehan
yourself or anybody
who was there
did he pick up things that eventually
might have then
in the evening as he was writing his
reports perhaps been you know an add-on
to something he would have done i'm sure
that they were i i don't have any doubt
about that but how does that contradict
my my hypothesis that he
he was being true to himself it wasn't i
mean he obviously wouldn't have liked to
would have admitted that to albert
stammersheen that he was using them for
this purpose but but it didn't require
him to be somehow duplicitous or he just
he just didn't have to he he had to not
mention it that's all he didn't have to
that's right that's how on explain it to
me you always said i never lied to
anyone i just didn't tell them the
complete truth i didn't tell them i
didn't tell them everything but he did
tell me that
living this dual life of being a
reporter
uh and then being a spy
the mental discipline and the
compartmentalization and the daily
strain was very immense on him because
he was the hardest thing for him he had
to always remember when he was filing a
story for time or helping bob chaplin uh
for the new yorker that he couldn't
include information
that he had gotten
offline that is it wasn't available to
all other reporters uh in vietnam or was
it in a captured document and the
hardest thing was to every day make sure
that he didn't screw up because if the
one time he would add information if it
ever happened
he would be outed and he would be dead
and of course again i find it
fascinating that he was the of all of
the uh communist agents operating in the
south and you know there were hundreds
and hundreds of these agents thousands
that infiltrated almost every every
level of south vietnam's government
bureaucracy and newspapers everywhere
on's mission was was first of all very
very important but he survived the
longest of any other vietnamese
communist agent no one else survived as
long as on did and this was one of the
things he was most proud of is the fact
that you know so many other people is
that noble i i read that with but i i'm
not sure
that assumes that he knows who every
agent was and how long they survived
i wonder if that if that's arguable i
don't know if it's arguable the party
that you know the party has done
even today they've done a very good job
of
sending out materials on who their
heroes were who the spies were like
and no one else has ever yet claimed the
longitude longevity role that uh that on
has we'll take a break here and come
back in a couple of minutes to continue
this conversation about a perfect spy by
larry berman be right back
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts
more with larry berman and robert kaiser
in a moment
book tv invites you to visit our new
enhanced website www.booktv.org
recently redesigned we've added more
information a new look and made it even
easier for you to use stop by booktv.org
for more about book fairs book tv news
and bus events or check out the full
weekend schedule for a new schedule
printing feature or to watch video
online
let us know what you think send emails
to online at cspan.org
afterwards with larry berman and robert
kaiser continues
we're back to talk about larry berman's
book the perfect spy about farms
one of the most remarkable spies of the
20th century
uh we talked about the the village of op
bach a very famous battle at the
beginning of the vietnam war
surely the biggest and most important
engagement battle of the war was the
tent offensive
in late january 1968
and there too it turns out
in your book on played a very important
role tell that story now if you would
yeah
well
the ted offensive is going to occur in
january of 1968 but months before that
planning had started and this is the
only time during the war that ahn's
direct supervisor a man by the name of
uh tu khan uh comes into saigon on
creates a cover for him uh that he's a
famous bird he's a bird purveyor and a
dog collector just like on and they're
going to spend time together you know
trying to uh
buy bur rare birds in saigon where is
ron's hobby we should explain and he
always had a german shepherd dog right
oh yeah the dog was a great lookout for
him as he did his drops but also it was
a great cover for him as he could always
disappear for a few days to say he was
out buying a dog or training someone's
dog and indeed
he used to train uh wind calcu's dog who
was the vice former vice president of
the republic of vietnam in the south so
on was known for dogs and birds
and in this case uh
the ons direct supervisor comes and it's
their job
to basically provide
reports on infiltration points into into
south vietnam or directly into saigon
which will lead to these mass uprisings
supposedly the mass uprisings and also
to identify those military installations
where security was weak that might be
vulnerable to attacks by the invading
vietcong forces and of course ah on from
tsunam because he had access to most of
these uh
bases and uh and radio stations and
alike he was really quite uh familiar
with the security arrangements and so
they sent these reports back uh and uh
they on would later receive a medal for
his contributions uh during during this
period ahn always described to me as
this as the most tense
period of the war for him because first
of all
something that i do not discuss in the
book but on told me quite often was he
had actually recommended against the tet
offensive to his superiors he believed
that
the south was not yet ripe and ready for
these mass uprisings but his reports
were rejected um according to on and uh
this is a sort of an interesting
historical point but why didn't you put
that in the book uh because i needed
more corroboration than just in this
case uh this was this would have been uh
there was no one else when i asked other
people in ahn's network about it they
said they couldn't recall that that
wasn't true and i just didn't feel
that was such an important point i
didn't want to use it so
uh
but on said it was a very tense period
for him because of course he knows this
attack is going to occur he makes
arrangements to evacuate his family to a
safe house he's really afraid that
there might be a lot of destruction but
also he's going to be responsible as
soon as the attacks occur for being time
magazine's man on the spot to explain to
everybody what the hell is going on and
what better source could you have than
the guy who would help plan the
infiltration
so what happened don't tell the story
well the mass this the the uh
uh a hundred thousand uh
vietcong uh and communist forces you
know enter into
vietnam vietnam uh the capital of
vietnam saigon but also cities all
throughout south vietnam in attempt to
create a mass uprising uh that will that
will give the communists this decisive
victory they had hoped to
to achieve uh but it didn't happen uh
and we now know of course that the
communists were
you know i mean their deaths and
their force levels were reduced quite
significantly it was a crippling blow to
them but it was a public relations coup
it was a coup because of two reasons
first of all
the invading vietcong forces had
actually got in very close to the
presidential palace the u.s embassy
there was gunfire in saigon
and the city that president johnson had
said with 550 000 american troops
vietnam is secure it turned out just the
opposite and that and very shortly after
that uh walter cronkite the dean of of
of of of the of us newsmen i think it's
appropriate way
uh
came on uh television and said basically
that uh uh the war war was a stalemate
he actually went to vietnam and this is
an historic broadcast where he said
sorry folks we can't win this right
exactly i
i should give readers uh another piece
of advice the best book on tent is by a
former colleague of mine don oberdorfer
it's got an easy title to remember it's
called tess
and it's a very good account of this
battle now i was struck by
the section in your book about this
where on
originally and what you've just told us
is puts this in interesting context his
initial reaction was whoops that didn't
work
and must have made him feel good if
indeed he'd recommend it against it
intellectually at least he he saw that
he'd been right but then tell what
happened next well what happens next is
very interesting he starts going around
to
all of the debriefings and starting to
listen to what both americans and south
vietnamese are saying uh and they
actually feel that
you know the gig's up basically you know
that uh
that there's even a there's even a great
concern that america will leave vietnam
that is american public opinion is
turning etc and his ears are wide open
he's picking up this growing anti-war
sentiment but he's also
picking up the idea that america is not
really ready to abandon vietnam and he
reports this back up to his his
superiors and these reports after tet
were really quite
significant because he tells his bosses
look we didn't really suffer a crushing
defeat
american public opinion is turning on
the war there's great doubt here amongst
the south vietnamese they're worried
that the americans are going to quit on
them and
so put this all into the balance sheet
and look at it as a great public
relations uh coup which it was uh for
the communism confirmed that reporting
or see it yourself
uh
which reporting uh on's reporting no i
did not see on's report i questioned on
extensively about it uh and
all of the unreceived and exploit medal
for this these contributions
and i did get it confirmed by four at
least four sources in in vietnam uh who
knew on that that was the essence of his
reports i might say that his reports to
this day are locked up in some vault in
hanoi and no one can get access to them
and i doubt there is no such thing as a
freedom of information or a foia act
that i can file in vietnam to request to
see the reports hopefully the day will
come
my role in this discussion is not to
give a book review
but let me just say one of my
frustrations is a very journalistic
frustration with the way you did this
is in the in the narrative storytelling
i always felt there was a very important
and mysterious
connection between
tet in july late january and the second
may offensive later the same year which
seemed to be a really fruitless hurling
of lives
to try again to cause some big
disruption but it didn't seem to me you
made it
persuasive or even
any connection between the two that
helped help me address my bafflement
about this do you have a theory about
what was going on there did on have a
theory well uh actually i think on
thought that those second attacks were
going to be uh were while they didn't
turn out again to have achieved anything
that the the the vietnamese
objective uh they contin
because during this period we have to
recall uh this is also the period where
lyndon you know lyndon johnson is going
to recuse himself from the race for the
presidency in april he was uh right
that's true right in april and this is a
period where the united states was
reaching out for some sort of peace
feelers and the like negotiated the
first possibility of a negotiated
settlement to the war from the
vietnamese perspective uh the offense
have made quite a bit of sense to just
keep the ball rolling to
and like but i raised it in the book for
a much different reason because this was
the one place i was able to question on
directly
about the his his hand or culpability or
actions in the deaths of american
reporters who were killed in the second
in the second uh period uh two of whom
were i believe one of them was a time
magazine uh chorus correspondent uh and
this is and the conversation that on and
i had about this i thought was the key
to the second tet for the book not
because i wasn't writing let's talk
about that that general
accusation i know some people have
complained to you that you haven't given
adequate weight to the fact that hans
activities contributed to the deaths of
americans
i'll tell you what i think about that in
a minute but
give us your sense of
how should we feel about the fact that
of course inevitably if you're helping
one side
that turned out to be the victorious
side in a difficult war
you're going to contribute to the
casualties on the losing side but it was
that is that how should how should that
fact affect anyone's assessment if arms
went on do you think yeah well i think
it's a stretch to say that on was
directly responsible for anyone's uh
lives he indirectly of course you can't
be the greatest strategic intelligent
agent of agent of the war
your campus believe you can't be
vietnam's super spy
and at the same time
say well the fact that so many uh
people died as a result of my reports i
you know i'm i'm free of that i mean i i
believe that on has an indirect
relationship to it all but just the same
as anyone sitting in our defense
department or any strategic agent
sending up reports even official reports
uh
would would have the same response
responsibility on of course says he
couldn't hurt anyone directly i believe
that's true i don't believe he ever you
know shot a rifle for example he didn't
he said he didn't know how to use a gun
uh but his gun was his you know his
reports uh and those reports had
consequences indirect consequences but
consequences none none nonetheless and
on and i
and on referred to these deaths of
course always as casualties of war and
then he would slam his foot his fist on
the table he as you know he was a man
who didn't get angry very often didn't
show a lot of emotions but he would
always say i was defending my country
against a half a million american
soldiers what did vietnam he was the
first person who ever said this to me
what did vietnam do to deserve
what the americans did to us because we
were a small country i was fighting to
defend my homeland wouldn't you do the
same and then he would just say let's
move on because this is not fruitful
because i was defending my home
you know i mean that was his answer
here's a question that occurred to me
would be good to ask in this context
do you think
that if pharmaceutical had not existed
and not been able to do what he did
that south vietnam could have survived
that the united states could have
prevailed in the war
oh i don't think the united states could
have prevailed in in the war the way we
were fighting the war um
i mean this is a it's a great question
but you know 550 000 american troops
uh massive bombing campaigns defoliation
agent orange an extraordinary logistical
setup
camron bay the greatest gift we gave to
the soviets
all of this
and we were no closer to achieving our
limited political objective
in 1968 or 69 or 1973 than we were in
1965 when the american escalation
started so i don't believe the
objectives as as and the strategy that
the united states was using could have
ever
achieved would ever achieve a beneficial
outcome so what difference would it have
made if if anne had married that girl in
california and never gone back to
vietnam how would history have been
different
well there wouldn't be a book called
perfect spy
to begin with but of course on wanted to
bring that girl back with him to uh to
uh to viet uh to vietnam and you know
i'm judge my question uh no i'm gonna
answer your question right now you know
on always said to me ano he said to me
uh do you know when i came back to
vietnam in 1959 if you had told me that
one day a half a million american
soldiers would be in this country i'd
say you're crazy i'd say you know we'd
have we'd have some sort of battle there
would be some sort of confrontation but
then the united states would back it off
i mean and realize that this is not no
this is not worth it
and then he would bring me into a
conversation about zm uh now to return
to your question i believe that uh
without a doubt
um had there been no fom soon on the
outcome of the war would have been the
same
but perhaps i believe on's contributions
expedited the outcome of the war
because of his reports in 1975 for which
he would earn his final exploit medal
because of course and i sort of actually
sort of like this answer to your
question which is i think it's going to
work which is
that
the communists believed that the war
that that really the americans uh their
final onslaught to saigon their their
unification to country would not occur
until 1976 77 even 1978 but it was on's
reports back saying that
detailing by the way according to on
watergate
nixon's resignation
the fact that the american b-52s were
not going to come back that they could
now expedite the timetable and move
forward i think that's where on's
reports expedited the end of the war and
the unification of vietnam let's quickly
recall what happened
for viewers the the
americans that essentially left the
country was still divided the south
vietnamese army actually on paper looked
pretty good uh kissinger and others
thought well maybe we'll have the decent
interval that we wanted but then what
happened
well what what what happened is that in
this country an anti-war congress begins
to defund the war
and the south vietnamese are basically
left on their own and of course uh
i
my own work in a previous book i wrote
no peace no honor which is nixon uh
kissinger and betrayal in vietnam is
about those paris negotiations and i
describe those the paris accord that
ended the war as a suicide pact because
it allowed the regular north vietnamese
army to remain in south vietnam in place
and just so viewers understand how many
people that is that's about 150 000
communist troops were allowed to remain
in the south pending free elections uh
and that those those never happened and
those allowing those troops to remain in
place uh really was the the slow death
knell for for south vietnam and by
1975 uh when it becomes apparent that
president ford the new president at the
time uh was his request for a
congressional supplement to support the
republic of vietnam was not going to be
passed
that was really it
your book reminded me of a
personal experience when i got back from
vietnam and i was very young i was about
27 when i returned from a year and a
half reporting in vietnam and one of my
best friends here in washington said to
me really interesting question at a
party somebody gave for us when we got
back
if you had been vietnamese of your age
he said
what would you have done here would you
become a vietcong or would you have
signed up with the south vietnamese
and it's a question i'd never thought
about
and in this social setting in washington
i said you know
i think i would have signed up with a
vietcong
and i think i would have lived to regret
it
in my position was
that that was the nationalistic impulse
why would you sign up with the people
that were fighting on the side of the
white-skinned foreigners
and yet i thought i
understand better than a lot of the
romantic vietnamese like on it turns out
it did this and it occurred to me
finishing your book that that's that
might have been what farm swan on would
have said
if he could have taken absolute truth
serum
that he did he did what he considered
the right thing till the end of his life
he considered it the right thing to sign
up with the vietnam against the french
and then against the americans and i
think americans have lost sight of the
fact that from a vietnamese perspective
it was one long war
the french were there they bowed out we
came in to take their place as you've
described in this conversation but it
was just it was one long struggle for
independence and unification in which
the enemy you know the white-skinned
european enemy
switched from god france to being called
the united states but it was a continuum
but i think on in the end as he
indicated to me in 1994 when we talked
and certainly as he indicated to you was
full of regrets about who these guys
turned out to be who were the winners
because they were uneducated they were
unworldly
they needed scapegoats as you indicated
earlier
they weren't good
peacemakers in the south and people like
ahn who found themselves mistrusted
because of their connections to the
americans during the war even though
he's the thrice decorated hero
they didn't fully trust him and never
gave him an important job or an
important role
uh
it's just it's an interesting irony to
me that that where it turned out well
not only didn't they trust him they sent
him off to one year of re-education or
up to a political institute to learn how
to think like a communist uh because he
had lived with americans so long they
felt he was much too american uh an
american boy soda so to speak now i i
asked alan that question if he had any
regrets uh and morley safer was the
first one to ask him in that book and
ann always answered of course without
truth serum he said no regrets because
this was for the vietnamese to determine
between themselves
and he said i he goes i hate the peace
is how he put it i hate the way things
are today in vietnam but i hated the war
more and we had to figure it out
ourselves the vietnamese not the
americans not the french not the
japanese who also occupied vietnam
because this was for us and this is what
the americans didn't understand uh and
and you paid a dear price for that your
country paid a dear price i i made a
note to myself to answer my own question
rhetorically that really
the story of pharm zwanan is is explains
why
uh we never could have won this war and
our our vietnamese never could have won
this war the fact that someone of his
quality his intelligence his human
qualities
felt that it was the natural and logical
and proper thing to do to sign up with
the vietnam in 1944
is really to me the most telling
evidence that we were just on the wrong
side we didn't understand it right and
as you know
families were divided too that is not
unusual i mean on his own brother you
know fought for the south uh uh
and was a arvind mechanic and who died
in the war and it was not unusual in
vietnam to have families uh just uh you
know two brothers on on the uh on the
communist side and two brothers fighting
for arvin and that's just the way it was
and that i think is a reason why the
vietnamese today have by and large
forgiven on that is the reconciliation
between our two countries is one thing
but the reconciliation with people like
pham soon on uh between vietnamese is
really i think a very interesting story
because the vietnamese understood better
than anyone the nature of their struggle
for independence what it was all about
and the lies and duplicities on both
sides and in the period of 30 years
since the war i think they've come to a
better understanding of this than a lot
of people in this country
it's a humbling fact too in my opinion
that if you could give a lot of the
south vietnamese truth serum who decided
to play on our team be on our side in
the war
for an explanation of why they made that
choice
for many of them i'm sure i know this i
feel i know this many of them would
would have had to say because i couldn't
imagine
vietnamese like us defeating the united
states of america i just assumed that
the winning side would have to be the
side the americans were on
a
good humbling lesson isn't that isn't
that interesting
on always felt and he probably told you
this also the biggest mistake the united
states spent in vietnam was not
if you just put the military aside first
it was in the training of a new
political our failure to train new
political leaders our our inability to
understand that the people that we were
latching onto had no legitimacy with the
people themselves and that as he said
and as i quote in the book you know all
these new roads all these new highways
all everything but the one thing we
haven't focused on was nurturing a new
political cadre of leadership that could
lead this
this republic of vietnam into the next
generation
you know someone who lived through this
at the time i couldn't agree more to
tell his wonderful anecdote about ho chi
minh the difference between ho chi minh
and the leaders in the south
oh
which one is that when on talks about
the connection that that hoe had
with little people you remember this
it's in here uh well
actually i don't i'm not recalling what
you're what the reference is important
there's there's some point where he says
look at how people reacted to hoe how
how
how people responded to him on a human
level that he was oh yes yes
that's where honest is explaining to me
that he's trying to grab get me to grasp
uh the difference between president two
and ho chi minh and uh and and from his
perspective it is that there was this
natural love and affinity that uh needed
no coercion and the we the way people
followed ho and he would often remind me
that something i knew uh but it's good
to be reminded of that ho chi minh had
written letters to president harry
truman in 1944 asking truman to support
the vietnamese struggle for independence
45. and to woodrow wilson in 1919 asking
the verse i recognized that's a good
example and and and asking president
truman uh why don't you treat us the
same way you are so beautiful so so
honorably uh recognizing the struggle in
the philippines and elsewhere but of
course vietnam was now emerging as a
part of the cold war as a cruci as
proceeds as a crucial domino uh within
the containment strategy and uh and so
it all sort of went for naught and then
of course ho did turn um almost
immediately to the soviet union the ally
that was waiting for him to turn
and uh the rest is history
the uh
i'd like to tell my favorite on story
it's not going to sell any books of
yours but it's a
i i i was he was such an impressive
person and you've captured this very
well he had this extraordinary poise
and equilibrium as a human being that he
very rarely got emotional about anything
in my experience you've referred to that
when i when i went back in 1984 1994 for
the first time in 24 years for me
personally it was a remarkable personal
odyssey i went with a wonderful
vietnamese journalist called vutui juan
who worked for the washington post
saigon bureau from 1966
until 1975. i'm happy to say he's now an
american citizen with three wonderful
american children and two wonderful
american grandchildren he came to work
at the washington post
after 75 and hawaii and his wife trying
had not been back to vietnam
from 75 to 94. i hadn't been back from
70 to 94. my wife and i and wang and
trung all went back together
and huang and i spent two long
evenings with on talking about
everything
which that's another wonderful gift that
on that he could as you've made clear
here could converse for hours and love
to do it
and i went into this conversation the
first of the two
uh
with a psychological need of my own i
realized later which was i was looking
for smart vietnamese
to
express
anger and hostility for the american
role
in prolonging the struggle for
independence killing so many people
doing so much
damage that you referred to earlier
and
and i could see that as i was fishing
for this from on
he got more and more exasperated with me
and finally he turned on me i quoted
this in the paper i didn't quote him by
name because at the time i thought i
could get him into trouble so here's
what i wrote in the washington post in
may 1994.
an old acquaintance from wartime saigon
a man who turned out to be a communist
agent who stayed behind to welcome the
revolution
offered a comforting explanation of the
ultimate outcome of the war
quote
you won world war iii he said to me
referring to the cold war
so you lost the skirmisher so what
so the vietnam war became a skirmish
went on in the bigger struggle in that
long view of the vietnamese take of the
struggle uh of history i would often say
to me when the berlin wall fell you know
you won and i put that in the
in the book
as well but of course it's sometimes i
would just tell on things are a little
more complex than that and he would say
well yes you paid a big big price but
you have to look at the big picture uh
the the big
the big picture
let me ask you the question that my
friend asked me in 1970
after knowing all that you've learned
knowing all you've learned in doing this
this book and the other books you've
done on vietnam
if you had been where's where on was in
1944 and the yet men had come to recruit
you do you think you would have resisted
them or would you have signed up to
i would always fight to defend my
country uh so that's my answer to that
and i i give uh two or three examples in
the book for that uh quoting wendy
larson uh who was at that time the wife
of john larson the uh the
the
time bureau chief of saigon and and also
ahn's friend many of his friends which
is uh on fought to defend his homeland
and the question comes back as frank
mccullough said said said to me and on
and to others in the book another time
magazine
if an army of 550 000 vietnamese invaded
california which is roughly the size of
vietnam wouldn't you fight to defend
your country that's what ahn did and
that's why i described him as a patriot
and a nationalist here there were many
patriots on both sides but the fact is
that it was a long and and terribly
destructive war with many lies on all
sides but the one thing that i don't
think
um people would really would really
debate was at the very beginning in the
struggle for vietnam independence and
nationalism i mean these were these were
patriots who joined who joined the fight
to save their country
we're running out of time one quick last
question is there some mystery for you
still that you'd like to
to know the answer to other well i think
on took uh several of the real
real big stories of his life with with
him he died in the in in september of
2006 at the age of of 70 79. i have been
fascinated by ahn's relationship with
the cia throughout the entire period of
the war
and i've had many people say to me you
know on could never have survived that
long without being protected and he had
to be working for more than one side
perhaps very low level supplying just
enough information and like and i would
like one day which is very doubtful i'll
ever know but i would love to to know
the full extent of von's contacts uh
with
members of the ci central intelligence
agency of course one of his dear friends
was william colby uh who was then the
bureau chief in 1959 station chief in in
saigon but eventually went on to become
the director of our
of the cia well we've got to end it
there thank you very much
go out and buy this book if you're
interested in the war in vietnam this
will be a treat thanks very much goodbye
[Music]
pete early explores the post-cold war
world of russian and american espionage
in comrade j the untold secrets of
russia's master spy in america after the
end of the cold war mr early focuses his
study on sergey trenikov or comrade jay
who oversaw russian spy operations
against the united states from 1995 to
2000.
mr trenikov who worked for the svr the
successor to the kgb defected to the
united states in 2000
pete earley and sergey trenikov talked
with peter earnest executive director of
the international spy museum
[Music]
pete earley the author of comrade jay
and sergey trechikov
the subject of comrade jay welcome to
both of you
thank you very much for being my guest
this morning our pleasure our pleasure i
would like to start with you pete this
is an extraordinary story
uh it is a story that is it is the most
up-to-date story we have had
of a
a
an intelligence officer
of uh sergey trechekov's rank
choosing to defect to the united states
and he tells an incredible story
and as i read the book which is quite
fascinating
one of the first things that happened
when you were approached about doing
this story was you said no you were not
interested
so i i think it would be interesting for
us to know
how did you become interested well i
became interested uh when i actually met
sergey i received i had done books about
the john walker spy case and about
audrey james the cia trader and
periodically i got calls from people
from the kgb saying oh i want to tell
you my life story and most of them
weren't very interesting and so i said
no i'm not interested i'm not interested
and then a friend of mine from the fbi
called and he said you need to meet this
person he didn't give me a name and so i
said okay and then it was very dramatic
i i they told me arrive at this place at
this time and when i got there two fbi
agents were there they took me up to a
suite where there were two cia agents
and in walks sergey and they i knew
instantly that he was somebody important
because i actually remembered his name
from when he defected and he was a
mystery he defected in 2000 and
disappeared off the grid and i knew he
was the highest ranking russian
intelligence officer to defect
and of course then as i spoke to him the
story got better and better
well you tell a fascinating story
let's turn to sergey fretchikoff
you
took an extraordinary step with your
life yes
uh you took an extraordinary risk with
your life
we're very fortunate to be with us today
we're very glad to have you
let me go back to
rather than go all the way back in your
life which i would like to do to an
extent
i would just like to ask you have now
lived
in the united states
since you came actually to
manhattan to be the number two ahead of
what would be the equivalent of a cia
station the resident tourer
you chose to defect in 2000 you've now
lived here
since that time so in almost 10 years
eight years
eight years two thousand i escaped
in october two thousand
yes october two thousand and
you have also since then become an
american citizen
two years ago uh we became american
citizens i mean
uh my wife my daughter and myself and
we're very proud and it was one of the
happiest days in our lives the story
of comrade jay which would have been
your name inside the inside the kgb
um
was comrade jean
john french yes and
you would have been a a and you depict
yourself
as an extraordinary loyal
very effective
kgb later svr svr officer that was the
successor organization
and yet
the story that you tell
is one of great great disillusionment
can you just in a few words give us a
sense of the nature of that
disillusionment because you had
everything going for him you were a
success story you had come in you had
been trained you had survived the sort
of vicious infighting that can take
place in the kgb later svr
and you were on the you were on the cusp
of becoming a general
and being a general in the kgb
uh is equivalent to having arrived it is
it is the sea it is the top position and
yet you became the solution what was
behind that disillusionment
first of all i was raised as a patriot
and when i chose to work for the kgb for
the russian intelligence it was it
wasn't the matter of money
it was the matter uh i wanted to serve
my country in the most effective way
and i thought that intelligence is one
of the uh of the best
opportunities
i had a skyrocketing career
for three years in the beginning of my
career i was the head of the young
communist league of the intelligence
i was a
captain at the time but my status was
off the left hand in general
i was always successful
and
people like me
usually don't defect
i never had any financial issues
problems
i was successful officer
definitely
if i returned back to russia i would be
general or even something more
that means that general or
with a very high position i was offered
many positions like this
and then i defected probably for my
former colleagues it's the main question
they're asking
what
drove this guy to the to to that
decision
uh
when i was the head of for example young
communist league consumer of the
intelligence
a lot of dramatic
events took place in the intelligence
people who were betrayed by
ames then hanson
were arrested and executed
and i attended
some trials on varovsky street
it's where they were trialled believe me
even for someone with good nervous
system
it's quite an experience
to attend this trials
they were all organized
to scare us
to show what will happen to you
if you defect or if you do something
wrong
it means in my particular case
i knew
what exactly awaits me in case of
failure
because all these people who were
executed they never had never was even
close to my position in the intelligence
but again it was a dramatic decision
we became dissolutions we i mean the
whole family
first of all my wife and myself because
daughter
my daughter was too young just to to
think about things like this at that
time
and to make this story short i decided
we decided to do something
finally to do something useful in our
lives
and not to serve
the people who call themselves a russian
government
and
who perform in my opinion the genocide
of russian people
of people who live in
in russia
and i had a choice to become part of
this genocidal team
or
to do something else
you know you you describe uh
going to the trials of uh
of uh kgb officers who were tried and
executed i'm thinking there's one
incident in your book
uh within a few pages where there were
in fact uh trials and executions of
three officers pigas off motorin and
polyakov
and
you were then i think about 29 years old
roughly yes and uh you described going
to a kg a dinner of other kgb officers
where the executions were announced when
the executions were announced
and everyone stood and applauded yes
um and i was among those who uploaded
but i and but i but i said but in the
book it's quite clear that that and you
say in one in one passage
that you realize that you were in an
organization where to succeed you had to
be a wolf
and so you would have just as sharper
teeth than anyone else absolutely but
having joined the the having been in the
young pioneers have been quite patriotic
you you were a true believer we used
that phrase a true believer what was it
like
then as you moved up the ranks
and you were exposed to this
incredibly
intimidating situation execution uh
everybody applauds and then you also and
this comes out so clearly in the book
the very vicious
infighting inside the kgb where people
would stab one another in the back
and and yet you still there were certain
people you trusted
but others that that you i mean it was
there were so many people you could not
trust i mean it was it sounds like a an
incredibly
almost gangster-like situation
yes
to some extent yes the life in kgb the
whole logic of kgb
it's quite difficult to understand for
westerners for americans
that organization was very cruel
towards the the population
but believe me this organization was
even much more cruel towards
towards their own representatives
like these executions
and i remember khrushchev who decised
not long ago he was the head at the time
of the first chief directorate of kgb
intelligence
uh he was very proud to announce like
uh traitor maturing executed and were
all standing and uploading
i uh
i uh
i'm rethinking this situation you know
and i was asking myself
uh
what i thought at that time when i was
applauding too
i knew mathurin he was a very nice guy
and i felt pity for him
he is a human guy
being he's a nice person
but i thought
yes it's the way to go
he betrayed
the organization he betrayed the country
and
you must understand how dramatic it was
to me to my family
to go
to become what we became
yes and i always
underlined that i never did it for money
i was never approached i had a very bad
reputation
i was never seduced
i was never bought
it was our
decision and i don't regret even for one
minute
that we started
doing what we what we did
let me just ask you uh peter lee
when you
met
uh sergey and and then you began
sat down to do your interviews
and you described something like 126
hours of tape interviews that you plus
just your normal conversation
did you have the sense
of a a man
with a great weight on him that was
being lifted what was your sense of
sergey the man i was you know i had done
interviews with john walker the spy the
naval officer who betrayed our country
i've done interviews with aldr james who
of course was responsible for cia deaths
and of course i went into this trying to
think how is he different how is he
going to be different and i remember
when i was in moscow and interviewed
general boris solomon who was perhaps
one of the greatest kgb cold warriors
who really attacked the united states it
was very
and he said there is no romance with
americans it's always the money and that
was the first thing that i saw was so
different about sergey he wasn't
interested in doing this for the money
he had
changed uh his whole attitude and he had
as he describes an allergy
towards the new russians who had come
into power he saw the corruption he saw
the greed he tells a story about one
officer who worked for him who was a
lousy officer who he wanted to get rid
of but he was just stealing so much
money for the people back in moscow they
were giving him awards this betrayed
everything but i think one of the most
telling things about sergei is he not
only helped us
he joined us he's a us citizen uh you
never saw walker you never saw ames you
never saw these kind of people saying i
want to live in russia you know i want
your money
but he it was not money and i think that
is a key
motivation into understanding him you
know there were many times when we'd
have conversations where i'd say sergey
trust me the united states is is not as
great as you think it is and he'd say oh
no no no trust me it is better than you
know it is having grown up here you're
spoiled you don't understand what it's
really like to live like i lived so this
this man not only
says he's put his life on the line but
he believes this and that was a distinct
difference and when people say oh you
know
walker ames sergey
they're they are not from the same mold
why don't we stay with that that subject
you've now
been here as a citizen you now are a
citizen
taken the pledge become an american
citizen you and your wife
you are now a daughter and your daughter
and you now have had an opportunity
to see america as they say warts and all
and you see the things that pete and i
could now sit down and complain about
you know whether it's that this this
election system that's now run for two
years and we still have no idea i mean
the british do it in six weeks takes us
two years but the other things the
problems with our economy uh the
inequities in in our in our system
in our in medical insurance uh
you know one of the great visions of
socialism of course was to have
universal medical care and that was that
was part of the vision that you bought
into as a young as a young soviet later
as a russian and now you see that we do
have inequities that is that is not
fair for everybody
so you've had a chance to get a
perspective
on your original vision of america as a
hope for you and representing a better
life do you still feel that way
absolutely
first of all there are no ideal
countries
i never idealized for example russian
american foreign policy
there are a lot of things in the society
like you mentioned them
which need to be improved
but my vision of americans and america
americans and america make
mistakes
but then
then
they
they correct them
then
they move forward then again they make
mistakes
but then they move forward
i always feel a progress
again with the understanding that i'm
not idealizing a lot of things which i i
can see in this country
by but still i think united states is
the main promoter of democracy and the
leader of the world
and uh for example if we
admit that i worked for
for american government
i would never work for any other gown
why
because this is the country which leads
the world
and it's my you know my it's my belief
sometimes pete
he is more skeptical
and uh
but it's it's it's
what we believe in the power of our
whole family peter one interesting thing
though is although
and this is a man who was a high-ranking
russian intelligence officer and i say
in the book that he worked for the cia
and the fbi for our country for many
years taking over 5 000 top secret
documents out he will still tell you and
he can correct me if he will correct me
if i'm wrong that he believes russian
intelligence is better
i i can't because i never worked in uh
in american intelligence but i uh assume
that according to the to the information
known to the public
russian intelligence was the most
effective
in the world
one of the reasons
first of all russian intelligence
was a rather cruel system
they were always pushing you to the edge
i remember in new york residency general
troubling came he was the head of the
intelligence
we were all gathered in this tea
intersection in the residency
and
he was talking about the what's going on
in the in the center
just informing us about the politics
with him
but then he says
colleagues please remember
if you are successful successful in
recruiting
you will have better apartment will
promote you will decorate you
but if it's a failure we'll crucify you
this is a very kgbs approach
and then we had a private conversation
and i asked him if he just loved
valencia there is no logic
because if you risk your life for the
country the country must you must have a
wall behind you
and he told me sergey you know you know
the system the same way as i i i know it
how it works
but uh in order to be successful in the
russian intelligence you must
achieve concrete results
concrete results recruitment
and russian intelligence
uh historically traditionally relies
upon mainly human intelligence
all these bugs satellites interception
it's good it's effective
but it's auxiliary
main have sources human sources
and
this is the whole
logic of the organization the school of
the organization
they teach you how to recruit
they want you to recruit people
and
sometimes
when i analyze some cases i thought oh
it's not possible no it's possible
when you start working you can achieve
amazing results
before you start work you think oh no no
no it's it's nonsense
we can't recruit someone like this
and then we start working and then you
see the result
it works
i i know that uh
among the operations and operational
activities that you were in charge of in
when you were in manhattan
uh was what we call covert action
and and that was in trying to promote
both dissension and unrest within the
united states to the extent you could
and
anti-americanism abroad to help give
america black i wonder if you could chat
a bit about that
uh
it's called ms
in russian
measures of support
before
it was called active measures
it was department a
in the uh in the russian intelligence
when
soviet union seems to exist
and people start thinking started
thinking that cold war is over
i know that american side was asking
russians
guys please stop these active measures
they're very embarrassing
uh russians agreed
and they changed the title from
department a department ms
same people
same mechanism same approach
nothing changed
and actually it's a very effective
mechanism and very cheap mechanism
to embarrass uh to embarrass other
countries
examples for example like
in europe
something something simple
if you have a source journalist or some
other sources
who can publish something like this for
example
mean americans
planted
nuclear devices on the territory of
of germany
in case of war if russian tanks
start advancing to europe
they'll blow this nuclear devices and
then they destroy russian military
machine but germany
with the russian military machine
and when information like this goes
uh to the circles of population
which are not that prepared to analyze
things
they start thinking oh americans there
be bad people instead
in the book there is example of nuclear
winter yes which was very embarrassing
for the for the united states
uh when uh soviet union seeks to exist
when kgb disappeared
when
svr took over all the functions of
former kgb abroad active matters became
believe me it was my job
more aggressive and more
numerous than it was during the search
well i don't know if we can quite
attribute it to the kgb svr but there is
a lot of anti-americanism now around the
world some of which we've brought on
ourselves but from what you say from
what you say
america remains a top priority a top
target within the sbr
both to
foster anti-americanism as well as to
create dissension within pete you had a
comment well one of the you're acting
asking about active measures one of the
things sergey talks about is how moscow
would send instructions to new york and
uh many of his officers would be
dispatched to the new york public
library to get onto the computer so
they'd hide their identity to just put
out reports and statements that would be
like 98 factual but have a little twist
in there a lot of them about chechnya
trying to turn public opinion and they'd
flood the internet with these that look
legitimate in hopes that someone would
pick up you know some little nugget uh
you know sergey talks about the end of
the cold war and and and
can you tell him about the target thing
i mean now
people uh ask me all the time what
changed after the cold war was over
who told you that cold war was ever over
in russian military doctrine soviet
military doctrine there was an official
definition of a main enemy
united states
nato
in
china in today's intelligence doctrine
there is definition of main targets
united states nato
and china
for me
uh the previous definition potential
main enemy is less aggressive
it's potential but when you are my main
target you are my main target right now
not potentially
it means even in theory nothing
changed even on on the level of of uh
doctrine you know
the other thing is
as you know in russian uh government
there are a lot of people with kgb
background
including president putin
we all have how they said
brains made in the same in the same
factory kgb factory yes kgb
and
traditionally
we never trusted
information from the mfa minister of
foreign affairs
not because it was bad information but
was open information the information
which you can get from the newspaper
we all trusted in intelligence
information
which was more
more secret more accurate
and that's why demand for the uh
intelligence information in today's
russian government
is uh probably higher than it was during
the soviet period
because not so many kgbs were in real
power at that time in russia
i remember
it was 2000 it was
august i think
the advanced team came
before putin's came to attend the
general assembly
and general muraf the head of the secret
russian fso equivalent of american
secret service
uh was instructed lavrov
and
he was by the way he was already drunk
at the time
but anyway he was telling him
please
i want to remind you that mr putin
relies upon information from these guys
support them and make their life as easy
as possible actually i never
had we never had any problems with
lavrov
we coexisted very peacefully very
productively
and i think that lavrov was never
offended
in his whole professional career like
that okay uh why don't we take a break
now and when we come back i'd like to
address the issue of one of a person you
considered one of the most important
reporting sources in the united states
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with pete earley sergey
tretikoff and peter earnest in a moment
as executive producer of the washington
journal i know that fewer calls are an
important part of our on-air programming
it's part of who we are we're committed
to opening up the phone lines so you can
talk directly to journalists elected
officials and other decision makers we
began taking calls during the 1980
presidential campaign which made us the
first nationwide daytime call-in program
on television and ever since then we've
been inviting viewers to call in speak
and be heard we take calls each morning
on the washington journal during our
coverage of congress on the campaign
trail after important speeches and as a
part of our key event coverage our aim
is to hear from many different points of
view from across the political spectrum
so if you ever thought about calling in
and put it off we invite you to call in
and talk about our topic of the day
the c-span networks
providing you access to public affairs
on television
radio
and on the web
[Music]
afterwards with pete early sergei
tretikov and peter earnest continues
welcome back sergey pete
i wanted to ask you uh sergey about what
is uh one of the perhaps one of the most
controversial things about the book and
that is your naming of a very prominent
american
strobe talbot a former senior editor for
time and the later of course uh the
deputy deputy uh
director of the deputy had the state
department here in washington
and you make it very clear in the book
that
you did not that you are not saying that
strobe talbot was a spy i think we
should make that very clear absolutely
but you do identify you use a term of
art and uh
an svr term of art as an unofficial
uh uh
source
unofficial special contact a special
contact now
as i read the relationship the the the
your comments on strobe talbot
he had discussions with mamadoff who was
his counterpart the deputy head of the
ministry of foreign affairs
and i would expect in the course of such
a relationship
that there would be confidence and
shared insights i mean part of
people speaking at that level is is not
to just give formal papers but to share
confidence insight how we go about
things
but i think the fact that
mommadoff was a an svr co-optee that is
he was cooperating with intelligence
therefore
the information from stobe talbot made
its way through intelligence channels
rather than mfa ministry of foreign
affairs channels therefore he carries
this
this term
an unofficial special or trusted contact
but but i think it will probably be
confusing for americans and you may want
to comment on this too one of the things
you should realize is it's not only is
he talking to someone who's a co-op team
okay
the svr is feeding that co-op t
questions to ask
and that's important to remember they're
saying when you get with this person
when you get with this high state
department official
try to turn the conversation this way
try to ask this specific question try to
get this information and that is
different than someone who represents
the state department i mean stro talbert
would not i assume would not have
allowed the cia to come to him and say
ask this question do this do that i'm
sure he felt independent from them and
that's not the way the russian was yeah
i understand the point you're making
what i would say though is
no i don't think strobe talbot would
sort of take a list of questions often
but i do think
that he would take uh that he would be
prepared to meet with a ci of say an
analyst or brief who said you know mr
talbot mr secretary um these are there
are a couple of issues we're very
concerned about and we would really
appreciate
learning any comments you make on this i
think he would take some questions from
cia you're going beyond my knowledge
there because i don't know how that
functions but i do know according to
sergey and he can address this himself
that the svr looked at strobe tablet and
thought here is another american here is
another westerner who's rushing in to
save russia and at that time the soviet
union collapsed it needed help but i
also think that what sergey said was the
attitude was
we can massage his ego we can play the
helpless the naive we can say we need
your help please and by doing that put
him off guard and try to use him and
manipulate him because this is not the
first westerner who's rushed in to save
you know russia sure well pete and i
have now both commented on what we think
you mean you tell us what you think we
mean first of all i never
called mr talbot a spy or
i think that he is an ardent american
patriot
and uh he was never my responsibility
uh but because of my position in this
entity i had access to some documents to
some files
where
strobe talbot was called special
unofficial contact
just mostly for curiosity i asked some
generals
how come
now why you consider him
such an important source of information
and then they explained to me that my
medev was used
uh to ask talbot specific questions of
course these two gentlemen as far as i
understand they developed a good
friendship
but you know it's my personal opinion
when you're in this high position when
you have access to top
secrets
friendship with a foreign counterpart
for me it's
it's uh sounds a little bit strange you
know
friendship is a good thing
but not when you uh represent your
country in official position
the only one thing i was told
that
the good thing for russians was that mr
talbot and mr mahmoud were had meetings
that attacked
no third person
present
and again
it's all i can tell you
uh
but again what that uh i want uh
to underline that mr talbot wasn't in
any way russian spy and you know one
thing that talbot was opening himself up
for
was that he doesn't know what the
russian is going back and saying
and it's quite possible and sergey was
often watching this with his own
officers that what was reported back may
have been highly exaggerated i mean we
ran into this with dobrynin and
kissinger and debates about that all the
time where the russian official would go
back and perhaps say things trying to
impress his bosses oh i got him to tell
me this advancing his own agenda so it's
just a bad situation when you get on
that one and one it would it would be
tricky and that's that's one of your
points absolutely
and you know people who were who worked
and who work in intelligence probably
they understand that sometimes we won't
look better than we are
i i know exactly what you're saying and
i think probably in some way we're all
guilty that that is i think a diplomat
an intelligence officer a journalist
perhaps
you know he wants his story his report
to to
look as good as it can and that he
succeeded in learning this or he
advanced
our country's goals by saying that so
there's there is that element i think in
almost all of us and i think when you
have a third party there that
makes you self-censor
and that's i think your point that's
things you might say
you know privately uh run can run risky
so let's take this case i think let's
take the case of strobe talbot uh and i
understand that mamadoff was a co-optee
would you you wouldn't have any way of
knowing that perhaps strobe talbot was
quite close to the intelligence folks
and was maybe maybe we wouldn't say call
him a co-opty but you know maybe he
accepted intelligence it's very possible
that
one thought that he's milking his
opponent okay the opponent was he oh i'm
doing great because i'm milking him you
know it's very very possible
uh and as you know in intelligence it
happens
when it
reaches the point uh this
dramatic conversation when i'm
recruiting you
i'm offering you something something
we both put something on the table
because you were thinking that you are
recruiting me
i was thinking that i was recruiting you
and we came to the same
it happens it's a paradox of sergey
tells a funny story about how they were
recruiting a german and one of the
points of this book that he makes is
that
many countries including nato will not
uh betray their own secrets but they're
happy to betray american secrets that
they feel like america is a superpower
it's an imperialist so even though we're
allies allies we will
and they get this german and they're
recruiting recruiting and he turns out
that he's an intelligence officer from
germany who's trying to recruit them
well i think
as we are both intelligence officers we
may have found ourselves in similar
positions
it was valuable yeah it can prove
valuable one of the things that struck
me was
you give such incredible insight into
the kgb into the kgb sbr and the
practices its approach to recruitment
and i i was uh
struck by the fact that you regarded
the u.n
as such a we have an expression in
america like shooting fish in a in a
barrel yes because you can't miss
and and so in the u.n you made the
statement here in the book you said if
one of my officers could not recruit
someone in the u.n what good was he
could you expand on that
uh
actually
u.n
is a very
good
place to recruit people
first of all the whole world
is is presented
but
it has a lot of drawbacks
i don't want to offend diplomats of any
kind
but sometimes they are not very
knowledgeable people
and a lot of people who work in un they
are more concentrated on things
we regret or we deplore how to put it
into this paragraph and they don't know
real secrets
that's why
we were trying to recruit people who had
access
to
internal documentation
those who could provide us with some
intelligence
not knowing real is the subject
but he can take something in his mission
and bring it to us
and we were capable to make our own
analysis
i
want to just stop briefly on basis of
recruitments the svr uses
there are four of them it used to be
ideological
philby was recruited yes on it
this basis doesn't exist anymore there
is no any more communism
this
base was replaced with political base of
recruitment to make it look simple
anti-american feelings yeah
when you go to some european countries
if you go to some middle middle east
countries they
a lot of people as you know don't like
america and they are ready to cooperate
with the svr because they don't like
america
second basis moral psychological
it's black mailing
we had a kind of
unwritten understanding between
uh russians and americans not to to
abuse this base of recruitment
because we have hostages both of us
something you are blackmailing me
but there are american diplomats in
moscow
who could be blackmailed too
but it basic exists
third bases the most the most the
easiest to understand financial
my money your information
and the fourth it was my first i first
introduced it by the way
it's business base of recruitment when
we create for our source
i
i don't like the word word spy
spies is justice for for for novels you
know
when we create for a source
business opportunities in russia
legal
personal works in the person works in
russia
nothing wrong with it
he pays taxes
the business is legal
but with the understanding that this
business was created by the fsb
and uh
again u.n
the
in many recruitments there is
combination of different bases elements
from
in un the most effective was political
base of recruitment antibodies
in canada he used this and it's
interesting setting up a business in
russia legitimized as you know the
hardest part is paying and meeting with
your person in your host country so
imagine if you had
someone who you recruited united states
and you set up a business form how easy
it is to fly there on this business get
legitimate payments and we don't have
any idea what a widget is worth there so
if they got inflated prices you bring it
back you know it's it's a good it makes
it much tougher to catch someone
and it sounds less even less suspicious
than being a consultant where you can't
wear it's knowledge whereas you're
saying it's a it's a business this is
something there's widgets or something
being sold and it's it's legitimate yes
i'm i'm not hiding that i'm working i
have my enterprise in russia
i'm paying taxes
nothing wrong with it and you were the
first to think of this in the svr and
were actually uh recognized for it it
was it was the first
joint venture between
svr and fsk at that time
uh
then
they changed the name to fsb yeah be
like fbi and cia internal nxt yeah and
was this i spent
several months
literally
in the fsb
dealing with
mr gominuke and mr balenko there were
two
senior officers working in the north
american department
of of of
fsb
we were just planning the operation and
the most important thing it was to find
good people to perform the operation
and it was disaster
a disaster why because uh these
counterintelligence officers they are
different from us
they are you know
they use force they they work on the
territory yeah they can be pushy and
they needed someone more
you know
finally
we found a
a candidate which wasn't good
but anyway they told me enough is enough
you must pick one and
you know uh i would like to just touch
on another couple of things that the
book is
extraordinarily interesting but you do
touch on some of the very well-known
cases
of of recent years and one of them is is
uh colonel yurchenko
who of course uh defected to this uh
appeared to defect to this country
and then redefect it and and one of the
most frequent questions that i get asked
at the museum is
was colonel yarchenko a genuine defector
or not and you do touch on the case from
your end of it and i think your comments
would be fascinating
uh
actually it was i think it was 85
85 yes i just joined the american
department i was a young starting
officer and
i thought that i won't survive more than
six months in this department because
the people were
so bright
you know and i thought that i'll never
be someone like them
and then i had a first assignment
to write
an article
for
for internal magazine
called raziaczyk intelligence officer
about hero name would name yurchenko
he just returned back
from he escaped then returned back to
the service
and i asked can you interview him little
no you cannot but you must write the the
article
uh
the russian hero how come you're an
intelligence officer
figure it out you know
i wrote this article of course no no
concrete facts because i had no idea
what he did
i i just knew that what was his position
he was deputy head of the american
department
deputy to famous russian intelligence
general yakuzkin probably you somehow
heard the name
and i wrote this
this article and then the
one senior guy he told me
thank you mr tredikov that you wrote
this article then we'll send this
article to the personnel department and
we'll attach you
this article
to your personal dose here it's it's the
end of your career
why
i don't know why
because you are in idiot
you're is it the fact he is not a hero
it means that they were still thinking
how to present the case
and i'm sorry and the paradox is that
eureka was decorated
they assigned him to near to a research
institute where he had no access to any
secrets
but officially he was given the
uh the very high internal decoration he
became the honorable czechist
that's
another you know yes an honorable member
of the organization
and they did it in order to uh to hide
what happened in reality of course he
defected
i don't know what happened to him then
probably he wasn't treated properly i
don't know
but when i finally met him briefly
he produced
on me a very strange impression
probably he wasn't totally sane
i know one thing that he was finding
every other week terminal illnesses with
himself
all kinds you know he was reading me
medical encyclopedia oh i have this i'll
die and
this is the this is what i know about
the keys then i met him many many times
just in the corridors
you had a comment
well this is what's so fascinating about
espionage as you know it's that
wilderness of mirrors and believing is
this person a defector is he not when i
did the walker book i had people say to
me oh john walker didn't really betray
his country in a few years they're going
to release him to russia and he's going
to be a double agent and you know i mean
you can come up with any kind of
nonsense and the question is how do you
verify it and with this case you know i
talked to americans i talked to ames
about yachinka i talked to russians
about him and i don't know of anyone who
dealt with him personally who believed
he wasn't a genuine defector but you'll
still have people who will see
you know and you know angleton's famous
for seeing all these things and people
defending it back and forth well we read
a lot of novels and we see a lot of
movies but but my question back to you
though is
um
so you were regarded as an idiot for
writing your article however
here is
uh yuchenko who's
clearly they understand that he did
defect he was not a hero
and yet
he was decorated and and uh and
everybody you know he was not he was not
he did not get the the uh treatment that
pugh chef and mother and uh
um
they can't answer this question i heard
krutchkov
uh he put it this way i tried to find
polite words
yurchenko
was in a deep
bad substance
but he managed to get out of this bad
substance by himself
he came back right yes he was the deep
something you know but he managed to
come back
any defection
is not
something the intelligence service
is proud of it's a failure it's a major
major major failure
then in russia
then and now
uh
you know sometimes i envy uh american
bureaucrats whatever happens nothing
happens to have to them
you did a hell of a job you know
something like that in russia no
if there is a failure it means some
people must be
sacrificed somebody must be punished
absolutely
that's why when you reach some high
position you always think when you sign
a document
because if something goes wrong
do you think uh who authorized this
particular operation or well in the case
of your checker
you spell out very clearly in your book
uh that general yakushin was forced to
resign
uh not because hirochenko and the others
maturin and okay and the others the
others and the they told that
american
department of the svr
and the american branch not only
not only
geographical political intelligence but
science and technology became the nest
of spies
and they needed they needed a
scapegoat
someone must must be sacrificed
but again with the humchenko it wasn't
that simple
uh first of all yurchenko was not
supposed to go abroad at all
because he worked in the department
of internal security
period these people they have they
cannot leave the country
till they die you know
they they are not authorized
it was an exception
who approved this exception khrushchev
himself
it means to make a loud
case
from you it means khrushco would expose
himself
yes
that's why in many cases uh there are no
much
waves
because too many high-ranking people
were involved in the case
and if they start
making waves they expose it themselves
there was also the the sense and of
course you you know the ames case very
well there was also a sense in american
intelligence that
that yurchenko was
was not punished in order to conceal
ames who was a new reporting source to
the sbo they did not want to
reveal what they knew what ames might
have reported and therefore yuchenko was
recognized as a hero
uh
it's possible
but you know they executed so many
people yes
after uh and uh i always ask myself a
question how unprofessional was it
to start killing people immediately
the death row for uh intelligence
officer was like four six
months maximum it's not like in the
united states people die of natural
causes
in jail yes and uh it was a kind of uh
in my opinion very unprofessional
because they exposed by the fact that
resources that they at least they knew
that uh that there they were sources
somewhere
in the american intelligence community i
i think just as a final note before we
close
are you are you at all optimistic about
what is going on in russia now
no what is your comment i mean and this
is because you used the word when we
first began talking that you escaped
and do you still have that sense that
about the situation in russia
uh that is something to escape from
it's not
even
the matter of who is in charge putin or
medvedev who will replace putin and
putin will replace medvedev i think it's
a pathetic uh very
stupid game you know everyone
understands
what's going on in the rail to that
putin wants to stay in power in any way
the whole system
uh how they run the country is is evil
it's based on wrong principles
they don't think about the uh well-being
of russian russian people they always
repeat that they have tremendous social
programs
uh whatever
go to russia i have a russian satellite
dish
i'm watching russian tv
moscow saint petersburg probably some
more few places the rest is 17th century
people don't have running water
uh in one estimates i heard that there
are
productive population in russia not more
than 17 million
other either
too old or
chronic drugs
who improve this situation
where is the improvement and at the same
time and it's for me it's disgusting
how uh
there's not the best people
spending
thousands millions
in a very tasteful
way you know
i always compare like mr barth i don't
know
american billionaires
they all
help the society they donate their money
they live very modest lives by the way
i think that buffett is still driving an
old volvo and something like that i read
it somewhere yes
because he is a good
he is a good citizen
those who are running the the country
you know uh it's not an exaggeration
when i had to shake hands with these
people i was rushing all the time to the
men's room to clean my hands
well
sergey tracikov peterlee thank you very
much for being with us today absolutely
fascinating account and i'm looking for
volume two because we did not really
touch on
uh the relationship
uh the fact that that sergey had chosen
early on
uh to seek to seek a new life here right
and his work with the ci and fbi so i
i'm looking for you to sit down and do
another volume two of your book thank
you so much for being with us thank you
thank you